It's 1230.
Good morning everybody.
I'm still waking up guys.
I don't know why I'm playing Castu right now.
I'm not even gonna be playing DPS.
Guys I'm sorry I'm still... my brain is still waking up.
I can never do 1230 streams cuz my brain is always waking up.
I don't even know if the sound volume is okay.
Is my sound guy here?
Is he here?
Let me make sure my sound is like not too loud.
Let's see.
Look at this like gold gun.
Okay guys I might have like click baited you guys cuz I'm...
Okay to be fair it is Masters rank but it doesn't mean this account is Masters.
It just means that I... I will get... I'll definitely get into Master Games.
I just... this account might not be Masters but the player base is not as high as it once was.
That like there is a potential that I'll get into Masters games because one... one I found out I found out that like uh not today like recently that like uh Masters 5 is uh...
also I don't know if it's too loud.
I can't tell.
Masters 5 is the threshold for support to hit top 500 and I heard a lot of players are like sort of low-key hard stuff Masters at the moment which like streams and a lot of players are like in Masters like a lot of like the good players I used to know back then are like in the Masters elo at the moment.
I was like what the fuck...
I was like, damn, okay.
And then so I was like, oh shit, wait, I'm gonna be griefing top 500 players?
Shit, okay, wait.
Cause I was like, okay, I do have an account that has Grandmaster MMR, but like obviously I'm not gonna be playing on that account.
Because I used to be good, hence the word, hence the past tense.
But now I've been playing like other games, like Bunny Garden and shit like that.
So like, I don't know how like Bunny Garden and Flight Simulator, so like I don't know how well that translates back to Overwatch these days.
So I was just like, um, so I was like, okay, maybe I shouldn't play on the Grandmaster account.
And I was like, alright, maybe I should do something that has a Master's MMR.
At first I was like, alright, I'm just gonna rank up this account to Master's and just go from there.
But this is my main account, by the way.
I haven't touched this main- I haven't touched the main account in fucking years with rank.
So because of that, they had a hard reset in rank from over- they had a hard reset from like Overwatch 1 to Overwatch 2.
Um, I mean like, it's not like super- okay, maybe not a hard reset, a soft reset.
Uh, but I mean like, it's not like super- okay, maybe not a hard reset, a soft reset.
But, so like, I did placements on this account.
And then, um...
I did placements on this account.
And then I did, uh, I- Yes, this is the Overwatch 1 account.
So like, this- this is actually- this is actually like the main main account.
And I was like, usually in the past I would be like, oh, I don't want to tape this account.
Because, uh, this account is so sacred.
It has like, you know, it has these.
It has all of these sprays, you know?
Oh my god, look at that.
You can tell it's the main account because it animates!
Whoa!
The sprays are animated!
Holy shit!
Look at that!
The sprays!
They move!
So, for those who are not familiar with the Overwatch rating system, the spray moves because I'm- I was top 500.
So you get a moving spray.
So...
So I was like, usually in the past, past Doki would be like, no, don't tape this account.
Because- because that's your top 500 account.
Don't play on it.
But like, all my top 500 records have been fucking erased.
Because they erased Overwatch 1 top 500 leaderboards.
So it doesn't matter anymore.
It doesn't matter anymore.
I don't- I don't care.
I didn't get top 500 in Overwatch 2 on this account.
I did it on a- I did it on a brand new account.
So like, this account doesn't have the Overwatch 2 top 500.
So it doesn't matter to me.
Plastic, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Are you playing in flats right now?
What's the flats right now?
I don't watch.
I don't watch flats.
I'm sorry.
Thank you for the soup!
Magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
I know flats back when he used to grind Overwatch rank.
I bumped into him a lot in Overwatch rank.
But I don't watch his YouTube content.
Because his YouTube content- he's like- okay.
Like, the reason- flats is really good at gaming the algorithm.
And like, um, making videos that like, um, majority of the Overwatch players like to watch.
But like, I'm not majority.
I'm like the majority of the Overwatch players.
I just watch rank.
Like, I don't care.
I- I- I- right.
And also like, these days, I don't even really watch Overwatch rank streams.
And I only watch like, uh...
I only watch like, Surefour playing rank.
Because I think it's funny when he loses.
I'm not like other girls.
I- I just watch Surefour play Overwatch rank.
Because I just think it's funny.
And I guess like, Ruben too sometimes.
Uh, because he's a friend.
Um...
I don't think Soundguy is awake, guys.
Soundguy is not as awake as me.
So how has the- how- how has the sound been?
Uh, chat.
Yeah, I think that's like the only Overwatch content I've been watching the last couple of months.
Like, it's literally just Surefour mostly.
Um...
I'm like trying to think.
Have I watched anybody else?
I mean, I watched like...
Like, I guess like ten- like five minutes of Aspen.
Because I was like, what the fuck's meta?
I was like, she's a support player.
Like...
I was like, I was like, alright, let's see what's meta.
Okay, I need- I need to know what support meta is.
And then I was just like, alright, Aspen's a support player.
This is the best way to figure it out.
Watch the- watch the support player to see what meta is.
Call that a fair play.
But I haven't like actually watched Overwatch content.
I think like by the time Flats became an Overwatch content creator, I've stopped watching Overwatch.
Because I used to watch Overwatch content.
But like, I'm like- but that was like past Doki.
Very, very past Doki.
Also, you might be like, oh my god, Doki, why is your name on the left side Kitsune?
Um...
They have like a streamer mode now where your name changes every game.
Thank fucking god for that.
Because that actually is a lifesaver.
Because like, uh...
I- I was like a little bit embar- okay.
No, okay, this is also the reason why I stopped caring about like my rank on this account.
Because like, there's streamer mode now.
So then I was just like- and it changes every game.
So every game, um, your name changes on the bottom left.
Which is a fucking lifesaver.
Especially if I have a private profile.
So they'll never know that's me.
Uh, but like, I was a little embarrassed in Diamond ELO.
I was- I was- I was- I was a little- I was- I was a little embarrassed being- just a little bit embarrassed being Diamond ELO on this account.
So I had- I was like, oh, they must never know.
They must never know.
Um, no way you're actually good in video game.
I was good in video games.
We don't know anymore, no.
We don't- we don't know anymore.
Alright.
Um, let me ask like an- wait, is my- are any of my mods on?
That's a good question.
Wait, are any of my mods on?
What do you mean it was?
Okay, there's a reason why I didn't-.
I am on streamer mode.
I am a bit embarrassed.
Also, like, uh, Ruben asked if we wanted to do- I'm gonna play a couple of solo games first.
And then if I- if I derank, cause I'm actually like on the line between Diamond 1 and Diamond 2.
So like, if we- I won't join voice though.
I won't join voice call.
But if we derank, we're calling in reinforcements.
Which is like- so we have like- We have three games at least of solo.
We have three games of solo at least, okay?
So...
So that'll be- we're gonna try our best.
So yeah, anyway, we're gonna be queuing support, D1 support.
And then if we get to Masters, then yippee.
Uh, but anyway, you're gonna see what I mean.
Regardless of what rank I am at the moment, because I'm in D1, I will automatically-.
Not automatically, but majority of the time I'll be in Master games.
So like, in the end, I will throw- I will fucking get somebody out of top 500.
If it's- And that's all that matters, chat.
That's all that matters.
We're not playing Cassidy.
I just like- I just like warming up and...
Uh, like I just like the sound and hitting the headshots in uh...
In the training range on Cassidy.
Cause it's not as fun on any other character.
It's only on- It's only fun on Cassidy.
Um...
Alright, let's see.
I think my- I have like a backup sound guy, right?
Uhhhh...
Hahaha!
Alright.
I have a backup sound guy, so I'm gonna check.
Also like, next week- By the way guys, next week- Uh, I tweeted about it, but next week- I said next week like five times.
Uh, I know I said that we're gonna have a rest week.
But like, it might not end up being a rest week.
Because there's a lot of stuff going on next week.
Hahaha!
There's- There's a- You'll find out when the schedule fucking drops.
Cause I'm still or- I'm still like figuring stuff out.
But you guys- You guys will see when the...
Uh, when the schedule drops and then you'll see why.
Hahaha!
You'll see- You'll see why.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Why do I hear myself?
Do I have a stream up?
Oh my god.
Where's the stream?
Oh fuck.
Okay, sorry.
Sorry guys.
I had a- I had my own stream open.
And I was like, what the fuck?
Who is that bitch?
Hahaha!
I'm really feeling the heat!
The voices!
Okay, here we go.
We're- We're gonna start.
Alright.
Uh, so yeah.
I am going to- Alright guys.
I'm- I'm a little embarrassed of showing you my- my profile right now.
So I'm gonna- I'm gonna change my icon as well.
Hahaha!
I just need you guys to know.
I have really- some really rough games while trying to- trying to see if I can speedrun the masters.
And like I- I had some- I had- but you can- this is the main account.
Haha!
So these are all the icons I have.
So- Hahaha!
Hahaha!
I'm just saying.
I got like a little embarrassed.
I'm- Okay look.
I'm also like a- look see?
It changes every time.
Guys.
In the name.
So like, I got- Okay.
So the reason why I- I'm a little embarrassed is that, um, thank God I'm private profile.
But like, anyway.
Uh, haha!
Thank God it's- Thank God it- This is when I used to be good.
Hahaha!
So you get- These are all the top 500 icons.
So like this is when I was- I used to be decent at the game.
And- Hahaha!
And- And this is what I was complaining about.
Like you see the icon that used to be really pretty.
And then they started being just guns.
And I was like this is so ugly.
And then it was like so tiny too.
This used to be like the top 500 icon in season 24.
And I was like this is so ugly.
Compared to like this.
This was like actually so pretty to have.
And then- And then later on they're like oh we should add the top 500 icon logo.
So people would know it's top 500.
So like at first there was no top 500 icon logo.
But it's just a golden gun.
And it was so fucking ugly.
And then- Yeah.
I miss when top 500 icons used to look good.
And now they just use- And now it's just like the tag.
The gamer tag.
Which was only available for like one season or something.
Um...
Yeah so like they had to make a lot of them that they ran out of maps.
Which is understandable.
You know?
They actually ran out of maps for the top 500 icon.
Hahaha!
And back then top 500 was actually hard to get guys.
Okay?
Back then top 500 was hard to get.
Cause there was an actual player base chat.
So you can't say that.
It was actually pretty difficult.
Cause it wasn't masters.
Hahaha!
It was- It wasn't masters.
It was- Hahaha!
Anyway.
So like the reason- Another reason why I am uh...
Uh...
The reason why that like uh...
I am a little embarrassed of showing my profile at the moment.
Is because the most played hours on it is Kiriko.
But I have a solid 30% win rate on Kiriko at the moment.
Because I- Every time we're losing I just swap to Kiriko.
Hahaha!
I had to play Kiriko for like you know- Okay cause like- There- Okay because- But because it's like- Well I- We're losing I might as well practice Kiriko.
You know?
Hahaha!
That's like- That's like my mindset going in.
I'm like well we're losing anyway.
So I think it's like a good time to practice.
Hahaha!
So that's like- Hahaha!
Like it's a- It's a good time to practice her.
Since like she is meta.
So I might as well.
But I do play Kiriko sometimes when I don't- When I'm not losing.
So like the moments when I win on Kiriko is when I like- Is when like I automatically- I pick her out of like first hand.
Not because like you know I was- Why is there a- What the fuck?
How many fucking- Okay this is why I need to warm up.
Oh my god I missed like 20 shots.
It's cause they're not training bots.
So like it was- It's- Oh the fall off damage too.
That's insane.
Where are they?
I hear them.
I hear you!
Oh okay.
Nice.
Hahaha!
So what do you usually play?
I like- I like Ana.
Ana is like the most fun.
But then Ana also requires aim.
Which like I don't know if I have right now.
Cause I'm still- I'm still waking up guys.
Like- Please Vera let me have this warm- Oh!
This is bullshit.
I don't know if I have the aim at the moment for Ana cause I'm still warming up.
This is different.
They're not training dummies.
They actually move.
They actually- These people move.
Nice I'll take that.
Jesus Christ the fall off.
There you go.
They're not like training dummies where I can- Where I know the pattern of their movements.
These people actually have strafe patterns.
Hello?
Where people at?
Oh!
Please.
Please be nice.
Okay thank you.
Killing the AFK.
That's right.
I gotta take what I can get guys.
I'm that desperate.
The fuck is this?
Look at that Cassie fall off damage.
Holy- No bro!
Respect the 1v1!
Okay we're gonna bring- Alright we're AFKing now too.
We gotta bring down the game volume a little bit.
Alright I brought it down.
Let me know if it's better.
Sound guy.
Alright.
Yeah exact.
Oh my God please.
You guys didn't see anything.
No!
No bitch get out!
Oh my God.
Please.
I'm so lucky.
Oh my God.
I swear guys.
If it was not 1230- I swear if it was not 1252 I hits those.
Guys.
I'm just saying.
You should see me.
I swear in NiteQs, okay?
In NiteQs is where I shine.
I swear in NiteQs is where I shine!
I hit so many shots in NiteQs!
I swear to God I'm not fucking with you guys!
I'm not coping!
You should see me in Death Master in NiteQs!
I swear!
It's just, look, things are rough right now.
So I brought down the sound volume by the way, sound guy.
It's just rough.
It's just rough at the moment.
I swear!
The moment we hit the NiteQ time hours...
I'll be like...
Bop bop!
Headshot, headshot!
It's just, we're at a rough place.
I know I say that and I should definitely not play Ana right now.
I should not!
Have mercy!
I just woke up!
Breezy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Please!
It's just a little rough.
Look, see it changes.
The name changes and everything.
That's why I'm like, I'm okay with...
Copium in its natural habitat.
Please thank you for the super chat.
It's not copium!
It's a scientific fact!
Look, see I hit those!
Okay, we don't hit those but it's because he was strafing.
So like, I got confused, you know?
You know, and like...
Oh my gosh.
Oh shit!
Oh, I fucking might die though!
I told you I hit those!
Bitch!
Oh, you see I hit both tracer shots too!
You guys didn't believe me.
I'm slowly waking up.
This is me in my natural habitat!
There, nobody believed me until I did a fucking sick-ass shot on the tracer.
There we go.
Oh, that's not my fault.
If you die, we have a Kiriko.
We also have a Kiriko.
That is not my fault.
Please get rid of this fucking tracer!
Holy shit!
Am I the only one that hits the tracer?
It's okay, we get like...
We get like three free games.
And then if we derank, we'll call in the reinforcements.
Oh god.
I think I might go Zen actually.
You know what?
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm believing you!
And he's anti!
Okay.
Bro, okay.
Come on.
Alright, we're gonna help save our fucking junker real fast.
WAH!
Okay, never save your junker.
Never save your junker.
Okay.
I'm gonna go Zenyatta.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
This will work, I swear.
Never.
I have the most healing!
You guys cannot be like, Doki, heal your teammates!
I literally have the most healing out of both teams!
Like, look at that!
He's so scared of me now!
Look at him!
He's so fucking scared!
Okay, there we go.
Alright, we don't have cleanse.
We're so fucked.
I... I...
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
There you go.
Fuck you.
Never say...
Never say I'm washed.
I'm running away.
This junker has ult.
This junker 100% has ult.
Never say I'm washed again!
Bam!
That's when you know!
Just chase your things.
Alright, here we go.
Okay, our Soldier fucking sucks.
Bro.
If I'm not afraid of getting banned, I would... I would say something.
Cause they're like apparently really harsh on bans now for toxicity.
So I gotta... I gotta make sure I don't say anything on chat.
Apparently they're actually like banning people for shit.
When it comes to toxicity.
Like even you say something like, bro fucking do be better at DPS.
Like what the fuck.
You can actually get banned for it.
You get chat banned.
I've been seeing like... like the... it's like a lot harsher now.
The moderating of the...
I heard like the... the... the Overwatch...
2-4...
Oh, yeah.
You are Kiri.
And you over extend.
Oh my god.
The shit talking are Kiri because they don't heal.
Okay.
Alright, I'm gonna go more.
Your place is where I can't heal you.
I told you it's not me.
Alright.
But like...
But like, yeah.
What was I saying?
Yeah.
The...
They like ban... chat ban you or like actually straight up ban you.
Like a lot easily.
So like you say something that is any remotely toxic at all.
You can actually get banned.
And I'm like... I don't...
No!
Okay.
I grieved there.
Alright.
Guys.
I will admit I actually grieved.
I actually grieved.
I was not paying attention.
I was looking at my chat.
Oops.
It's okay.
We can get this back.
It's... I can have one...
I can have one game where I don't play perfectly.
Like... Come on.
I mean this is like the first fight where I don't play perfectly.
It's literally the first fight.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm healing you.
I'm doing my job.
Okay.
Poor Soldier.
That poor fucking guy.
Alright.
Here we go.
There.
Look at that.
Look at my skill.
Look.
This was obviously not winnable.
Not gonna lie.
It would not matter if I play like the best game of my life.
These...
They're... They're like... Yeah.
This... This team is not salvageable.
It's not salvageable at all.
Alright.
Where... Where is...
She recalls here.
She blinks here.
Hello.
Thank you.
Soldier!
Are you... Okay.
I was gonna say.
Soldier, please.
So... Are you serious?
And then you flip it?
Okay.
Alright.
This is...
This is a little...
This is a little tilting.
He actually let it flip.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Look at him run.
There.
We flipped it back.
We didn't even...
Oh my god.
We literally got the point for 8%.
Come on.
Bro.
You're full healed.
Look.
I played a almost perfect game.
Chat.
Like...
Whoops.
Okay.
It was almost perfect.
Guys.
But I know damn well these guys are not playing any perfect...
These guys are definitely far from perfect.
Oh my...
Oh my god.
They fucking gone.
Look.
This is top 500 reaction time right there.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
That's right.
Top 500 reaction time.
How did I live?
I shifted.
You can shift in alt form now.
Which is great.
That's...
That makes me very happy.
But yeah.
You can shift in alt form.
Yeah.
That's right.
Look at that fucking reflexes.
They definitely have junker ult.
So I'm both gonna save my Q...
My shift.
Uh.
See.
I need to charge up my fucking Q too.
It's been working.
Will you be okay...
She's not gonna be okay.
I TOLD YOU.
IT'S NOT MY FUN!!
I SWIFT It doesn't matter.
It doesn't fucking matter.
A team will be dead no matter what.
I'm not playing Ana because like...
This team does not deserve my Ana.
I'm not gonna play this.
Especially this fucking venture.
Like, nothing will save this venture no matter what hero I play.
Go Life Weaver?
No.
Life Weaver... I still don't know how to play it.
Because Life Weaver was locked for the longest time until they were like, we're gonna make every hero free.
But like... but like I actually do not know how to play Life Weaver.
Please!
Holy shit!
We don't deserve to win this.
Oh my god.
Please!
How do you have nine deaths?
5200 heal!
That's insane!
Oh my god!
Bro!
Oh yeah!
The one that's not getting flamed is definitely throwing.
They were flaming the fucking... You cannot blame me for the loss.
Because I... I have the most healing.
Out of two teams I have the most healing.
Ok, we have like one more game to like... protect our...
Protect our hero.
And then I'll call in reinforcements.
Oh my god.
If the games get more rough I'll call in reinforcements.
You're the support they always be.
Yes!
But like... I wasn't the problem.
Guys.
Guys, you can't blame me when I'm not the problem.
Oh my god, I almost fucking...
What the fuck?!
What?!
He fucking flicked me!
Holy shit, the fucking turret bait!
That's actually crazy.
The turret bait.
There we go.
Watch that.
Look at that flick.
Guys.
Look at that fucking flick.
Oh.
Guys, his strafe pattern!
His strafe pattern!
I couldn't download it in time!
I couldn't!
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh, I hear him.
There we go.
Look at that.
I should have done the cool kais.
Don't look at...
Oh, you see that headshot?!
You see that?!
That's fucking right.
That's right!
My first headshot of the day!
Oh god.
Oh, nevermind.
That's her...
That's her 20th headshot of the day.
Guys, this helps me warm up.
Okay, I need this.
Okay, guys.
Thank you for the shot.
Ooh, a reaper!
You know what?
Maybe that will hit somebody.
Come on, Junkrat.
Oh god.
Guys, never go inside a tight corridor with a Junkrat.
Oh!
We did it!
See?
I'm waking up, guys!
I'm waking up!
Look!
I'm gonna grief somebody's top 500 game!
I told you guys.
No matter what, I will eventually grief someone's top 500 game.
Right here.
I'm gonna grief somebody's top 500 game.
Alright.
Does this team deserve...
Does this team deserve my... my honor?
We'll see.
Alright, let me grab reinforcements just in case.
Alright.
Um...
Okay, there we go.
Guys, I got the... I have the...
I have the... uh...
reinforcements on backup.
Just in case!
Just in case this match goes terribly wrong.
Thank you, ՛գ renovation!
Thank you.
Believe in GrumpyPants!
Alright.
We'll see.
I realized like, what is a streamer mode name too.
Like, what names are streamer modes.
So many people!
So many people are using streamer mode these days.
I mean, it makes sense because you know, you could flame And then like, they won't know it's you.
The ELO insurance.
Oh my god, it's from Amatra.
It's from Amatra.
Oh my shit's fucking bugging.
Holy fuck.
I love hearing that!
Don't you love it when your tank is like, oh my shit is bugging?
I'm just freaking out.
Please!
You're literally a tank!
Please don't do this to me!
Just leave!
Leave the game!
Okay, I'm good.
Ash won.
Oh my god.
You know you love hearing your fucking tank being like, oh man, my shit's bugging, bro.
He's good.
Guys, he's good now, guys.
He's good now.
Everything's okay.
Look at that, I can hit a tracer.
A little psych.
Just gave you guys a little of a heart attack, but it's okay.
Everything's fine now.
Always keep your teammates on your toes.
Exactly.
Alright.
You're fine.
Yeah.
Yeah, see?
I might have missed like two more shots, but you see the- No!
It's a Sigma!
Wait, they were Sigma this entire time.
I hate playing Ana against shields.
It's like, not fun.
Like, I guess like, Rein's shield is okay, but like, how the fuck?
Oh my god.
Okay, I don't have to ult then.
Oh!
Please!
Please, I- I've done everything I could.
No.
Where's the- Where's the- Doom!
Please!
Doom!
Pick me!
I've been trying to kill you this entire time!
I've been trying to- I've been trying to fucking kill you, I do!
Are you fucking kidding- Oh my god!
Picanto!
Go, Picanto!
Go!
Picanto, please!
Pick me, Picanto!
Holy shit, who is he?
It's fine.
He didn't need my ult.
I saved my ult.
Wait, wait, wait.
I saved my ult for next fight, guys.
I- I- That was intentional.
Because I knew he would clutch this.
This was the same guy where his shit was bugging.
It was the same guy.
Don't butterfly me.
Oh my god.
Please.
There.
This is how much I believe in him.
I believe in you.
I believe in you, Picanto!
Picanto, you got this!
Picanto!
Where is he?
Wait, where is Picanto?
There he is.
Look at that.
See?
This man.
This man deserves it.
Cool, guys.
Don't look at- Don't look at me.
But then I missed.
Maybe I should start looking.
Okay.
We're fine.
See?
We are so fine.
We're so healthy.
Look at that.
I-
They didn't see.
Picanto did not see.
He didn't see.
Okay.
That was a little embarrassing.
Big ass.
Always believe in Picanto.
Guys, look.
I've warmed up in everything.
But like...
I've warmed up in everything?
What the fuck is he doing here?
Oh my god.
What are they all doing here?
Oh god.
He has all- He actually has all- There, I hit it.
There.
I hit it, guys.
I redeemed myself.
Everything there is pain.
Thank you for the CB chat.
There.
See?
I hit those.
I hit the aunties.
I told you.
It was a bait, chat.
It was just a bait.
Damn it.
You misread.
Look.
I get one mistake.
Oh.
Oh yeah.
So like...
Look.
Every game, I get one mistake.
This is my one.
That's how I realized.
I realized I was like...
My mic was too low a bit.
When it was a little too low.
Every game, I just...
I get one mistake.
This is my one.
This is my one, guys.
Alright.
Here we go.
Let's go.
Only one freebie.
Look.
We're still gonna win right now.
Regardless.
Unless we don't fucking get past the first...
The first... What is it called?
Oh my gosh.
Overwatch terms.
I already forgot Overwatch terms, guys.
Where are those... Where are those... Checkpoints?
Yeah.
The first checkpoint.
It's fine.
The first tick.
Yeah.
Guys.
This is how I watched them.
I actually don't remember Overwatch terms at the moment.
Here we go.
It's okay.
We can do this.
I didn't get this top 500 spray.
To miss my antis.
Holy shit.
He's going straight to point.
They might have seen me.
Okay.
Ow.
No.
I lived though.
You guys ready?
I'm like on their hand and they're saying...
No.
We are absolutely not ready.
Guys.
There is actually a chance we might lose.
There's...
It's crazy for me to say.
But...
But we live in a world where we can actually lose.
Oh, look at that!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No, shit!
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
We're okay.
I'm gonna swap off because like I am not playing... I am not playing Ana into this.
I'm not playing Ana into this.
No, fuck that shit.
This is... this is too much.
This is too much.
I refuse to heal through a Sigma shield.
Alright, Kiriko.
Guys, it's not because we're losing them swapping to Kiriko.
It just makes sense.
I hate playing Ana against Sigma.
Okay guys, it's not because I'm giving up.
It actually makes sense to play Kiriko in this scenario.
Wait, we should fucking push up because...
Yeah.
Oh!
There we go.
See?
Look at that!
We're slowly but surely raising our Kiriko win rate!
Look at that.
I told you!
It makes sense to play Kiriko!
This was my first death, by the way.
I only had one death, guys.
One death.
That's how you fucking play support.
Alright.
I'll just be like, invite me whenever.
Invite me whenever.
There we go.
Alright.
Even though we won that game...
Like, I... Wait, oops, sorry.
Let's just get some Overwatch 2 insurance in here.
We're still... We're not gonna be in like a voice chat with them though.
We're just gonna be like chilling.
But Kondo was good.
He actually hard carried us.
He hard carried me.
Oh my god.
Let's go pick Kondo!
Oh wait.
Alright, never mind.
We get... We have to... We play another one.
Because our insurance isn't even ready.
Rank insurance time!
Our insurance was not ready.
So we play another.
Alright.
We need to slowly warm back up or aim anyway.
That's fine.
Alright, watch this guys.
Craziest headshot you're gonna see.
Craziest headshot.
Right here.
What the fuck kind of fight is going on right now?
I told you.
WAHOO!
SHIT!
I told you.
Craziest headshot you're ever gonna see.
Woah, woah.
Hey guys.
Hey.
Calm down!
Hey guys.
Let me regen my fucking HP.
She's popping off.
There you go.
I told you.
Okay.
Look.
I popped off in the beginning though.
Lucias are hard to hit, okay?
They all like...
Look at them fucking riding around.
Like a little rat.
Come on.
Come on Lucio.
Also, Sound Guy, I like adjusted my mic a little bit.
Sounds still okay.
Unless Sound Guy like left after it peaced out after that.
Bro, fuck off!
Bro, what the fuck?
There's a Hammond?
Don't make me fucking come up here.
That's fucking right.
I can jump.
That's a streamer mode name too.
Please res me.
You get to like see all the streamer mode names while you're playing.
You're gonna fucking suzu.
But you can't suzu from these shots.
Look at that.
Wait, is it just me?
And the... Oh no.
It's me, Kiriko and Sombra.
Where the fuck's the Sombra?
Oh shit.
Yeah, it's never a good idea to fucking hide you in front of a Kiriko.
Oh.
Wow!
Please spare me.
Potato, thank you for the super sticker.
Thank you.
Where was that?
I'm gonna AFK for an hour.
Can I just see you later?
Jessie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh god.
I hate Soldier and Strafe.
Please, fight each other and then let me take two kills.
Fight each other, please.
There we go.
Oh no!
Who expected the fourth party?
Who expected that?
You know I'm inspired now.
I'm not inspired.
I'm...
I haven't...
I haven't played Tracer in so long.
Guys, it's been a while since I played Tracer.
Oh god, not against Kiriko.
Playing against Kiriko with Tracer is like...
is like playing against my counter.
Oh god, that's scary.
Oh!
It's like one headshot away.
Oh, please have mercy.
What's that?
I see her.
Lucio.
Okay.
Full regen.
Because I don't know my map.
Health packs.
That's the only reason to play Tracer.
You know where all the health packs are.
But I don't.
That's the thing.
Oh!
No!
Here we go.
I take those.
I'm desperate.
No!
Okay.
Where is...
It's okay.
I'm rank one in deathmatch.
Guys, don't talk to me unless you're rank one in deathmatch.
Where the fuck is he?
Oh shit.
Watch this.
Whoa!
Sombra!
Oh no, I don't have blinks anymore.
No!
I got...
Bro, there was three people!
Did anyone get the license plate?
It's not fair!
There was like three!
I'm one Tracer.
Oh my god.
Why is it all Kirikos?
Please.
Is it just Kirikos?
Where the fuck is the Widow?
Let me farm this Widow.
Okay.
Oh, I hear him.
Bro, stop following me!
Bro, leave me alone!
Farm somebody else!
Where is this Widow?
I'm going to try to...
Oh, there he is.
Please!
Let me farm this Widow!
Oh my god, it's worth it.
It's worth it.
That's it.
Bro, it's not my fault!
I literally have like three people on my ass!
Bro, bitch!
Bro, fuck off!
I fucking farmed her!
Leave me alone!
Okay, where's the widow?
I won't make that widow leave.
Right here.
Okay.
Baby?
There you go!
Fuck off!
Oh fuck!
Okay.
Give me a sec.
Give me a sec!
All right!
Don't worry!
Bro, what the fuck this Kiriko is just annoying us!
There you go.
They don't know, they don't know.
Oh god!
They don't know.
I don't know how I'm here.
I need to regen because I don't know where the health packs are.
I don't know where the health packs are!
Bro!
Okay!
Okay, nice.
I got the Kiriko kill.
She's just watching!
It made me... It gave me performance anxiety when he just started watching!
I don't know what to do!
Oh, thank god.
It's okay.
We in the game.
We in the game!
Actually a hunting party.
They were judging me!
They were looking at me!
It happens to all of us.
Can I play Mercy?
Am I... Guys, do I get my one?
My one Mercy game?
Yes.
Have I been...
Have I proven myself enough to have one Mercy game?
Look, I get... I get one mistake and one Mercy game.
Do I... Can I... Do I not... Can I not try anymore?
Mercy is cracked now.
You say that and then you get like...
You get like two guys yelling at you because you're playing Mercy.
You say...
You're playing Mercy would be the mistake.
Guys, sometimes a support player just want to play Mercy.
Okay?
They just want to play Mercy and just relax.
Alright, guys?
I need you to know that...
That sometimes people just don't want to aim.
And that's why Mercy and Brigitte was born.
Yeah, Widow.
That's why I don't... I personally don't like this map if they have a good Widow.
Oh.
Over there.
Oh, he fucking dead.
Okay, I should play Kiriko.
I'll save the Doom and then I'm gonna swap the Kiriko.
Because we need cleanse.
Alright.
Guys, it's not because we were losing.
It just makes sense to play Kiriko.
Okay, guys?
Sometimes I play Kiriko because it makes sense.
Alright.
He was just pepper spraying me so I was just like... whatever.
Guys, there are moments when I pick her because she just was the character to play.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
Even if we lose, we have a demotion protection.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Do one damage.
Oh, god.
It's fine.
I'm alive.
I am not alive anymore.
Please tell me you're not Doom 1 Trick.
Because we really need you to be somebody else.
They are hard countering you, my dude.
They are hard countering you.
Oh, thank god.
Okay, they missed.
Are you serious?
Okay, that was a mistake.
I swear to god.
Please just be alive.
This is all I want.
Be alive.
He has ult.
Winston has ult.
Winston...
Why are you there?
Oh, Dooms are...
Not anymore.
There's just Dooms that like...
Okay.
Alright.
They wasted that.
That's good.
They wasted the ult.
We're fine.
Yeah, there's structures there now.
There's new stuff.
There's so many new things.
It's okay.
Maybe our Doom...
Maybe our Doom will swap.
Oh, thank fucking god.
I honestly never expected him to swap.
But thank god.
Also, nobody talks in Overwatch anymore.
It's actually sad.
Everyone just plays the game.
There you go.
That's how you headshot.
Wait, I think he still has ult.
I don't think he expected to get burned that quickly.
Look at that.
Look at that headshot.
Whoa, look at that.
That was not a headshot.
But look at that though.
Jesus Christ, please.
There's too many flankers.
Okay.
Alright.
I'm gonna go.
I think I can kill him.
No one.
Nope.
Are you serious?
Sometimes there's too many things.
I can't fucking do everything.
It's fine.
We're okay.
Please.
Anybody.
I'm about to be at 2k damage.
I mean, at the same damage as our Sombra.
It's okay.
As long as I don't publicly say the toxic stuff to them, we're fine.
Like, how trash this Tracer is.
He should uninstall this game right now.
But it's okay.
Please.
Bap.
I'm a team.
Oh my god.
It's okay.
We have rank insurance later.
Look.
It's not me that I have a 30% win rate.
It's not my fault that I have a 30% win rate on Kiriko.
It's just...
It's unwinnable.
I'm in an unwinnable scenario.
I'm in a win-win situation.
I'm letting...
He's only 14 years old.
Look.
I swear to god.
It's not a me issue when it comes to Kiriko.
My team...
My team is just...
Let's just say...
Let's just say they could be held back a grade.
Let's just say that.
I'm out here skipping five grades.
My teammates are still fucking in kindergarten.
Like...
Look.
You can't blame me.
I have the...
Wait.
Shit.
This character...
Never mind.
I don't have my sprays on this guy.
That's a nice way to say it.
Look.
Guys.
I'm PMA.
Positive mental attitude.
Positive mental attitude chat.
It's all about being positive.
Yeah.
Okay.
How much you want?
I'm gonna run up this wall and then get headshot.
Nope.
I didn't.
Thank fucking god.
Thank god.
I had somebody...
I had one of my friends call me like a heal bot on Kiriko because all I do was like heal instead of like DPSing.
And then I like 1v1 them on Kiriko and then I fucking shit on them.
We did like...
We had like a 1v1 session on Kiriko and I had like...
I think it was like 20 to 10.
I was like, say that shit again.
I was like, fuck you.
Who said I'm a heal bot on Kiriko?
It's not my fault that my team keeps fucking dying so I can't DPS.
Like it's not my fault.
Okay.
Look.
That...
Okay.
I might have missed shots there.
But like...
Is that what I'm saying?
There we go.
This is different.
The strafe was insane.
The strafe pattern was insane.
It's different.
I'm not a heal bot on Kiriko.
All right.
I can also DPS too.
But like I need to win the game so I can't fucking try to prove a point at the moment because I need to make sure my team's alive.
Like I said, it's not my fault that I'm healing so much on Kiriko.
I'm going to do it.
I have to keep them alive!
Look!
Oh my god, I swear, please poke.
Please, I need heals.
Please, don't let this monkey kill me!
Don't let this monkey kill me!
Alright, there you go.
Anyway...
Panzer, thank you for the 50k!
Thank you!
Okay, that's fine.
Alright.
Making sure you're alive.
Making sure you're alive too.
Alright, there you go.
You forgot!
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
See?
Headshot!
Boom!
Climb the wall!
Headshot!
Boom!
There you go.
Easy.
Oh god.
Oh... Oh god.
Oh god!
Alright, we're fine.
Everything is okay.
Everything... We're totally gonna lose this.
We're...
I actually have...
Wait!
No, we're totally gonna lose this.
I'm going in with zero confidence here.
I... I honestly do not...
I do not think that this is winnable.
Unless... I do have my rush!
Yeah, Masters is top 500 now.
If you're in Diamond, I think Masters is Diamond 5.
Or Diamond... Not Diamond 5.
Diamond... Diamond 1?
Maybe?
Maybe Diamond 1?
It's okay!
I'm protecting you!
Everything will be fine!
Are you fucking...
I... I can't believe it!
My rush got fucking eliminated!
My rush actually got eliminated by a hack!
Oh god, this might be where I die.
This might be where I die.
Let them out!
Oh god.
Oh...
I'm that good.
I didn't need rush.
I'm so good that I don't even need rush!
You got this!
Guys!
Who the fuck needs rush?
I'm that good!
Never judge me!
I have to...
Okay, don't look at this, though.
Don't look at this.
Look at the heals.
I am not a heal bot.
But I kept my team alive.
I'm the same!
I'm not a heal bot on Kiriko.
Guys, I'm not a heal bot on Kiriko.
I had more damage than our Bap on Kiriko.
That's so different!
It's okay.
We have rank insurance now.
We have rank insurance.
We don't...
We don't talk about...
our fucking accuracy.
Not a heal bot.
Look at this.
That's different!
I had to heal that much because my team was dying!
Look, we're slowly but surely raising our Kiriko win rate.
Guys.
Welcome back to Tamaya Farm!
Welcome back!
Straight, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, guys.
Okay, look.
In Overwatch, it's actually not a compliment what I found out.
Like...
How do I know?
I've surprisingly been called a heal bot on Kiriko.
Not...
Not just once.
Like...
It was like, heal bot quote unquote derogatory.
So I...
So unfortunately, that's how I know the heal bot is not the way to go.
Why is it that bad?
Because when you're playing Kiriko, the issue...
You're supposed to put in the DPS as well when you're playing Kiriko too.
But like, I...
Apparently, I...
I...
Do not put in enough DPS for them to be happy about it.
Yo, yo, yo!
How you guys doing?
Holy shit!
He's loud.
Give me a sec.
We're gonna...
Can I...
I'm gonna have to adjust the fucking thing.
Alright, give me a sec.
We gotta adjust...
How do you adjust the fucking vol...
Is there like individual volume sliders?
Oh my god, that's so loud.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
Uh...
Voice chat.
Oh, is it cause like voice chat volume is like at...
I'm putting at 75.
There we go.
Guys, I'm not throwing.
I'm not throwing.
It's my time.
Wait, I'm a Sombra?
Oh my god, okay.
There's no reason to play Mercy with Sombra, Tracer, with two flankers.
There's no reason.
Guys, I'm not picking Kiriko.
I'm not picking Kiriko because I'm throwing.
Okay.
It's cause...
Cop wise, I have to.
Sometimes you just have to play these characters.
But it doesn't mean you're throwing.
Thank you.
It's just not...
Oh, please, Ruben.
You are my rank insurance.
If I start losing without rank insurance, what does that say about my insurance?
Okay.
All right.
Okay, we have Ana.
Okay, we have two flankers.
You can't blame my team.
Everybody's playing...
Everybody playing Ana.
We're playing the required character.
Except for our DPS, which is unfortunately like, you know, what we need good DPS.
I should have avoided Sombra.
There's rank insurance now?
Yes, my rank insurance is called having a duo.
That's my rank insurance.
Look, I did have a pause...
Woo!
Is he still holding it?
He's still holding it.
Is my head peaking?
We're fine.
See?
We're okay.
All right.
We're all here.
Look.
Oh my God.
Thank God.
He's playing Soldier now.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
All right.
And then he died, but that's okay.
It's okay.
He's dead.
But like...
Okay.
All right.
This is fine.
They used copy and they used rush.
All right.
I think I won more being solo.
I'm just...
All I'm saying is that I won more games playing solo.
You'll be able to walk out of spawn.
It'll be beautiful.
All right.
Wait.
I think I can like chill now.
We have Ana.
We have Soldier.
And we have Ashe.
Nice.
All right.
This is it.
Use my rush so I can swap later.
All right.
It's okay.
It's just on Ruben.
It's fine.
Look at that.
He's fine.
Look, he's so healthy.
Look at that.
He took two...
Oh, and then our Soldier died.
Oh, and then our other DPS died.
Okay.
This just wasn't the game.
This is just not the game.
This is just...
It's all right.
We're just...
We were not meant to win this.
It was canon.
It was fucking...
It was just canon.
It was just...
No, he's not!
Words are his?
What do you mean words are his?
What do you mean?
Okay.
All I'm saying is that...
The rank insurance kicks in now.
It kicks in.
The rank insurance, it's gonna kick in now.
I would type where the DPS at.
Look, I would too.
But I'm also afraid of getting...
I'm getting banned.
Because they're very strict now about banning people.
They're very strict now and I don't want to get chat banned.
Guys, I really do not want to get chat banned.
Even for like stuff like...
Guys, I get one!
Guys!
I get one game!
My one game of Mercy.
Like how every game I get one...
Like how every game I get like one mistake.
Every three games I get one chance to play Mercy.
Oh my god.
Dude, I'm so ready to win.
First game of the day feeling fresh and ready.
Wait, wait.
Why would you ask that?
You clearly missed a payment on your rank insurance.
Don't worry, I got you.
Don't keep faking.
Thank you for the Akka super.
Thank you.
You're right.
You're right, Bacon.
My rank insurance starts now.
It starts now.
This is where it starts.
My one game on Mercy.
Where is the other seat?
It will be fine.
Where am I?
Oh there it is.
Oh run!
Oh this is so easy!
This is so easy!
They are on run!
That's like automatically easy game.
Okay.
Okay I sort of threw there.
Okay I threw a little bit.
But like it was a joke.
It was like...
It was just a joke guys.
Alright focus now!
Focus now!
Guys.
I'm not pistolling because I'm throwing.
I'm pistolling because I want to get the Zenyatta out of the way.
Oh god please Livanna.
Please fucking Liv.
Okay here we go.
Here we go.
See?
Fine.
We're fine.
Look!
I'll swap after my ult!
Okay!
Here.
Watch this.
Look at all the...
That means my DPS is doing great.
The most engaging gameplay ever.
Here we go.
Come on!
Get a kill!
You got this!
Ohhhh!
Okay.
That's fine.
See?
Now you get your kill.
Now you get your one.
You get your one right here.
Right here!
That's right!
That's right small pup!
You get your one kill right here!
Right here is where you get your one kill!
This is it small pup!
I won't stop healing you until...
Small pup please!
Oh he did it.
She did it.
She fucking killed it.
She fucking did it.
I believed.
What was that?
What is this guy doing?
Oh my god.
Wait.
There we go.
It's fine!
The hero we all deserved.
She got her one kill.
We did it.
Now I don't have the damage booster anymore.
Oh my god.
He's so... Is Ruben okay?
I'm not okay.
I am not okay.
Oh my god!
Two kills!
I've never doubted you.
Never doubted you for a second.
What the fuck was that Rineshatter?
It was called Optimism.
Oh she is so fucking dead.
She is so fucking dead.
She is so...
No!
Just needed one poke!
Just one fucking poke man!
Oh my god.
That tracking is beautiful though.
Please.
Just one poke.
Oh my god.
I'm taking a nap.
Alright.
It's fine.
I will rez her.
And then nothing bad happens.
Yo we can kill Bastion!
Alright.
We can also kill Ana.
See?
It'll be fine.
It's okay.
I'll meet shield you.
You won't die on my watch.
I can kill this guy.
He's getting healed?
What is going on over there?
How is he getting healed passively?
Why is there a rogue over here?
I shot him!
How did the regen...
Pit.
Okay.
We're fine.
That's fine.
Later.
See?
We're in the...
We're in a stage of it's fine and it's not fine.
But it'll be fine.
They have no sleep.
Oh no.
It's not fine anymore.
I'm swapping.
There's no reason to play her.
I win these.
That's the crazy thing.
Alright.
Let's see.
I'm gonna play...
I'm gonna play Kiriko.
We need Kiriko for the laning phase.
It's always about the cleanse, guys.
It's always about the cleanse.
It's so over him.
We're so back.
We need to get rid of antis.
We're gonna up our win percentage on this character.
Guys.
It's gonna work.
We're gonna up our win percentage.
What the fuck?
He's like 1.
Holy shit.
I am just gonna watch.
I'm gonna wait here.
Is he fine?
I don't think he's fine.
I don't think he was fine.
That means because I refunded my Mercy.
Because I refunded my Mercy.
That means I get to play Mercy next game.
Because I did a refund and got my money back.
So I have one refund.
Okay.
Thank you.
That's how it works.
I got my money back.
And I got a refund.
Refund is guaranteed.
We're gonna kill the Soge.
I'm gonna shit my pants.
Is he okay?
Dude.
I know.
Poor guy.
That's what I'm talking about.
Alright.
I did not wake him up.
Everybody else woke him up.
Guys.
It wasn't me.
Oh wait.
Oh my god.
They're getting kills.
Go.
Where is the...
Where is the Hammond?
I can't see the Hammond.
Nice.
Please.
Just shoot him.
Shoot him.
He's so low.
Oh my god.
Thank god.
At least shoot him.
Please shoot him too.
No.
Okay.
We're good.
This is happening.
I told you.
Look.
Maybe Mercy was just not the pick.
Guys.
Maybe Mercy was like 100% not the pick.
He's slamming me.
We're gonna kill the Loaded.
I'm not sure yet.
I need more data.
Just a maybe.
Alright.
We're fine.
I have Rush.
There.
You're welcome Tracer.
Now I never have to heal her again.
She can't complain because I saved her life one time.
That's how it works.
Being a support player.
Wait.
What the fuck?
I'm not gonna look.
Can we kill this Rodent?
Look at this guy.
Okay.
There we go.
What the fuck was this Ana doing there?
Not a heal bot.
I have less damage than our Ana.
But I was also playing.
Wait.
No.
Of course I have less damage.
I was playing fucking.
I was playing fucking Mercy.
I'm about to laugh at Ana.
What the
fuck is this?
That's embarrassing.
Kill him now.
No he didn't.
Oh wait.
I'm almost there.
There you go.
Headshot.
We chill really low.
Oh god.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh it's not fine.
I ran away.
Oh no.
It's okay.
There we go.
It's fine.
I need my damage!
Oh, there's our Reaper!
It's fine, we're okay.
Just like Tanimura all over again.
All I'm saying, chat...
All I'm saying...
is that...
I was Mercy for like 60% of that game.
And I'm already almost the same damage as our Ana.
That's all I'm saying!
I'm not saying that our Ana was bad!
I'm saying that I'm really good.
I'm just saying...
I was pretty good with that fucking damage there.
It's fine, it's fine.
I think I'll play Zenyatta actually.
Should I play Zen?
Is it worth it?
I'm gonna do it.
I'll play Kiriko if we die.
It would be 30%!
I literally swapped when we were here!
That's like literally 60%!
You see the chat for me?
Did you call me for the new hero shooter Marvel?
Yeah I did.
And then I accidentally called the water guy Aquaman because I literally forgot the Marvel water guy.
We need to switch that MV.
I'm really excited though.
I'm really really excited.
I'm really looking forward to it.
We need like... I just want a fucking good FPS game.
I'm tired of all the realism ones.
What the fuck is he... WHAT?!
He's like... Oookay.
Alright.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Yeah, our hog's dead.
Our fucking tracer was AFK.
I'm tired of all the realism shooters like the... the... what is it?
Like the PUBGs and the Tarkovs.
I just want like more of the non-realism shooters.
Realism shooters just die so fast.
It's just not fun for me.
Why is there a floating orb?
No!
What?!
The ride is a floating orb!
I don't get it!
I literally can't see the ride!
I'm like... No!
It's back!
It's fine.
The ride is a floating orb!
I see the ride!
I actually can't see the ride!
What is this bug?!
That bug only existed when my drives were crashing!
Oh no...
I actually can't see where the ride is.
That's so bad.
I'm sorry, I can't see the ride!
Holy shit!
I don't see this!
What is this bug?!
I haven't had that bug in so long!
It's just orbs!
We can also kill Rein.
Oh, if I don't know where that ride is, I'm sorry!
I'm sorry!
I can't see him!
I...
Oh my god.
Good job.
That's a dead body.
Okay, we know that.
I can't... I actually don't know where...
This is so bad.
This is actually so bad.
Oh my god.
Okay...
Oh no...
I died!
I'm gonna assume the Reinhardt is with the team, right?
He has...
He has to be with the team.
He died a lot.
That's the Rein!
The tiny orb right here!
That's him!
Are you serious?
Oh...
Oh... He has played.
He has played.
He has played now.
No, it's okay.
That's fine.
I got slushed by our fuckiana.
Okay, I brought us Reinhardt.
What the fuck is this bug?
It's alright.
This is...
This is a little awkward.
Wait!
I'm an orb too!
Guys!
Oh, the Rein!
At least I can see the Rein now!
I can see the Rein!
It's fine!
I can't see anything else!
But I can see the Rein though!
Genji, you can't die fast enough.
You're a genius!
It's okay!
I can see the Rein now!
Guys, I can see...
Okay, I got my one.
It's actually a really big one.
I'm ready.
Not overclocked.
Interesting.
And they all just...
Oh my god, I was gonna say...
Guys, I don't think my rank insurance is working, guys.
I realize my rank insurance is absolutely not working.
I'm an orb!
I don't know what's going on!
There's two orbs!
Oh!
We're all orbs!
Guys, I'm losing with the rank insurance.
I think I might need a refund.
I might need a refund.
My insurance has... I was winning more.
As soon as I got rank insurance, I think I got sold a scam.
Guys, as soon as I got rank insurance, I've been losing games.
I...
People are turning into orbs.
Uh...
Things...
Things was not going so well for me.
Oh my god, I see my hands!
Holy shit!
This is it!
I can see my arms now!
Alright.
I'm not saying Ruben is scamming me!
Guys, we've got a rock win and we win.
That's it.
I'm not saying.
It's actually such a free game to fall down first place.
Alright, let's... I hope I can see you right.
I'm not gonna lose to a tank who's 14 and 10.
Alright, here you go.
I'm... I refuse...
Here you go.
I refuse to lose to that guy.
To be fair, one of our tank... one of our DPS has like 11 deaths.
Alright, there you go.
We're not orbs anymore.
This is it.
Guys, they're on Rein and Zen again.
We're not orbs.
But somebody's an orb.
Alright.
This is a little awkward.
Oh, this is so awkward.
Where is the Rein?
What?
Oh, my God.
Where's the big, fucking fat Rein?
I'm the most worried.
I think the most worried part is...
is I'm scared I'm fucking...
I won't be able to see the pin.
I...
I will not be... I 100% will not be...
I got my one.
I definitely will not be able to see my fucking Rein.
Wait, big, big, big.
What's up?
Someone else step on the point...
just don't see Rein.
Oh, that's so easy.
I'm here.
I can see anywhere.
Wait... I'm gonna go for the Ana.
What are you...
She's there.
Where are you, Rupit?
Where are you?
What is this fucking bug?
What?
No.
What is he?
What hero is he playing?
Okay, Doom.
Okay, alright, Doom.
Okay.
Is that Ryne?
That's Ryne.
That's...
Okay, I'm gonna hope everybody will be fine.
Wait, what is that?
What is that?
Is that a Doom?
I might need to restart my game.
Oh my god.
I can't even see the orb!
What?
I'm restarting game.
Oh my god.
I'm one game away from deraking!
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna restart.
I don't know what happened.
Honestly, I never...
The last time this happened was like years ago.
So...
Battle of the goddamn orbs.
Orbs.
Overwatch joined now.
Bro!
I was just having too good of a good thing and then their game was like, you're having fun in Overwatch?
I...
Well then, Dokia.
We're not gonna let you have that.
There's an orb among us.
They're just like, you're having good?
You're having a good time?
How dare you!
Now here you can't see half of the players on this lobby.
Overwatch 2 and fun can't be in the same set.
How dare you start having fun on Overwatch.
That was actually crazy.
That actually like when the... when it was like a doom echo.
When it was a doom echo, I literally could not see the doom.
Like that was so big brain.
That was actually so fucking big brain.
Like...
Like I can't believe it.
I can't believe that happened.
That was actually crazy.
Alright, here we go.
We'll be fine.
This time... this time guys, this is it.
Overwatch 2.
Okay, let me...
Cause like my drives aren't... my drives are not crashing.
I know that for sure.
Cause like last time...
Last time when we had orbs in Overwatch, it was cause like my PC was fucking dying.
This is still not the...
This is still... I'm not using my new PC yet cause I haven't had time to set up my new PC.
But like okay.
Your storage space... this is probably being used by something else.
Check task manager.
Oh no.
How bad is my storage space right now?
Can't be that bad.
Yeah, it's not even that bad.
It's not like my storage space is at 41%.
What the fuck?
I just hope my PC isn't... same thing happens.
The mod up.
Very common on my...
Oh no.
Is it... is it my game?
Is it... is it my PC?
We'll know.
We'll know if it's my PC.
If everybody's orbs are getting here.
But the thing is... I play so much... I think it's cause I'm streaming.
Maybe it's cause I'm streaming that the games are getting rough.
Like...
Is it me?
Am I the problem?
Am I... Am I the issue here?
Alright.
No worry.
We'll know.
I got my refund so I can play Mercy again.
I got my refund guys.
Is everybody loaded in?
Everybody's loaded in.
It was not me.
It was the game.
Look.
See?
What happened?
Dude.
Okay.
This is my off wall man.
Okay?
It's...
Look.
See?
There's a... There's... No orb.
Wasn't me.
It was not me.
I fucking knew it wasn't me.
I've always been a DPS player.
It's never me.
Archives.
About checking the archives.
It was not me.
Good luck with that.
It's okay.
I can play.
I can play Murky.
Murky time.
Yeah.
Alright.
It's time for relaxation after orb watch.
It's orb watch time.
Alright.
Here we go.
Look.
See?
So relaxing.
Don't have to try.
Just crouch.
Woah!
Sorry.
Everything's fine.
It was just a little scare.
Just a little bit of a scare.
Right here.
See?
Everything's okay.
Alright, Ash.
Go and do your thing.
Let me hear the fucking...
Let me hear the ting ting sounds.
At least let me hear some headshots.
That'd be crazy.
Oh, wait.
We can push this freely?
You know what?
I'll take a free push.
Don't!
Okay.
It wasn't as free as I thought.
It wasn't.
Guys.
Apparently, it was not free.
Of course.
You don't get things in life for free.
I forgot about that.
Mercy.
Kill their Mercy.
If they can kill me, you can kill their Mercy.
It's the rule of law.
Where's the door?
Thank you.
There you go.
I have Blade II.
He has Blade!
He's gaming!
Alright.
I believe in him.
They remember the payload existed.
Why do they always remember it at the worst possible moments for me?
I think it's gonna be easy.
I think they just hate YouTubers.
They knew.
They knew!
Wait.
There's more.
Look.
I'm getting targeted.
All I'm saying is that I'm getting targeted right now.
I'm getting targeted here.
On LAN, I win those.
Alright.
This time.
Okay.
I'm gonna focus.
Guys.
Look.
All I'm saying is not me.
I'm just getting targeted.
I can't f***ing avoid forever.
Stream sniping.
Oh sh**.
Stream sniping!
I can't believe they would do this to banish Banshee.
I can't believe it.
They do this for the up and coming streamer Banshee.
It's so f***ed up.
Oh no.
It's okay.
I can fly up in the air.
Where?
Where was my echo?
Why do you care?
Why?
Okay.
My echo f***ing flew away from me and I couldn't fly up in the air.
Yeah.
Holy sh**.
All I'm saying is that I couldn't fly in the air.
Okay.
I couldn't fly.
Why are you healing the hog?
Oh my god.
Yes.
That could be pocket.
Because I need healing.
Wow.
He has a single die.
Guys.
This is the Overwatch experience.
I'm gonna report this guy and I hope he gets banned.
Okay.
No grass.
Five points.
I f***ing healed as best as I could.
In this scenario.
I'm so good at plans, dude.
I might be a genius.
Guys.
It's not me.
I swear to god.
Oh my god.
Guys.
This is why you don't play.
This is why.
Because you're not in voice.
Mercy.
I can say whatever you want about Kirit.
I can't hear you.
All I'm saying.
All I'm saying is that playing Mercy is pretty rough.
Look.
It's my team.
Mercy is only as good as the team.
Copy.
I hope the echo dies.
That's all I'm saying.
Holy sh**.
I'm just getting targeted.
I'm 100% getting targeted.
There's no way.
There's no way I die every time.
Oh my god.
They have nothing because they also just used high noon in the fight before.
Oh.
Wait.
Did I like res that?
Maybe I should res that.
Should I wait?
Nah.
I'll just wait.
Alright.
I'm gonna go mid and I'm just gonna walk on this thing.
I'll go do the echo.
But it would be a shame if the echo dies.
I support it.
Oh.
You're a Mei player?
It would be a shame.
Am I a Tama player?
Am I a Mei player?
Make up your mind.
People can play two teams.
I did say it was a shame.
Look, he get pock- I told you!
You can't help him!
You can't fucking help him!
He dies with a pocket!
He fucking dies with a pocket!
You can't save him!
Oh my god.
Holy shit.
You can't heal stupid if he dies with a pocket!
You can't fucking save him!
I knew it wasn't me.
I fucking knew it wasn't me!
I knew I was getting targeted!
I fucking knew it!
I'm swapping.
Fuck this bitch.
Fuck this whore.
I was justified!
I will never save him.
I hope he dies in game.
We are gonna hear you.
They are not in voice.
Alright.
Bye.
Sorry, Overwatch puts me through a really rough place.
Welcome to the Overwatch experience.
God, it would be a shame if you die.
Yo, this guy put his window down and I- This guy put his fucking ammo down and I hooked the window.
I'm so mad.
He's so dead.
Bro, back up!
Bro!
Why are you still- Why are you healing?!
What?!
Oh my god!
Why?!
Reset!
Okay.
The more you were alive, the more- What do you mean more of us were alive?
It was two supports and a Mei!
What the fuck am I supposed to do?!
You can do the fucking 2020 finals.
The fucking- Whatever it's called.
Ow.
Are you gonna drop him on top of your head?
Alright, I have ult soon.
Oh, he did get the Sigma.
Good for him.
Doing the bare fucking minimum.
This is where I die.
Big Flux!
Holy shit!
What a fucking- Okay, not gonna lie.
That was- That was an insane combo.
Bro, this kid is fucking five.
Alright, we find the key.
What?
I fucking swapped him Ana.
I don't think that was on her Ana and that was definitely not on me.
What?!
I literally swapped Ana on the last fucking thing.
This kid is like twelve.
This kid is twelve.
There's no fucking way.
I'm gonna- This- Never peaked Masters on your level 321 account.
Stop blaming everyone but yourself!
Except for support.
Except- Yes it is!
Stop!
Right or wrong?
Holy shit.
You're fucking trash, kid.
You're actually trash.
You're the only one on this team without any healing.
Do not leave a broken world behind.
What are you doing?
Inappropriate text chat, voice chat.
That's what I thought.
Underage- Okay, I should say underage.
Blaming everyone but your- but yourself.
I did not- I did not say all that.
Thank you.
Toxic as hell.
Bro, go back to school.
Just kidding.
At your- at his age?
I was fucking top 500.
What the fuck is this kid doing?
He is like high school and still Diamond.
Fucking learn the game.
This game's been out for like seven plus years and you're still Diamond?
Don't be a Diamond shitter.
Oh my god.
Imagine fucking still being a Diamond shitter after like...
Okay, so...
And not peeking more in that.
Oh, it would be a shame if he dies.
Why is there a cast there?
What do you mean?
Yeah, oh man.
Why is there a cast there?
I will not let them rise.
I'm gonna stand here menacingly.
Alright.
Oh man, sucks that fucking he's dead.
So sad.
Oh my god.
Sucks that he's dead.
Alright, I'm heading over.
Everybody gets heals except for- except for the- except for that guy.
You're fine.
Her mercy is just fucking pistoling them.
Honestly, you're just mad she's go bossing.
Look, if you're- you guys are still Diamond after seven years on the game, it's not you guys.
It's your team.
But this guy, this guy 100%, 100%, he's gonna be stuck in Diamond forever.
And it's because of him himself.
Yeah, yeah, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
It's because of- it's because of him.
Individually as a player.
Not because- not because of you guys.
Yeah, it's fine.
He's jumping off the map.
It's fine.
Thank you for this.
He's hard stuck.
He's fucking hard stuck.
He's never gonna get past Master 5 in his fucking life.
This is- after Squall, this is his whole thing.
He gets- he gets like a shitty time at Squall that he goes and be toxic in Overwatch because it's the only time he feels powerful.
But thing is, it will never fix how shitty of a player he is.
He's not the person he really is.
He'll be like, oh!
Oh!
The reason why like, people are like, shitty towards me is because other people are shitty.
But no, he's just an asshole.
Yo, kill this guy.
Oh, I...
Damn, dude.
Oh my god, did I sleep him?
I did.
I must have sleep him.
I was gonna say.
Nooooooo!
He might rez this though.
Oh.
It's fine.
He didn't get the rez off.
That's fine.
Oh, we don't have a Kiriko.
It's okay.
I'm coming to save the day.
Our supports get out alive and I'm here to save everyone.
I'm so sad.
Listen.
You were asking for it.
I was good.
I don't know.
There's a hog there.
I was good.
I don't know.
Our Cassidy!
Bro!
Bro, Cassidy is like, I don't know about you.
I'm getting healed.
I'm fine.
We will end this now.
Get in there.
Oh my god.
He's actually won.
Please.
There you go.
Oh look.
The one heal of the day on that guy.
Nice.
Wait.
Where's he?
Yay!
We did it!
He sounds like a little... He sounds like a fucking Chihuahua.
Uphill bat.
Yeah, that felt like an uphill bat.
That kid was the uphill bat.
That... Yeah, that child was definitely an uphill... Don't be mean to Chihuahuas.
I'm fucking no bite, bro.
Doki roasting him in chat.
Of fucking course I'm roasting him in chat.
You got his fucking 15 minute of fame.
The thing is, like, he knows Ruben.
I'm pretty sure he knows, like...
I avoided him.
I avoided him and reported him.
But like, the thing is, he knows Ruben was streaming.
So I'm pretty sure, like, he was like...
He was like, trying to do like...
Like...
I guess like, attention... attention whore to Ruben's stream.
But he doesn't realize I'm a bigger streamer.
So that's his reputation now.
He made himself look like a fucking fool.
Alright.
Here we go.
Damn, he played himself.
He's just a... bait streamer.
How did he do that?
I'm going to put it in my lab.
We don't have that guy on our team.
Let's go.
I can hit child.
That was unfortunate.
He was pretty good.
He was pretty...
That guy was yapping the left way too much.
I like... Okay, it was pretty funny.
Our Cassidy...
Seems like you guys were having a good conversation.
I don't know.
The Cassidy was like, I don't know.
I'm getting healed, bro.
Alright.
Yeah.
That's what it seems like.
And he'll never know.
Stop.
That was my favorite part.
When Cassi was backing me up and was like, I'm getting healed bro, I don't know.
Oh no, I'm about to go Kiriko?
Yeah.
Oh my god, he got burned so fucking fast.
I'm scared of getting hooked.
Oh okay, nice.
Nice, he got Genji.
Wait, they get to play Mercy?
And like...
Oh wait, we have a Mercy.
Whoa, where's our fucking Hog?
Oh there he is.
There's our Hog.
Okay, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine, we're fine.
We're fine, we're fine.
That was me.
That Mercy was... How?
How the fuck does he have...
Oh god.
Oh my god, no!
I'm about to go Kiriko.
Goodbye, Cassidy.
Goodbye.
Oh no.
Hog just now got hooked.
That's okay.
They're gonna have Hog ult, I'm pretty sure.
Genji maybe might get Blade in like one more fight.
Cause like, I swear I have not seen the fucking Genji anywhere.
Oh shit!
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
Go, go, go, go, go, go!
Oh, not go, go, go, go, go.
I go.
Why are we ignoring the Kree?
Come on.
I go now.
I got him, so thank you.
I'll work your way up here.
That's what I meant by go.
I'm going Kiriko.
I'm Kiriko time.
I'm giving up on Ana.
Cause we need cleanse.
We need the cleanse.
The other Hog is scared.
Cassidy, Cassidy, please.
Cassidy, no!
I'm trying!
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA surroundings.
I don't know, she was just barely getting out.
Dis frust chillsп It's always Kiriko time.
Since when?
Since you two want.....
They really wanted me.
I even climbed!
I even climbed the wall!
No unnecessary rings!
I don't understand!
Where is...
There's like three different things I heard.
Yeah, they popped so many ults.
I climbed up to avoid the Cassio just to get slashed.
Just get shanked by Genji.
I was on the wrong part of the neighborhood.
Climbing away out of this.
I have to play Kiriko for the cleanse.
This sucks.
This is what happens.
When they have an Ana and we don't.
How do you do this?
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
What?
Oh my god!
Oh thank god!
She missed her anti!
She's just like me!
Oh god.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please, please!
No she's not.
Oh my god.
Who's healing the Mercy?
What?
Good question.
Honestly.
Oh!
Tog'lo!
Yes!
I contributed.
I contributed to this.
Wait.
Oh no.
The Hog's back.
You're by yourself over there.
That's okay.
Is it okay?
Please, please heal.
Please heal me.
Please.
I can't!
I can't heal you!
I'm fucking with our Hog!
No, we cannot.
We cannot.
Our poor Cassidy.
Begging for the heals.
We were all... We were all tunnel version on the Hog.
It was in fact not okay.
All right.
It's fine.
This is fine.
We're so healthy.
This is good.
This is not good.
No!
I'm okay.
Wait.
You!
You just...
I'm okay.
I heard your sound.
They're gonna rez, aren't they?
They're gonna rez.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking called it.
What?!
We had 20 people!
Nobody looked at the hog!
All I'm saying is that we had 20 people and nobody looked at the hog.
Good job.
I knew he got hooked by 20 people.
Kill hog.
No.
I'm not there.
I'm here now.
I'm gonna save my cleanse for him.
Okay, I live these.
You do.
Did you load?
No!
Oh, thank god.
Okay, thank god.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Nothing to worry about.
He missed his hook.
See?
He doesn't have hook.
As long as I don't look at him, we'll be fine.
He doesn't have hook again.
Let's leave.
Oh god.
There you go.
There you go!
We're fine!
Okay.
Nice.
See?
Everything's fine.
He's so low!
Cassidy's right here.
We gotta kill Ana too.
Where the fuck is the Cassidy?
I pushed it, Zamp.
Oh, there's the Cassidy.
You take a lot of damage, huh?
Heroes never die.
What the fuck?
I'm on fire!
What was he doing in that corner?
It's go time!
They're on his one on me.
Oh god.
Oh, they didn't touch!
I should have...
They didn't touch!
We're okay.
Enemy in sight!
You can't hook if you don't look.
Exactly!
If you don't look at the hog, you never get hooked.
That's the game plan.
I told you my Kiriko's not that good.
Don't look at the accuracy.
I like your mask.
I said I like your mask, dude.
See, it's not that bad.
It's all right.
I have to play Kiriko for cleanse.
Let's Kiriko go.
Exactly.
No, no, no.
Don't look at...
Look at...
Oh my god.
Don't look at the heals though.
Don't look at the heals.
Oh, it's just...
Whoa!
Round three.
Capture.
No, no, no.
If you don't look, they don't see.
All right.
Let's see.
Where are they at?
We'll be fine.
You know, I have a plan.
I don't like this plan already.
Let's just do it.
Ow.
Yo.
Oh!
Here's a look.
Yes!
Oh, keep him up!
Keep him up!
Oh, they got the rez.
They got the rez.
And then he got the hook!
Where's this bullshit?
Oh no.
I'm fucking dead.
What?
I'm fucking...
Yeah, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Guys, every time I hear, let's hear a plan, I knew it was not going to be good.
It's never good when you hear, let's hear a plan.
I had a feeling.
Guys, I had a feeling.
Hog's left side.
All right.
I am heading to our hog.
Oh my god!
Cleanse!
This is it!
I saved my cleanse!
Cleanse for that one moment!
The one streamer moment!
I did it.
What?
All right.
I'm rezzing.
I should not do that.
I could have got hooked.
I almost got hooked there.
Bad rush.
Oh god.
No!
Please.
Don't let them flip it.
Do not let them flip it!
Hit your shots!
Go!
The soldier didn't hit the shot.
The soldier didn't hit the shots.
Oh my god.
I'm anti-knife.
I can't do that.
Not like this.
Get up.
Don't get hooked!
No.
He doesn't hook.
Yes.
No hook.
And I succeeded.
And today is the day.
Ana, please.
Ana, he can jump back up.
They can jump back up.
Ana, please.
Please.
He knows how to jump.
Ana, no!
No!
Ana, why would you be there?
They know how to jump.
There you go.
Don't say it's over!
Don't say it, guys!
It can't be over yet!
Maybe I'm just an Ana bot.
Maybe I'm just an Ana one trick now.
Because I could just be an Ana one trick at this point.
I feel like I've had more success as Ana.
I can't believe it.
I do better when I'm on Ana than any other character.
Alright, no more getting picked.
Yeah.
Whoever gets picked, be blamed for the entire game.
Oh god, I'm gonna run away.
I'm gonna be here.
I'm gonna position myself away from everybody.
Save my cleanse for our antis.
No hinders.
Don't die, guys!
You're doing that thing.
No more.
You're dropping?
But our DPS needs help!
I'm on point with Hog ult, by the way.
Oh god.
Wait, what the fuck?
No way!
I thought my Ana's got this!
No, you actually should be winnable.
I'll come back to him.
Oh god.
Really good today.
Nice.
Oh my god!
We still have one more fight though, guys!
We still have one more fight and he's on Doomfist and he's not in Orb.
Okay.
There's still one more fight.
We still have one more fight.
Rook bottom right.
I gotta keep our...
I gotta keep our DPS alive.
Panic fix.
I'll Doomhap.
Praise on me.
This is fine.
Cleanse!
Alright, no throwing.
Got you!
I got you!
It's so winnable!
Nice!
I'm just that good!
We did it!
I fucking knew it.
It's not me.
It was never me.
The comeback.
It was never my fault.
Bro, fuck that kid.
That kid.
He lives right free in my mind right now.
Bitch, I hope you keep losing SR.
Fuck that child!
That's right, I don't need you!
Dude.
It was the chihuahua...
It was the fucking chihuahua.
I think my favorite thing about your dick is how it's not in Orb.
NS, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you!
You know what?
That's my favorite thing too.
I think you're right.
The fact that he's not an orb and I can actually see my tank...
makes so much of a difference in video games.
It's actually crazy.
Jem, thank you for the one gifted chip!
Thank you!
That damn fucking Chihuahua.
Yay!
Here we go.
Zen time!
Because I don't want to play Kiriko!
I don't want to play Kiriko!
Let's make sure we kick all the fucking...
Band of the pillars.
I wish Blizzard World was real.
Is anybody else here up with me?
No?
Okay guys, I can...
Oh no, they have one.
They have a Wonton.
I'm gonna leave.
They have Moira?
No way.
And a Mora.
Ooh, that's scary actually.
Oh, and a Hanzo.
Alright, I'm gonna back up a little bit.
They have like a lot of characters that can actually like poke me and I'll die.
Which I am not a huge fan of.
Why?!
Monkey's sleeping.
He's low.
Or high, high, high.
Oh no!
I'm gonna help with the...
Guys, I think I'm gonna...
Hold up, nah I win these.
Leave.
I'm gonna leave now.
No, no, no, we actually win these.
I am...
Is he gonna touch?
Okay.
I couldn't touch.
But I did my best.
I answered him.
I almost killed him.
I got you my nephew.
Thank you my hero.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Guys, all I'm saying, when I die, I might pick a character...
Their monkey's real low.
Yeah!
That's fucking right!
Now if I...
Oh shit!
Okay, I didn't get headshot.
That's the... Thank God.
I didn't get headshot guys.
Okay.
They have to like go here, right?
Like I might...
I'm fine.
I'm okay.
Oh he is not.
No!
They went auto!
They went auto and D.Va!
Wait, D.Va's sleeping?
It's fine.
I had to die.
It was just canon.
No!
They went auto!
They fucking cleansed this fat ass again!
No!
Every time!
I got my one.
Every fucking time!
I have to fucking...
I have to...
I killed D.Va.
Oh my God, I know.
Okay, you won't be able to do anything with that?
Oh no.
D .Va?
Stop, stop, stop.
Stop.
There we go.
We're fine.
I'm gonna be fine though with this Genji on my ass.
It's okay.
Back to Kiri Jail I go.
You thought you could leave the Kiriko Jail?
Look, I'm playing Kiriko.
Guys, it's because I need to up my win rate on Kiriko, okay guys?
This is the only reason.
No.
Oh no.
Please.
Please don't log me.
Just play.
Please, I don't wanna...
Don't force this off of me.
Just play.
Play.
Do the play.
There you go.
I got you!
Oh, I don't got you anymore!
Guys, I don't got you.
It's Kiriko time.
Back to Kiriko Jail I go.
I love Kiriko.
Woo!
I love being Kiriko.
Yeah!
Cleanse time!
It's time to cleanse!
Time to cleanse all those aunties!
Let's go!
Woo!
Okay, I need to save my...
I need to save my cleanse for it.
Oh!
He ate him!
What's the point of cleansing?
Oh my God!
What's the point of cleansing if he just eats it?
Oh my God, I hope it was at least delicious.
Oh my God.
Guys...
Please.
Okay.
Thank god.
It's okay, they couldn't eat that.
What?!
Okay.
Here I go.
Here I go!
Wooo!
Okay, we needed maybe a Zarya there.
We need maybe...
We need Zarya Symmetra.
We just do better on offense.
We'll do better on offense, right?
Jesse, thank you for the super chat!
Thanks for reading my super chat earlier.
I'm back now.
Good luck on Masters.
It's okay.
As long as I'm throwing other people's top 500 games, I'm fine with that.
As long as I'm giving and taking top 500s from people, I'll be fine.
We're an offense team.
We're an offense team, guys.
This is it.
Really?
We're just an offense team.
This was our legacy.
This was what we're meant to play as.
We were just meant to be...
We were just meant to be Kiriko.
Here we go.
It's fine.
Don't meet that guy, dude.
I was born for this.
I hope somebody loses their top 500 in this game.
Here we go.
This is it.
I believe.
Yay!
Alright.
I caught the anti.
Oh, wait!
Wait!
If he plays...
If he plays fucking Zarya...
I wouldn't have to...
We should just win this for free.
Yeah, we should.
Technically.
That's how it should go, yes.
We got the best player.
Our Ana is okay.
Our Ana is so healthy.
But...
See?
I knew we were in...
I knew we were in the offense team.
Okay, I'm gonna fucking cap.
We don't need heals.
We don't need heals, guys.
We're fine.
All I'm saying...
Is that now that we have Zarya...
I don't...
I don't need to play...
I don't need to play Kiriko anymore.
Because the Zarya was...
Zarya bubbling is our cleansed.
We have tank cleanse.
So I can play whatever I want.
Oh my God!Counter -Picking!
How dare you Counter-Pick in my Overwatch games?
You're all supposed to one-trick a hero.
This fucking sucks.
.
Okay, guys, I changed my mind.
I need help.
Okay.
Okay, I...
Here we go.
I'm dead.
No!
Team wipe!
It's okay, I have rush.
Now I can go D.Va and counterswap their tank again.
Oh my god.
I can't believe people are countering each other.
This is not the Overwatch I remember.
Where are my one tricks?
On the enemy team, but not on my team though.
Not on my team.
No, no, no.
Can't even use my fucking rush because like...
Where are we rushing?
I'm just...
Enemy fight!
Woo, please.
That's fine.
We're fine.
Oh, we're not fine.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
They fucking Sombra took the cleanse.
That's actually pretty awkward.
That's pretty awkward.
All right, we are...
You can nano me this fight and I can just like dive somebody.
All right, we're gonna...
We're gonna play.
Okay, but like hear me out.
Hear me out.
What if we play...
What if we play Brig?
Hear me out.
I barely played Brig, but like I think I can take him on.
Oh my God, we almost see nine.
They almost see nine.
They have Primal.
Nope.
Okay.
Oh!
Oh, my God.
Okay, I hit those.
I hit Zuzu's.
Oh, this is where we died.
This is where we die.
All right, I'm going Brig.
Fuck this.
Hear me out.
This will work.
Guys, hear me out.
This will 100% work.
Hear me out.
I'm gonna fucking counter them so fucking hard.
Alright.
Watch this.
I did it.
I told you.
I swapped Brig and then I did it.
I countered the Winton.
It was that easy.
Oh my god.
It was actually that easy.
Are we... are none of us on the cart?
None of us went on the...
None of us actually went on the cart.
That's actually crazy.
Alright.
Remember when I said I'm gonna counter the Winton?
I did not predict a ult.
Okay.
I can't... I can't stop a fucking monkey ult.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm all... I can't stop a monkey ult.
Alright.
Okay.
Hear me out.
What if I swapped this... Okay.
I can't swap.
I should build an ult first.
I'm gonna build this ult first and then we'll swap.
Monkey too strong.
It was just unlucky.
I'm gonna protect this Ana though.
I'll protect people.
Don't worry.
I'll protect my team.
I'm gonna force guard.
I'll be here with you on cart.
Oh shit.
Please.
Oh!
Oh no!
Please!
I thought the Ana would look at me!
It's okay.
Guys.
It's okay guys.
It's okay.
It was just... Okay.
Maybe it's not okay.
Maybe it's...
Thank you though.
Maybe...
Maybe it's not okay.
I shouldn't be swapping.
Look.
This is it.
More is to pick.
The plan isn't working.
I realized that like...
Maybe I need to know how to play Brig.
To play Brig.
It's definitely not okay.
I feel like I need to know how to play Brig.
To play Brig.
I don't play Brig.
Is that obvious?
Is it obvious that I don't play Brig?
I can't tell.
Oh...
Oh my god...
Bro, this fucking...
This monkey has been...
Bro, please, please, please.
All right.
Oh my god!
This fucking monkey...
It has been chasing me this entire time!
Really?
It's not obvious.
Oh my god.
Yeah, the monkey was so good.
I can't believe it.
You know what?
It was an equal fair match.
The monkey absolutely fucking hated me.
I swear I was getting targeted.
I swear.
This was targeted harassment.
I can't believe it.
It was targeted.
I refuse to believe it wasn't.
It was not me.
Ban him!
Ban him for targeted harassment!
That went through the strongest dokey hater.
He's an anti.
I can feel it.
I can feel the anti in him.
Alright.
I'm on it now.
I'll be on it one trick.
I'm on it one trick.
I'll be an Ana one trick.
Yay!
Alright.
A voice as teammate.
I can't even get him as my teammate because I'm duo'd with a team.
Yo, yo, yo.
How you guys doing?
This is gonna hit something.
Yo.
So, was this wide-cued for you?
No.
This is Diamond 2.
Oh, okay.
Oh, just asking.
A little birdie told me.
A little birdie told you what?
That your tank might be wide-cued.
What the fuck?
What does it mean?
Yeah, you know.
Okay, it's waiting.
Oh, anti!
Huge!
Oh, they have a widow!
They have a widow!
Oh my god!
Oh my god, she's so loud though.
Holy shit.
Her mic is like, peaky.
I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
Not goodbye?
Not goodbye.
Yeah.
I'm gonna have to mute her.
Her mic is so fucking loud.
Yeah!
Okay, my headset's charged.
Okay, there we go.
The mic was so loud.
Yeah, why did I have to crash that set for the Overwatch game?
Why did I have to crash that set for the Overwatch game?
Oh my god.
We're fine.
I can't deal with...
I can't do with my webcam mics.
Alright.
I died!
I did it!
I need a reload!
We're doing it!
Yes!
Look at that!
We're fine!
We also can definitely change CAS.
Where's the CAS?
Speed em up!
Yay!
We're doing it!
Oh.
She's so low!
Please!
Shoot him!
Oh my god, the double hook though.
That's actually gamer.
Right there.
Soldier is scared.
I know my one trick.
Don't be scared.
I'm here to protect you.
I can do this.
Oh my god.
Yep.
Gamers.
Hahaha!
Yep.
Gamers.
Hahaha!
How am I dying?
I'm floating school.
We're...
The gamer experience right there.
We're bottom enemy.
There's soldiers one bottom right.
Please!
He's outside!
And their mercy is on me.
Please!
Oh fuck!
Okay.
Okay, we're gonna roll... ring around the Rosie this.
Hahaha!
The Cassie and I were just...
Did you like the Cassie and I's ring around the Rosie?
Hahaha!
It worked!
Oh no.
No.
I'm really low.
Please.
Doom absolutely dies.
He has no block.
They have no Suzu.
Please.
Please, hard.
No!
It actually works!
Alright.
That's fine.
Wait, did he alt it?
No, he didn't.
Alright.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
How did she live so long?
It's called positioning.
You see that spray?
That's how I lived that long.
Hahaha!
That's how I live.
Coffee.
Oh my god.
Four antis.
I don't know if you guys saw that.
But I antied four people.
Just said.
Stop me.
Enemy in here.
Rosie's...
Oh.
He ended.
Guys, I think he ended.
Oh no.
I'm a little...
scared though.
He has no block.
Can we?
Can we though?
Oh no.
Ah!
Fuck!
I couldn't see!
There was red everywhere!
I couldn't see him!
Nice.
Good job.
Guys.
Alright.
Watch this.
Five antis right there.
No.
Six antis.
Because I'm gonna My antis can transcend back to Overwatch 1.
You see that?
I just antied five people.
Hahaha!
I'm coming back.
I have the ult.
Oh my god.
They're like...
We're barely alive here.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna meat shield you cats!
Oh I can't meat shield cats.
Nooooo!
Bro!
How do I travel?
Hahaha!
Yo.
What?
Okay.
They just...
I'm the only person here!
You're the only one alive!
No I'm dead but why are they using fucking 80 ults?
Haha!
That line.
Alright.
Okay.
Here we go.
This is it.
Oh my god.
She had...
Oh!
I don't even have to look to anti.
That's how good I am.
Hahaha!
I don't care if they go south.
I'm gonna take the shit out of that guy.
Hahaha!
It's that easy.
Nice.
Antis.
Please.
I'm getting harassed.
Alright.
We're okay.
Oh god.
I'm pushing Gaff.
Oh!
Goodbye!
Are you talking about the antis or the antis?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
We're okay.
See?
Yo.
You also sound like you're using a webcam mic.
Why are you talking?
Hahaha!
It fucking sucks!
You lose your right to talk if you have a webcam mic.
I'm talking shit to the antis.
Okay.
Oh.
Ring around the Rosie.
Ring around...
Nah.
Something went wrong with it.
Please.
Get... No!
You don't even... You didn't even get...
Okay.
You killed him.
Alright.
Get me back to 21.
Oh shit.
It's okay.
I have... I have...
A little.
Okay.
No.
It's not my fault!
I'm... Exactly!
Look at our DPS!
They have negative kill.
KD!
The negative KD!
Not us!
Oh.
Don't let them push.
Yo, I'm not backing the fuck up.
Go, go, go, go!
Oh.
Not go for me though.
We lost a lead though.
It's fine that we let them tap.
There you go.
We're going.
We're going as hard as we can go.
Okay.
That's not...
Whoa!
Please don't... Please don't harass me.
Oh god.
If I keep Ruben up everything will be fine.
Please!
He's literally won!
Okay
How?!
I fucking anti this man twenty hundred times!
It's because they hate VTubers!
This is targeted!
You can tell!
This is 100% targeted.
There's no way!
I swear to god.
I swear!
Who gave him a hundred punch?!
Who?!
Look at him!
His punch is at a hundred!
Who gave this to him?!
Focus on!
Okay.
No, you need to say okay with a little more enthusiasm there.
Bro!
I'm funky!
Look at my TPS!
Seven versus twenty four!
Who cares?
That guy sucks!
Seven versus twenty four!
Somebody's not picking it up!
And by somebody I meant everybody!
Except for me and Ruben.
I'm not going to be able to take much of a fight, man.
You go to hell!
This ends now!
My god!
I don't trust my DPS enough to like give them heal.
Give them nano.
Like she did zero!
I am...
Keep me up and win, I promise.
What the fuck?
Wait, there was a murky here?
Really low!
Our team got...
Yeah, our team got diffed hard.
That's a hard avoid.
No!
I can't avoid people!
I assume...
I assume like...
I assume like... I don't know.
Ruben will avoid them for me.
Alright, this is it.
Yeah, the ninja mercy out of nowhere.
Guys, we're not gonna win this.
I'm sorry.
I...
I... I don't think this is winnable.
I'm not gonna lie.
Yeah, yeah.
We lost two.
Yeah.
Ruben, we're...
We're doing everything we can to keep you alive, Ruben!
I...
I knew that was a winnable.
I... I...
I knew... You have late game.
Guys, no amount of healing can save a 9-12 and 9-13.
No amount of healing can save this fucking team.
Like...
Negative DPS.
Both healers have 11k plus healing.
We can't save a fucking stupid DPS player.
The healer... Yeah, the DPS diff was... was just...
...
It's just not... not it.
They just... It's just... It's just not it, guys.
It was just not it.
That's Overwatch matchmaking for you?
Yeah.
Oh, nice!
I avoided those people.
Alright.
Guys, I get one game where I can relax.
Guys, this is my one.
Guys, I can relax now.
It'll be fine.
I won't fuck around.
I won't troll.
I won't troll chat for reals.
Woooo!
Yeah, queues are fast.
I mean, it's prime time.
...
This was me, guys.
Look, see?
It sets the sunsets!
...
This was when I used to be good.
This was when people wouldn't target me because I was a VTuber.
...
The old animated space... Guys, I'm only losing... I'm only losing because people are targeting me.
Say no now.
I used to win because I wasn't VTuber back then, so people would be nicer to me.
...
It's true.
... okay.
Oh my god, it's another Doom.
I might have...
Nooooo!
Oh god.
Oh god, please.
I have 20 people on me.
Bro, what is going on?
Why is there so... Why do we have another...
Why is every... Oh, Sombra for Doom.
Okay, I was gonna say, why is everyone playing Sombra and I realized Doom.
Doom.
I'm going D.Va.
You just gotta beat up the back line.
Alright, here we go.
Honestly, I believe... He's gonna get a kill.
I can... I believe.
Sombra, if you can touch, I can follow up.
Never mind, never mind.
He's not gonna touch, man.
I don't think he can make it.
Let's say, there's no way.
There's no way he makes it.
And we got a pick though!
Woah!
Look at him go!
See?
So fucking easy.
Please don't die.
Oh, please don't!
Guys.
I told you, every time... Every time I get a little bit confident, Doomfist is here to punch me.
To like, slam me to the floor.
Easy.
I got doomed.
I got fucking doomed, man.
I hate this.
The world isn't fair.
Playing Overwatch 2 made me realize the world just isn't fair.
The world is just unfair.
What?!
Bro!
I think she had...
Oh my god, I think she wanted to stick me.
There's no way.
That was 100% a stick.
She's low.
This ends now.
Oh my god.
There's no way.
Soj is actually really low.
Oh, woah, woah.
There is a way now.
There is a way.
Really one.
Oh, please grab your mech.
Get your mech.
Please get your mech.
That's all I want.
Get your fucking mech.
Woah!
Here comes Jotan!
But don't kill me!
I'm flopping.
Kill you.
I'm not relaxed.
There's no relaxing in this game.
There's no relaxing in this game, guys.
Alright.
Back to being my one trick.
Back to one tricking.
Here we go.
And the mech ruined.
Back to my one trick.
It's fine.
We can kill Doom.
He's half HP alone.
Ruben, please peek me.
Please peek me and please don't peek me in a way where I could die.
I fucking... I'm dead.
Please!
The Doom can still die.
Look at this guy.
He's half HP.
Look at him!
Just look at him!
For the love of god!
Okay.
I'll really lead back to Ana.
I hate it.
I got you.
Kill Zen.
Please just look at him.
I swear.
I did not get targeted this hard when I played off stream.
I swear to god.
Things were so much easier.
Kill Mercy.
She's really low.
Oh my god.
Leave me alone.
Just leave me alone.
I don't deserve this.
I've been a good person.
Nice.
Good kill.
He wanted to sticky me so badly.
Oh my god.
He was ready to sticky me.
Woah woah woah woah woah.
Leave me alone!
Holy shit!
I can't breathe!
Leave me alone!
I don't know.
Kill him!
Just kill him!
This is where I die.
Ring around.
He's so low.
Headshot.
Come on.
Pass.
Half left.
I'm good.
Thank you.
Kill Zen.
It's okay.
Thank you.
Somebody kill this man!
Please.
He's so low.
Oh shit.
I am unranked.
Please.
Can I cross?
Do I have enough time to cross?
I'm walking in a straight line.
Please don't headshot me.
Oh no.
Oh no!
Leave me alone!
You're alone now.
Get in there.
Okay.
Alright.
Here you go.
We're fine.
He's de-activated.
It's fine.
We're okay.
We're... We're okay guys.
Nothing to worry about.
Let me leeeave!
Pleeeaase!
Pleast for the love of God.
Oh my God.
I see him.
I see him and I hear the tracer.
Let me live!
I'm on my game now!
Go ahead.
Oh god.
It's fine.
That's good.
They just have Mercy, Zen and Doom.
You win that.
EMP activated.
Oh my god please.
Kill mercy?
Oh my god!
Just kill the Zen!
Kill the Zen!
When you're getting okay, anybody can be afraid of doom when with the way I was being treated
Oh my god
If you saw what I was you guys saw literally what I was going through You guys saw the targeted hate
Oh my god That was oh my god
This is it i'll be okay i'll be okay guys i'll be okay this time there's no way report
Wait, which one's Keep you alive when you're distracted
LOL Mother's work is never done
You're right good thinking guys good thinking fuck
that dude Hahaha And incoming!
Oh my god, they have a Symmetra.
Oh my god, he's on fire.
Oh no.
Oh, we got Zenyatta!
We got Zenyatta!
He's anti'd!
I swear to god!
I swear!
Please!
Don't let him live!
Alright, we're fine.
We're okay.
Oh thank god.
Thank god.
Worst in your previous game.
Okay, that rock needed an anti.
Oh thank god.
Okay, our Sombra is actually...
shutting him down.
That makes me a lot happier.
Knowing that.
Knowing that it's working.
Nice!
We're doing it!
Alright, we're doing it.
Everything is fine.
Enemy fire.
Their Zen is in danger.
Oh thank god!
Guys, guys!
He left me alone!
Now he's targeting Sombra!
He has a new person to hate!
Guys, that wall was so...
That wall needed healing.
You guys don't understand.
Guys, I panicked.
I couldn't help it.
I panicked.
It was so scary.
You don't understand.
Holy shit, he almost burned to death.
I literally got it just in time.
Is that Junkrat?
No, that wasn't.
That was just Doom.
Oh, GG's.
Oh, thank god.
He stopped!
Guys!
He stopped going for me!
Oh my god, the constant hack is actually...
Ring around the Rosie.
Is that guy about people talking shit to his teammates?
No!
Guys, the moment I stop ring around the Rosie...
It was over.
Maybe I was confident.
And being like...
The doomfist is not aiming for me, clearly.
For one moment, I was...
He's not aiming for me.
But...
But he never forgets.
Is he gonna die?
Did he?
Did he totally die?
I couldn't tell.
I can't tell.
Do you think he totally died?
Oh god.
Alright,
so instead of the Doom targeting me...
Now it's like everybody else...
Everybody else is sending in a kill list.
I think this is the worst part of being supported.
Everybody just wants to kill you.
We did it!
Yay!
Who's the Zenyatta?
Did he fucking advertise his Twitch?
And then people are like, report the Zen?
Bro!
And he advertises this fucking Twitch when people are like, avoid the Zenyatta.
Report him.
A 30k bounty.
Alright.
Who do I... I got their Zen and Sim.
Okay, who do I avoid?
Alright, I'm gonna cleanse my avoids list.
Give me a sec.
Let me cleanse my avoids list.
I'm hiding the game so I don't put... I don't put the avoids list on blast.
No!
I can't!
Okay.
Unavoid.
Alright.
Let's see.
Now traveling to prepare for battle.
Select your hero.
I say it as like... I was like, oh I don't want to blast... put somebody on blast.
I say it as I fucking shit talked like 20 different people.
From this stream alone.
Is it time?
Is it?
Alright, here we go.
Oh, we have... we have a...
We have a Junkrat.
That's fine.
It's okay.
It's fine.
You think we can get... we can climb here.
We can do this.
Yeah!
We'll be fine.
Everything will be fine.
I mean, you can tell he's a fucking specialist.
Look at his gold gun.
Look at my... Honestly, you can farm a gold gun in so fast.
I have a... I have a Dilare.
Oh my god.
Alright.
We're just gonna...
Ow.
How?
Nice.
Alright.
We're good.
Oh, thank god.
Wait.
We take those.
Yay!
Free... free!
Free point!
It's okay.
This next ante... watch this.
Watch this next ante.
Oh!
They never expected...
I told you!
Oh shit!
There is people there.
We need SOS.
SOS right now.
Guys.
Don't ever expect the Spanish Inquisition.
Inquisition?
Inquis... Inquisition.
They're on as low...
Okay.
I'll probably live.
I'm fine.
There you are.
Ryan is coming in.
Oh!
I hit those!
Inquisition?
Inquisition.
Yeah!
They never expected.
Oh!
I hear him.
I hear him on the right.
Three antis.
Oh shit!
Ryan!
Please.
What?
Where is he going?
What is he doing?
What is this?
What is this gameplay?
They're Moira's really locos.
I don't think they know I'm here.
Ah!
I'm alive.
We did it!
Yeah!
Yippee!
I saw my life flash before my eyes but we're okay!
We're okay!
I don't think they might know.
I didn't even have to use my ult.
I don't think they know I'm here so Ryan tries to pin.
Here we go.
Can we say that Joki is having her toxic...
Guys, the thing is, playing Overwatch, no matter how PMA you are...
When you're playing Overwatch, there's no way to be positive in Overwatch.
There's no way to be positive about anything when you're playing Overwatch.
Fine.
We can get back Masters here.
PMA streamers are not even PMA.
They're just passive aggressive.
Like, it's just a fact.
They're not actually positive.
They're just extremely passive aggressive.
It's true.
Woah, who is he trying to kill?
Our Junkrat?
Our Junkrat.
Bro, I don't even know who I'm trying to kill.
Oh, please.
Please.
It's so winnable.
Hog, just keep healing.
You're a hog.
You have regen.
He's so dead.
Our team was not ready to help.
Why is this guy typing at me?
Guys, please.
I don't want to be on point alone.
Guys.
Guys, please.
I'm sorry I saw the charge!
I saw the charge and I freaked out!
Nice.
Got my one.
Nooooo!
Nice.
Why is nobody on point?
He has to either shatter me or the Ilari!
He has to pick!
He has to pick one or the other!
And he picked neither!
Okay not gonna lie though, that guy got so much fucking health charge from that.
Oh god, I'm backing out.
Where's our fucking...
Woo!
Oh my god he lives?
More no fed?
Please, I don't wanna get shattered.
Please.
I don't wanna get shattered.
Somebody, somebody come over here!
Go!
I believe!
You versus Ryan!
There you go.
He just TP'd.
Please don't shatter me.
This Ryan is not playing the game right now.
Ryan is not playing the game.
That poor Ryan.
Holy shit.
That Ryan is having the worst time of his life.
This poor guy.
No, don't shatter.
No, no, no, no, no.
I panicked left.
He's anti'd, please.
He's anti'd, just... He has to shatter you or me.
He has to shatter you or me.
He missed both!
He missed...
Fighting his demons.
The Ryan that replays the game.
He actually missed.
What a fucking loser!
He's blaming his teammate again.
Ryan, watch.
Wait, this is playing the game?
Wait...
That's so sad.
Wait, that's...
That's the saddest game ever.
Guys, we just... Guys, I think it's possible.
We just need to win three games in a row.
And then we can do it.
We just need... We just need three games in a row.
Okay, this is it.
Three games in a row.
We got this.
I'm top 500.
I'm gonna make... Actually, no.
I can't make him lose top 500.
Because actually...
Wait, I'm gonna avoid our Junkrat.
Like...
Bro, like... I'm sorry.
But like... Even though we won the game, it's not because of our Junkrat.
There's... There's no... It's not...
It's definitely not because of our Junkrat.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
If she knows... I have 50 games, guys.
You know why?
Because I tried to speedrun to Masters before the stream.
Because I... This account started off as like Diamond.
I mean, it is Diamond now, but it was lower.
This account started off as D4 after placement.
And I tried to speedrun to Masters before the stream.
But it didn't work.
I didn't speedrun.
Alright, here we go.
Alright.
It's okay.
This is our new speedrun now.
This is our new speedrun.
It also like... Did it help that during the speedrun, I was only playing late-night queues?
I was...
It was only... Imagine an Ana wouldn't...
I'm not...
I'm not even on one trick.
I can perfectly play other heroes.
It's just Ana is the most fun and also like my best one.
Chunk for Torb.
Torb is okay.
It's like an extra player.
It's like having like six players.
Guys, it doesn't help that I would play this game at like late-night queues.
And like late-night queues are absolutely the most terrible thing you can ever play on.
I mean, I used to die.
At such a delay, play 1-6.
We had only 40-50 games.
Okay, you guys got the idea.
And I am not even running a game.
I got a trabajame...
A rune box.
They use cutting beneficial to healing of the enemy.
They do.
I haven't seen anymore.
I have never seen one.
Okay, this one.
This one.
I've got to feed later.
Look at that.
Another Susu.
Okay, let's hope he doesn't die.
Because he doesn't because he's gaming.
Gamer of the year.
F***ing course!
Yay!
Easiest game of my life.
We're gonna 2-0 them.
Right here.
I'm gonna bet on it.
I'll bet like $100 that we're gonna 2-0 them.
Look at that!
And the ante!
Who is she?
Even though like a top 500 Ana should be able to ante anything.
But like who is she?
Oh, s***!
It's okay.
We can...
Alright, I'm gonna back out.
I don't think we're gonna win this.
Wait, they're running Sigma?
That's cheating!
Oh, I'm gonna die.
No you're not!
I'm a f***ing healer!
No, I'm not the Sigma.
I can't...
I hate playing Ana against Sigma.
No he doesn't.
Oh no.
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
This is not perfect.
Okay, he just gave him like 100 HP, but that's okay.
Oh my god!
That poor Sigma!
Got cyberbullied so hard!
Shoot the Torp!
It would be so funny.
Beautiful.
Oh no.
That sleep would have hit if the Sigma didn't have shield.
It would have hit 100%.
F***ing hell.
Wait, is that...
Okay, we're fine.
Everything's fine.
Ow!
I got the Cassidy too.
Look at that.
All I'm saying is that because I'm a support, any...
any kills my DPS gets is my kill.
It's the rule of law.
Who is he ulting?
Oh, our poor f***ing Torp.
Wait, more no fade.
We can kill Sig.
Oh!
No!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Not the shield!
No!
Your fat ass took the anti!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Cassidy, take the hit for me.
Cassidy, take the hit.
Take the hit, Cassidy.
I cannot contest right now.
Give me a sec.
It's okay!
I'll contest for us.
I'll show you one on me.
I'll punch him!
Nice.
Sorry, Torp.
Intentional body block, by the way.
Very intentional.
I'm body blocking for the other team.
It's okay.
See?
2-0.
Alright, who wants to bet?
We're gonna 2-0 them.
Guys, I don't have a problem with betting.
He wanted the healing.
Yeah.
Yay!
Yippee!
How are we overwatching?
I think we're like solid even at the moment.
If we win one more game, we're positive.
It only took us 3 hours.
We went through a lot.
If we win one more game, we have a positive.
Win rate.
It just takes one game.
Oh my god!
I'm living life by the edge!
Oh, they have a Zen.
Oh no.
Not a Zenyatta.
Only took 3 hours to break even.
It's just business.
Give me a sec.
Okay.
That's not fair.
It's okay.
I'm also being shot at.
Oh no.
It's okay.
Hanzo might be the dumbest boy alive.
Oh wait, he's alive?
How the fuck is he alive?
It's okay.
I got you.
Oh, I got you.
I have to reload.
I got you.
How are we alive?
Nice.
This game is so trash.
Yes, but what else do I have left?
What was it?
Marvel Rivals waiting room right now.
This is my waiting room for the Marvel shooter game.
They have a hog now.
Okay, they know I'm here.
Oh shit, no shit really?
Ow.
All I'm saying is that if you had streamer mode...
Don't worry, they won't know I'm right here.
Like right here.
They will not know.
They will not look down.
Watch.
Oh shit!
He turned around!
I told you.
They don't know.
They will never know.
I told you.
I knew they wouldn't know.
I got you.
Nice.
Kill him.
Oh god.
He's coming over.
Wait, what the fuck?
What is this soldier doing?
What is this soldier doing here?
Why did our fucking Ana get killed like that?
What the fuck?
I got jumped down from the top rope.
Where was my bodyguard?
That was my first step.
I hope the Cassidy dies in game.
We should all be 1-1-1-1-1.
Alright.
This is so un-changed.
Okay.
That's fine.
This is perfectly fine.
Yes, it's perfectly fine.
This is not fine anymore.
I would have...
Okay.
All I'm saying is that I could have actually 100% killed the Cure girl.
With just my game.
GG.
Nice.
No!
The Cassidy lived!
Press all the Qs.
I don't know how I lived there.
Guys!
We got a positive win rate!
We were here!
Guys!
A positive win rate!
The Doki luck is real.
I can't believe it.
For today.
We got a positive win rate for today.
Oh my god!
I just need two more wins!
It's so possible!
We got a positive win rate for today!
We can do it!
It's like...
Oh my god!
It's so winnable!
I believe in us!
There's no way!
It's not like we're gonna lose like five games in a row.
Guys!
It will take me like...
I bet you in four hours!
In four hours!
We can...
We can finally have a positive win rate!
We
can finally have a positive win rate!
This is it!
I believe!
Okay, I'll let you guys see how bad my Kiriko win rate is.
I'll let you guys see.
It's actually pretty fucked up.
It's pretty bad.
This is my most played int for this season.
It's really bad.
Okay.
Anyway.
Now speaking of Kiriko.
Actually I won't.
I don't wanna play Kiriko.
I actually don't wanna play Kiriko.
Bro!
I hate this map so much!
I actually hate this map.
Like so much.
I wish they would...
remove this map.
Okay!
21 and like 3 at the...
Right now!
I swear!
I swear it's not because of me though.
Every time I lose as...
Every time I lose as Kiriko, it's not me.
It was never me.
I swear.
I swear guys.
It's never a me issue.
All I'm saying.
Here we go!
Yay!
I hate this map though.
I hate this map so much.
Ugh!
It's not me.
It's my tank and DPS and other support.
Hello!
Alright.
Wait.
I went the wrong way.
I'm sorry.
I don't know why I went this way.
My actual teammates are over here.
Oh!
That's a good!
What the f...
Where did the chunker came from?
Holy shit!
Where did he come from?
What the f...
Alright.
This is a little awkward that we lost that.
We got the initial pick too!
Wait.
I don't know if it's Sol.
It's a streamer mode name.
But like...
If it's not, then he's actually...
I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
I leave.
Guys, I might lose my positive win rate right here.
I have a plan.
I wanna go under.
I might lose...
Guys...
There might be a moment where I lose my positive win rate.
Maybe.
It's possible.
And then he's...
Hold up.
Leave him.
Did we leave him?
I don't think we left him.
I don't think...
Please!
Cleanse me!
I'm important!
Guys, I didn't get cleansed.
I didn't get...
I don't...
What cleanse?
Our Kiriko only cleansed themselves.
See?
This Kiriko looks...
like a person with a 29% win rate.
Not gonna lie.
I bet you that Kiriko has a worse win rate than me.
on Kiriko.
I was fucking around.
I was fucking around!
Why would a Samba be right there?
Why would she be right here?
Guys!
Like, why would she be right here?
Why would she be right here?
Oh my god!
Like, how?!
How do you, like, add her a spawn?!
Okay, here we go.
Just Samba things.
I swear.
Target it.
100% target it.
There's no way.
There's no way it's not targeted.
I'm just gonna...
Go.
I'm dead.
No more go.
They're all low.
Oh my god!
Alright.
Good kill.
I am going to go Zenyatta.
What?!
For the Widow?!
Did she just solo ult to get you?
Yeah!
For Widow?!
That's crazy.
That's... kinda fucked up.
Goodbye, positive win rate.
I don't need to kill her.
I got her in my heal.
It was nice having a positive win rate for a little bit, though.
I had a good time with that.
It felt really good.
For like one second.
They're taking the top right now.
Which means we can go top.
Wait a second!
You got a touch!
Oh shit!
I didn't realize.
That's fine.
We weren't winning that fight.
Alright.
I'm gonna die.
Might as well.
Guys!
No, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
This is it.
This is the plan.
This has to be the plan.
Right?
This is it.
There's no way.
It would be so funny if I get railed right here.
It would be so funny.
Two kills!
This is it!
I knew it!
I fucking knew this was the plan.
I miss the character.
I knew it.
I knew it, guys.
This was the plan all along.
Alright.
All we have to do is...
Make sure our Widow is pocketed.
What the fuck?
Why is there three people here?
Behind us.
Oh, that's not good.
Yeah, this is not good at all.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
It's not fine anymore.
Kiriko, it's not fine.
It's not fine at all.
No!
Riven, you're the only one left!
You know, I got a little ambitious.
No!
It's okay.
It'll be different here.
It'll be different.
I believe.
I just realized how big I am on the screen.
I hope that has not been affecting the gameplay.
After three hours, I realized, whoa, I'm like one fourth of the screen.
It's fine.
Oh, see the bubbles!
Make it bigger.
I got you!
Wait, okay.
Okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
We're fine.
Not quite.
We need it bigger.
Nice, we did it.
Woo!
That was a little ambitious.
They used EMP, they used Rush, they used Queen ult.
That was very ambitious.
No bigger gold.
I can't see shit.
Make it bigger.
Oh, oh, there he is.
I'm a little scared.
Just a little scared.
Just a little bit.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
It's fine.
It's not fine anymore.
It is absolutely not fine.
Fiam.
Fiam's last words.
Guys.
It was nice having a...
I think it was like...
It was pretty cool having a positive win rate though.
It was pretty cool.
I...
I had a good time.
Seeing what that was like.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey Doki, how's it going?
I ordered Chipotle.
We were... it was a reversal?
Are you fucking kidding me?
That shit was so rough.
That shit was so fucking rough.
And it was a fucking reversal.
That's actually crazy.
I worked so hard.
By the way, for those who don't know what reversal means.
Reversal is basically the...
Our team was considered...
Stronger than the enemy team.
But that's not true.
There's no way.
I refuse to believe that.
Anyway...
But yeah, those were my stats.
It's a little...
It's not the best.
Alright,
here we go.
It's okay, we win this, we're back to positive.
Alright.
Guys.
I don't know what to do.
Actually, no.
Actually, but like, what if?
But like, what if?
This is how we break the curse.
I am bronze player and the gameplay looks the same.
Actually, nano blade.
This is it.
Nano blade.
Oh shit!
This guy doesn't heal.
This guy is a DPS Lucio.
This guy...
Okay.
I'm gonna be doing all the healing here.
He keeps me sharp.
Wait, who said that?
1000 on Joki losing?
Okay, Brados McGee!
I'm gonna remember you.
I'm gonna fucking call you out if we win this.
Why do I have this individual on my team?
What did I do to hurt God?
I'll just tell you.
This Lucio is a DPS Lucio.
So, I'm gonna be doing all the healing soon.
I'm gonna be doing all the healing soon.
Here we go.
Alright.
I have a ram.
Watch this.
I'm watching.
Oh, he's on time!
He's on time!
What?
There's no way he...
Okay, I was gonna say.
I'm gonna install this game right now.
I have to fix my frames.
What?
What frames?
You're on Lucio.
People who have no frames will play Lucio.
Hold on.
You wanna see something crazy?
What?
Watch this.
I'm gonna...
I'm tied?
You're gonna jump off the bridge in the altar, right?
No, I'm gonna make...
Oh my God.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay.
I have to reload.
Let's go.
No, actually watch this.
Come over here.
No!
Stop doing streamer things!
Stop!
Stop doing streamer things with the game!
Play to win!
Don't play for streamer moments!
That's all I asked for!
We don't need streamer mo...
We don't need streamer mo... cool streamer clips!
But the content...
The content is winning!
I try to play the best I can!
And I still make content.
That's just a fucking content diff right there.
I'm not saying content diff.
But... content diff.
No, you're new.
Let's put like 400 alts right now.
Oh my God!
The 2k!
We definitely do not.
Is the Bob there?
Is the Bob still there?
Oh my God.
Nice.
Now you do what?
This?
What?
But my hog is just so terrible.
We're good.
One continent let's show care.
Like a neon hog.
Literally neon hog.
Oh no.
They're making content.
They're trying to make content again.
They're trying to make content again!
I'm pushing the ash, bro.
You're inting!
No!
How does...
What the fuck?
Bro, he got outjunked!
Watch this.
He got outjunked so hard!
Keep watching.
I made space.
Guys, one day.
One day.
Bring me back to days when making content was winning the game.
Bring me back to the good old days.
Overwhelming.
Not true.
It's like years of zombies.
Literally you and he, right?
Please don't let me die.
I'm your only hope, Gengu.
Gengu, please.
Gengu.
Come on.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Please.
Our Gengu died with a nano blade.
Our Gengu died.
Our Lucio died with a Lucio.
Our Hog's gonna die too.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Here we not go.
Alright.
I think it's time.
No, I don't think so.
It's all about the epic fail.
When you close your ears.
Ba-da-da-da-da-da-da.
Ba-ba-ba-da-da-da.
Yay.
To be fair though, if you're streaming this game non-stop, you have to figure out some ways to make this engaging.
to make this engaging.
But then, to be fair, people watch Shroud.
There's an audience for people who just wanna watch winners.
I'm dead.
How did he find me?
Oh.
Okay.
I saw that.
I was like, how did he know?
Okay.
There's still an audience for people who wanna watch people win games.
Look at Shroud.
His personality is literally winning video games.
And being good at video games.
Oh, I almost got the ram.
What Shroud?
He's a...
He's a boomer that is good at any FPS game he touches.
And TPS game as well.
He's also a millionaire.
I hear you.
From Matra.
Okay, I gotta go.
Am I gonna die?
I'm dead to this.
I'm not dead to this.
We're fine.
We can do this.
I have ult.
Which if he comes to win.
Okay.
Alright.
Here you go.
It'll be fine.
We might have the Junkrat.
But we'll be fine.
Okay.
I'm watching.
I'm watch... OOOH!
That's actually good!
That's actually a good bomb!
There you go.
We're doing it.
Is Doki winning?
Define winning.
Being even in my win rate percentage right now for today.
Even...
After 3 and a half hours.
He'll be fine.
I don't think he'll remember the one time you spawn camped me.
4 years ago.
Okay.
To be fair...
Any good gaming moment, I remember.
Wow!
Can't die.
Why am I flying into them?
I only remember that because I was looking through old screenshots on my PC.
Ohhh...
You're so proud of spawn camping me?
I wish!
Three years ago I was playing Ana!
What's going on?
I wish I kept my old... I wish sometimes I kept my old videos and old clips.
Because I had a moment where I spawn camped... not spawn camped, but like I...
I caused him, the tatman, to like rage so hard in the game that like he... he like...
He like rage quit overwatch.
Oh no...
No, I didn't keep any of it.
It was like on my old old PC.
I didn't keep any of it because I never, you know...
I never thought I would have to look back at it again.
Oh, he's so dead.
You know, it was a good push.
It was not winnable.
The good old days.
I used to have clips of like moments where like I have like big streamers rage at me because I was... I used to be good.
I...
It was like Tim, the tatman, Moonmoon and...
Who is it?
It was like Tim, Moonmoon and one... a DPS player.
I don't remember who.
I wish I had the clips though.
I wish I had the clips.
Always play Ramatra, right?
Okay Zenyatta time.
All that lost content.
Yeah.
If I still had my tweets from like before a time, I would have...
What do you mean?
If I still have the clips, we would...
Lucio is such a good hero.
Or tweets from back then, then we could have it.
That's just not true.
He's my...
The lost media.
Was a stream sniper?
I wasn't a stream sniper.
It's just I... He would have been high elo games and they were in high elo games.
I'm saying go through my profile and look my winrate on every other character.
Yeah, I made Tim, the tatman rage quit Overwatch.
You like literally got off Overwatch and like quit the game because of me.
He even like solo shattered me too.
I was like fuck this Lucio.
Alright buddy, I'm gonna sit here and wipe my mouse down while you... yeah.
Tim, what are those names?
He... Tim, the tatman.
The tatman used to be like one of these streamers.
Umm... on Twitch.
And now MooMoo is just a GTA RP streamer.
Oh, I should go hog.
Let's see.
You know they say like the camera adds 10 pounds?
I think picking hog adds like 40.
Oh fuck, fuck, fuck, fuck.
I discredited him.
I think he wants to punch me now.
I personally think Doomfist dies.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Wooo!
I did that.
I did that smile.
Oh, I gave him punch.
I gave him punch.
Whoops.
Oh... did I?
Okay, please get your mech.
Please get your mech.
That's all I want.
Oh!
I didn't give him punch this time.
I didn't commit a mistake.
Oh.
I squished him.
No, no you didn't.
Please, please.
Don't die.
You're welcome.
Okay, buddy.
Guys, we need assistance.
I'm just like a human crit hit.
Just kill one person.
That's all I care about.
Say your human is pushing it.
Hahaha!
Thank you.
I'll take it as a compliment.
Oh.
Guys.
Kill anything.
I'll take any kills.
Kill anybody.
Wait.
Nice, nice.
That's a good wall.
We got the bombs.
Put my bomb in front of the enemy team's window.
I have to save my trans for the male.
What rank is this?
D1 to Master's III.
Is the rank.
Guys.
Please.
Guys, if I die, we lose.
If I die, we lose.
Alright.
Nice.
Squirted Mora.
I'm killing Light Weaver.
Hit.
Oh god, not hit anymore.
Nooooo!
No!
Please!
Please kill them!
Please, just kill the Doom!
Why is this guy still spying?
What are you doing?
Please, just hit the Doom.
There you go.
We're fine.
It's okay.
We still have our... We still have transfer mail.
We're fine.
This is where I might die though because the Doom is looking at me.
Oh, I do not like where I'm positioned right now.
Wait, he's... What?
Where is this?
It's okay.
It's okay, Ruben!
It's not okay because I'm so on this position now!
This is fine.
I sacrificed my life for the position for that.
It was actually not okay.
Ow.
No, Ruben.
If you DM the Venture, I would only lose.
Oh.
There you go.
The Venture would have died.
Please!
Nice!
We're fine.
Wait, what?
We're not fine.
There's an Adventure up there.
I was walled and I got full Venture combo and I had no answer.
It's okay.
Capstir lives those.
The Mei also missed her...
I know.
I saved that chance for 20 years just for the Mei to fuck up her ult.
What?
No way I don't pick this.
There's no way.
Somebody break the thing!
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Thank you.
I don't know what that guy is doing, but...
I...
Merry-go-round.
Merry...
What the fuck?
I'm just trying to...
Okay.
Goodbye.
Holy shit.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
We can touch.
I will touch.
I didn't play Brig.
Why Brig?
No!
Not the Mei!
Wow!
I guess I'll die here.
Dipstick.
Okay.
To be fair, we do have a Junk player.
To be fair, guys.
We have a Junk player.
Oh, my God.
Someone, please!
Break the wall!
I can't hear!
Oh, no.
Oh no.
He's so low!
Burn him!
Just kill him!
What the fuck is this wall?!
Okay.
I'm actually mad.
We don't need to overchase.
They should be close to us.
Be careful.
I'm almost at rally.
I slept somebody.
Bro, that fucking...
Push the meter.
I need care.
I'm almost at rally.
I have rally.
I have rally and one more stun.
Oh my god.
I'm shooting the wall.
I'm coming.
I'm under Mei.
Okay.
I have to reload.
We gotta kill Mei after I...
No!
Mei low.
Mei one.
The tire clutch!
They have Mei ult though.
They have Mei ult.
Okay.
Big.
Oh my god.
We only have... We only have tectonic.
What do they use?
What?
Meteor?
They have Mei ult.
We just have tectonic.
We need to...
We need to try and like farm nano here and like maybe use tectonic for... so we can build a farm.
Bro.
I'm so... I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
I'm on Mei 24-5.
Nice.
What are you doing?
Brick tree.
It's tectonic.
Carrier Avenger.
Flicker Avenger ult.
Marnialfame.
No!
I can't do anything!
The Avenger is behind us!
Please!
No!
The fucking Avenger flake!
The Avenger flake!
We almost have nano.
3% off if you can live.
No!
The Avenger flake!
Bro!
Where the fuck?
Nobody fucking helped me!
No one helped me for the Avenger flake!
He said focus Avenger!
Bro!
No one helped me when I spammed the Avenger flake!
That's actually tilting.
RIP Doki's 1k.
You see, I have a solution for this.
What 1k?
I don't know what you guys are talking about.
I'm gonna use the fucking...
Now I'm negative win rate again.
That's sad.
Alright,
I'm gonna use the bathroom.
We are back.
Chat.
Yo, yo, yo.
How you guys doing?
Shit!
I'm back.
It's okay.
It's okay guys.
Everything's okay.
We're okay.
It's okay.
We can do this.
Just in time.
Is he gonna make portal?
There you go.
Yay, portal!
Watch this.
Hell yeah.
Get predicted.
No, no, wow.
Oh my god, they have a junk as well.
Was this the junk from the last game?
I can't tell.
No!
Wait, the ram is anti.
He can die.
Can he?
Are you sure?
Are you sure about that?
Are you...
Are you 100% about that?
Okay, nice.
He can die.
He's antied again.
Good job.
I can keep doing this forever.
Okay.
I actually might have to go Kiriko because they have Ana.
Oh wait, they don't!
They don't have Ana!
I can stay!
Get back here!
I can stay Ana!
I don't have to go Kiriko!
Oh my god.
Oh, saw life flash by before my eyes.
Okay.
Whoa, I have nano in like one game.
Holy shit.
I just build it off of... that means they have DPL assault soon.
Because I fucking farm this nano off of.
What?
Alright, I take those.
Okay.
Go!
Just do anything!
This is the anything nano!
There you go.
I just don't miss.
It only took four hours to warm up, guys.
It just took four hours to warm up but we're here now.
We're here, we made it.
We fucking made it!
You fucking made it!
Where's the Pharah?
I was like, does he exist in my game?
Guys, I also hit those.
Let's see.
Oh, he's so dead.
He's so fucking dead.
I'm okay.
He's so dead.
I'm not okay.
I lied.
Why did you not run out?
I'm under attack!
Alright, I guess I'll back up a little bit.
I guess I'll... Thank you.
The Junkrat helped me back up.
Oh, alright.
And we all split up.
Please.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Oh my god, we're okay.
I told you I'll be okay.
Alright, all DPS are at different angles.
Where do we go?
I don't know.
Oh, I see.
Which is the right side to look at?
I don't know.
Oh, my HP.
There you go.
It is winnable.
Oh, he's just better.
He's just better.
I told you.
We'll be fine.
I missed.
He has to die.
No, we lost our fucking...
It's not the theory.
So this is winnable.
Is it?
It didn't feel winnable for me.
Oh, wait.
They flipped.
Oh, it is winnable.
It is.
My first death.
No.
I'm so sorry.
Okay, he apologized.
It's okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's alright.
Okay, guys, I bet we're going to win four games in a row.
I can feel it.
I can feel it guys.
Four games in a row.
I have more damage than the fucking Brig.
I can fucking feel this.
They also, they don't have a Kiriko.
Let's go.
So they don't have to cleanse.
Surely.
All I have to do is just one Trigana.
Then we can do this.
First game watching the other healer carry?
What do you mean other healer?
I'm carrying!
Alright.
Nice.
Are they going?
No they are dude.
Ow.
Oh I hit something.
Cool guys don't look at antis.
Oh shit nice.
There you go.
He's also asleep!
He did not have a good time!
Holy shit!
That man got fucking bullied.
Oh my god!
That poor guy!
That poor man!
That guy was not having it at all.
No!
He has an Ana!
It's gonna be Kiriko's duty soon!
No...
It's Kiriko time.
And a Widow!
Bro what?
Bro...
Bro please have mercy.
Oh please don't look at me.
Please don't look at me.
Guys...
Guys... I have to... Guys...
I have to...
I have to play Kiriko.
No...
It was gonna be a happy moment.
I could have felt happiness for a second.
Oh woah!
Jesus Christ!
Oh I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
He almost has Visor though.
I need to wait for first one.
Oh that's nice.
Oh!
Oh this is not good.
This is not good.
There's no way he can die.
There's no way.
We...
See we did it!
We did it!
We're doing it!
Okay...
Now we're doing it.
Alright...
We're doing it.
Now we're doing it.
Yeah.
I have cleanse.
I can't do anything now.
Sorry.
Are you fucking...
The fucking bait.
The fucking bait right there.
Oh he did!
Oh!
There you go.
The double headshot!
Where is she?
Sagger her.
Alright there you go.
Hanzo buff.
Yeah I heard about the Hanzo buff.
Please.
Not the Hanzo buff though.
I'm tired of Hanzo buffs.
Alright I'm helping.
I'm helping.
Oh!
Woohoohoo!
Okay that hook was actually insane though.
That was an insane hook.
We can literally kill him.
Bam!
Thank...
I saw it live.
What an insane hook.
You should have picked Mercy.
I won the game!
What do you mean I should have picked Mercy?
Okay guys.
We're almost back.
Guys we're at a positive win rate!
I think.
I can never tell anymore.
I can't tell anymore.
You've been killing me for so long.
I don't know which is positive and which wasn't.
I might as well make my waiting room right now for the next stream.
Just in case.
I'm gonna make my waiting room for the next stream.
Cause it's a good night dra- Alright guys give me a title.
What should the title be for my good night dragoons number 3?
Guys.
What should the title be?
Hey Doki it's my birthday today!
Any chance I could get a happy birthday from the coolest thief around?
Thank you for the super chat!
King thank you thank you!
Of course!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear King!
Yeah!
We're not stopping until we get...
Wait what's top 500 right now?
What is it?
Competitive leaderboard.
This is on Asia because I made my account where I used to live in Asia.
So that's a little awkward.
Alright.
Masters 4?
Okay we're not stop...
Okay we're gonna stop at Masters 5.
I have no patience to keep going.
I have no patience to play this.
That's way too many games to do.
Okay what is this...
Uh...
We're not gonna get 700k.
We're not gonna get 700k subscribers today.
I don't think so.
Uh...
We're like 1000 off.
That's way too many thousands.
One is way too many thousands.
That's a little sentence.
Alright, let me see.
I'm gonna put thumbnail art here.
That's just one.
Someone had like, what was it?
Post overwatch detoxing after Overwatch 2.
That's good.
Winners after party.
No!
Don't say I couldn't reach Overwatch.
I couldn't reach Masters.
That's not true.
That's not true and I'm gonna show you guys.
Post overwatch suffering.
I like that.
I got Masters.
Yay.
That's gonna be the title.
I got Masters.
Yay.
Hey.
Oh hey!
This guy likes...
He likes...
He likes barbecue.
That's...
That means barbecue, right?
See?
That's the cue, right?
That's what it means.
Barbecue lover.
Oh my god.
Yeah.
He likes barbecue but specifically the chicken in barbecue.
That's why...
That's why... No!
He likes the BBC News!
I almost forgot!
He must be British!
Guys!
He must...
He must love the BBC News!
He's from British!
He's playing on NA servers!
He's EU playing on NA servers!
It has to be it!
Shit.
What else could it be?
I don't understand.
If it's not the BBC News, what else could it be?
There's no other alternatives.
The BBC News is copyrighted.
It's trademarked.
Guys!
All I'm saying... BBC News is trademarked so it can't be anything else.
Oh my god.
This fucking ham is just going a merry-go-round.
Oh.
Poor... I think we... I think we are... Oh!
Oh!
I missed through that.
I missed through that hard.
Goodbye.
They don't know...
They do!
They didn't know that.
Oh my god.
You live.
Go!
Huge cleanse.
I mean it was pretty big.
This is as big as BBC News.
No Suzu?
There you go.
Oh!
We can kill Brig.
Can we?
Can we though?
I don't think so!
Oh shit.
Wait, we got the D.Va mech though.
Okay.
We gotta kill Sombra.
Oh no.
I'm... No!
Guys, I don't think... I don't think we got this guys.
I don't think we got this.
How can your team knock... That is a very good question!
Team?
How could you guys not kill her?
She's so dead.
I forced the fucking...
Alright, I'm just gonna TP here.
I'm gonna force this.
And then I'm gonna TP back up top.
And that's how portals work.
I don't... I don't... I have to stay as main healer because we have Mercy so heal...
Zen is really bad with... Zen is so bad with Mercy heals.
Because there's not enough heals for Mercy.
So I have to play as a main healer.
Oh, I feel...
I'm like thinking about maybe going Ana.
But like I feel like I'm just gonna get harassed as...
I feel like I'm gonna get like hard like fucked over as Ana.
Oh my god!
Me?
I'll try.
Woo!
I can try Ana.
I'll try Ana and see if I'll be okay.
Cause like looking at this...
I don't think my team will save me from the Hamlin Tracer dive.
So I can't tell.
I mean we'll see.
We'll see if I'll survive.
I got you.
Enemies on the payload.
Let's get them.
We just need a Sombra.
We literally just need a Sombra.
And then we should be fine.
Why can't the news help us now?
Aww.
Nice.
Good kill.
We can kill both.
Why is this...
There we go.
Goodbye.
Guess I die.
Oh, guess I'll die again.
Guess I'll die again.
Yes, I'll die again.
Face your eyes Ohhh...
Guys...
This game is rough.
This game is absolutely rough.
That was really tough.
This game is absolutely...
All I'm saying...
Is that I know I'm avoiding a person here.
Easy Gamer.
We gotta kill their support!
No!
I slapped him!
He lives!
He fucking lives the D.Va bomb!
That's absolutely fucking crazy!
He actually lives the D.Va bomb.
I'm too fast for you.
Don't kill me.
There you go.
Can you kill Marge?
I can try.
I did my part.
Can you kill Kiri?
I don't want to get off.
Whoa!
Alright.
What a match.
Now we have two more minutes to hold this.
Let's go.
We used almost everything.
Alright.
I'm just not...
I'm not very confident with the Mercy pick right now.
With the Hammond and Tracer.
Straight on.
Oh!
End game!
Nanner full time!
Let's go!
Let's fucking go!
Oh!
I feel even more confident now!
Oh god.
I'm fucking protecting you right now.
I'll heal here.
Please Mercy.
They're breaking dice!
Oh god!
Oh!
I'm alive!
No!
I'm depressed.
Guys!
I don't want to stand on the cart but I will do it for gaming!
Oh!
Oh god.
He's low!
Please!
I fucking killed...
Get off the point!
No!
I just got nano too.
I live for so long on the cart.
Because no one else wants to go on the cart.
Why is the poor Ana on the cart duty?
Why?
The poor Ana has to be on cart duty.
The old lady.
Somebody give me a life alert.
This old lady should not be on cart duty.
Please BBC News!
Save us!
I've got a good feeling.
This could be our family's fault.
Okay.
Post Overwatch.
Relax stream.
There we go.
Alright.
I'm just making my waiting room right now.
Because we have to.
You want to try dive?
Okay.
Just one more mission.
9pm.
Yeah, I think it's ready.
Are the streams at 9pm?
I don't even remember.
I'm gonna hack the Ana.
Okay.
I'll go Kiriko then.
This is fine.
There we go.
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna get Masteries, guys.
We'll be so relaxed by then.
Okay.
Why can't the BBC News help us?
I don't understand.
There's a reason why I don't want to go.
There's always two or whatever.
I can't.
I'm dying.
Maybe I should care.
See?
More on the Mercy.
No, no, no.
Not ready.
Why did I decide to play fucking Kiriko?
I knew playing Kiriko was a mistake.
I knew it.
I knew it was a mistake.
The game give it and the game take it away.
Nice.
Holy shit.
We like, stuffed that ball.
That ball.
That ball needs to be put down.
In the game.
He's old.
He's too old.
Alright, here you go.
Ignore ball.
Fuck him.
That body ball was really good though.
Enemy here!
All I'm saying is that that ball has lived past his life.
I swear to God.
Put that rodent down.
It's a pest.
Oh my God, he's so low!
Someone quick!
I'm on cart.
Breeze brings relief.
We literally...
Okay, honestly, all we need is just a Sombra.
That's literally all we need.
I swear.
Oh, we do have a Sombra!
I did not even know...
This is how irrelevant our Sombra was.
I didn't even know we had a Sombra.
Guys, our Sombra should not have been pushing the cart.
Our Sombra should not have been pushing.
He needs to be out there to get rid of this rodent infestation.
Our cast is half-exceeded.
Okay.
Bye.
EMP activated.
EMP?
Bro!
You need EMP this guy!
This guy is the one that needs to be...
Please, please!
Move!
Push up!
Why?
Oh my God!
Why did you guys AFK?
I literally couldn't TP.
What is this?
I can't believe it.
They are all so...
Watch that.
I'm going to shake the fake Bastion.
Someone get rid of that.
I'm going to get rid of this Hammond.
That's all I care.
I'll get the job done with you, Tracer.
Please.
This is for you and Kiri up there, Tracer.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, BBC News.
I'm here to help you.
I'm getting rid of this turret.
Oh, never mind.
Helping is over.
Thanks.
Oh, thank God.
Thank fucking God.
Their Torb is alone on the left.
Don't worry.
Wait.
He's a bug.
Oh, nice.
I did it.
I did not expect this.
But oh my...
How?
Enemy in here.
There you go.
We're fine.
We are not fine.
Oh, God.
Get rid of the turrets.
Please get rid of this.
Bring no bash?
No.
How is the Brig still alive?
We are very capable of killing Brig here.
Are we?
We're not!
Oh god, I'm not feeling... Oh nice!
Two kills!
Please, we just need to get rid of the bot.
That's all I care about.
Someone please... just get rid of this one thing in my life.
I have... I have... Rush!
Just live!
Okay, nice.
Not nice.
Absolutely not nice.
Absolutely not good.
Unless... please.
Please just kill the bot.
Please, he's just ring-arounding the Rosie right now.
I failed.
I'm begging of you.
Please, he's still alive!
We have to kill Brig.
No!
I clapped!
Guys, I clapped!
Oh my gosh, he's alive!
Where's my clap?
I gotta get off.
Clap gone.
Are you gonna win this?
You're gonna win this.
Guys, I don't think they're gonna win this, guys.
We don't want this.
Bro, we're like... we're super staggered.
Oh no.
Oh no!
I'm gonna be staggered too.
JK, I'm the gamer.
Alright.
Here we go.
This is it.
Oh.
It's just not meant to be.
You know?
Just not meant to be, you know?
It's just... just not meant to be.
I can feel the Tracer looking for it.
Oh, come on!
You fucking...
They're anti.
That's an anti.
Goodbye.
This is where I die.
It was nice knowing you.
I got you.
Wait, you can DM that?!
That's crazy!
I didn't even know you can DM that!
Holy shit!
Wait, this changes everything!
Wait, that's actually insane.
I did not know that.
I'm getting on Tracer.
Right side, half HP.
That's actually insane.
Okay.
Please, it's literally Hammond.
Again.
It's literally Hammond again.
Oh my god!
I got saved!
My hero!
Academia.
I didn't know that!
Why the fuck did any of the other Divas ever DM me from this?
Oh my god!
Okay, I should go.
I don't think I should go.
Defense-wise, I don't like going defense.
Actually, no, I should go Ana for Hammond though.
For Hammond.
I really hate playing...
I hate playing...
Defensive Ana on this map.
But because they have a Hammond, I feel like I should... might as well.
I feel like I should.
Oh my god!
My fucking hero!
Just one more mission.
Maybe if I put the spray in front of them, they'll get intimidated and stop harassing me.
I don't think anyone... I didn't know.
I didn't know you can... I know you can punch deflects now.
Or unless that was a bug, because I punched a Genji deflect.
And got the kill.
Alright.
There you go.
We either win this or lose this horribly.
We'll find out in the next episode.
Doki has been playing Overwatch for four hours now.
Whoa.
Echo ball.
Please.
I can't.
I got knocked over.
We're so fucked.
Come on, I fucked up.
I got knocked off.
We needed help.
We all needed help.
Holy shit.
I'll get out.
Will I get out?
Let's find out.
I did.
Wait, are we contesting?
Oh no.
Oh.
Maybe I should have went Kiriko.
Maybe I should have went Brig.
But Brig is not that much healing so I was conflicted.
Oh nice!
Nice kill!
Ante too!
Cleanse!
Trying so hard to keep you up.
Don't worry.
The news.
I've got the news.
He's at the end.
He's so low!
Go!
Oh god.
Oh my god.
This is the last...
Please.
Please!
Brig!
Are you fucking kidding me?!
Oh my god!
Please!
I might be dead here...
I swear to god.
I can't.
Oh no!
This is so risky!
This is fucking...
No!
Please!
Okay, I can heal from here.
I can heal from the far.
As long as he doesn't harass me, we're fine.
Please.
The longest fight of our fucking lives.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Get this fucker away from me.
Get him away!
Jesus Christ!
He's won!
I'm so sad.
I'm actually so sad.
This hamster lived for so long.
We just don't kill the healer.
I get harassed so much.
Does the MP just go for the healers?
Oh my god.
The amount of times.
No!
Call out when you need help.
What do you got?
Res, res, res.
No!
Guys.
Guys, I think this is GG's.
I have a feeling.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't out-heal this.
We're just staggering over and over.
There's no way.
No way we can do this in one minute.
Oh no.
This guy does not know how Ventral works.
Okay.
We gotta go now.
That's very unfortunate.
Bro.
This Tracer needs to get off my deck.
Guys, it's over.
It's so over.
I never had...
Please.
For the love of god!
This has been the most it's so over game ever.
The struggle is so real.
Kill ball, right now!
Oh, don't worry!
I wish!
There's no way we pushed it all the way here.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
Oh my god!
Bro!
I have 8k damage?!
Holy sh...
Guys...
It's not okay.
This is not okay.
Guys... guys, I don't think this is okay.
Oh my god.
Maybe... maybe I'll Brig.
Maybe...
Maybe this is it.
Maybe all I need to do is play Brig as well.
We can use cure... yeah, yeah.
Up the win rate.
Yeah, that seems right.
Guys... guys, maybe it's... if I was Brig?
Maybe.
Is Sombra just non-stop hacks the... the...
I'll try to peel for you more often.
We have to hold the top.
Yeah, just play what you're playing.
This is it.
Maybe.
Maybe this is all we do.
It should be winnable, right?
If he goes Hammond.
Oh, sh...
If we could kill Brig...
Let's get out of...
Guys, I don't think it's winnable anymore.
There's a Brig on me behind, by the way, guys.
There we go.
I got... I got him out.
Where's that Brig?
Alright, this is it.
This is not it, guys.
I think...
I think we know...
That this is not it.
Oh my god.
This is absolutely not it.
I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
I'm f**king leaving.
Oh no.
Brig on Brig violence!
Let's go!
Okay, let's not go.
Let's not go.
Let's absolutely not go.
Guys, it was not it.
All I'm saying...
I was not the issue.
I'm gonna avoid...
I'm gonna avoid the Mercy because I think the Mercy is a one trick.
And like... and they don't swap.
So I'm gonna avoid the Mercy.
And I'm also gonna avoid...
Who was the Sombra?
Who played... this was the Sombra, right?
I assume these two are duo'd.
Guys...
Reversal?
Are you f**king kidding me?
Okay.
Alright.
Nice.
Guys, this is where our luck changes.
We're gonna win five games in a row after that.
This is exactly where our luck changes.
This is it.
This is f**king it.
Bro.
Oh my god.
Remember that kid that was like 1k?
He actually thought that was serious.
And he like replied on Twitter.
Asking for the actual $1000.
He's like, what the f**k?
Bro.
He actually thought we were serious about betting real money.
He's like pulling up the...
Oh, we have a fair.
Pulling up the receipts on my Twitter.
And was like, bro, where the f**k's the 1k?
Bro, there's no way.
Yo, yo, yo.
How you guys doing?
And by guys, I mean you.
Because there's nobody else in VC.
Holy sh**.
And I'm so sad about last game.
And he was like, why did your mods ban me?
First off, it was a timeout.
Second off...
It was...
I banned.
Second off, it wasn't the mods.
This guy.
Who am I talking to?
Where is it though?
Oh, God.
I'm just gonna res him.
I res up res Bozeman.
Okay.
Whoa.
Oh, I f**king messed up my jump.
Here, I got you.
I got you.
I think Ruben is tired now.
Ruben is not tired.
You know how I know?
If you look at Ruben's Twitch bots, he f**king streams 18 plus hours of Overwatch every f**king day.
So I know for a fact that like he's not done.
He literally plays Overwatch like 15 to 18 hours a day.
Yeah.
Wait, I have ult.
What the f**k?
I actually have ult.
Oh my God.
Finally.
Holy s**t.
We've actually made progress.
Whee!
The least dedicated.
That's depressing.
That's what happens if like...
If you...
If you have...
You're not on variety.
It's a sad life.
I don't know.
I feel like I'm on the path of an only FPS streamer or like only...
Like a specialty streamer.
You play the game until it dies.
Hehehe.
I don't got you.
Oh, I don't got you anymore.
Oh.
That Pharah, this?
How?
Oh, he killed him.
Guys, I can't wait to get back to the game.
The game... the SR I lost.
She's still grinding.
Not stopping until we fucking hit Masters.
It's literally... Guys, I've just been targeted, okay?
I can beat Masters so easily.
I've just been targeted.
I swear.
I can easily get Masters.
It's just streaming the grind is a lot more difficult.
They don't care.
Yeah, yeah.
It's all stream snipers, guys.
You wouldn't understand.
It's just all stream snipers.
See, that Hog put that trap there?
To purposely stream snipe me.
He stream sniped me and then put the trap there.
Our fucking Pharah is so dead.
Okay,
I was not saved.
Okay.
I win these.
We saw your record before stream.
That's different.
I gained back though.
I'm positive.
I'm a positive win rate on everything else.
I have a positive win rate on everything else but Kiriko.
It's different.
I love having new temperature IQ DPS players on my team.
Every single game.
It's my favorite.
You guys just don't understand.
I don't know the game.
Oh my God.
He's following me.
Never go too high.
It's high filling these.
Okay.
I'm going to wait.
Alright.
Because I don't want to get pushed off the map.
It's fine.
We're fine.
It's alright.
We're so fine.
See.
Bro, I played Mercy for you Pharah!
Where the f*** is our... where... oh...
No!
Shoot the Pharah!
Shoot the Pharah so I could have...
Oh nice, just a Kiriko.
Oh nice, okay.
That's good.
That was a 100.
Yeah it is!
It made the hog turn around and try and look for me.
So it was intentional because the hog turned around, forced a bad positioning, and then let my team push up.
Camille didn't shoot the Pharah.
If he shot the Pharah I could have got the RZA.
Oh no, can I get the RZA?
Woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah woah!
Woah!
Go shoot the Pharah!
Please stop shooting the Pharah!
It's fine, it's fine!
The Hanzo alive!
Keep Hanzo alive!
Nice!
See, I told you everything's fine!
I got back the SR I lost last game!
Yay!
There we go.
We're doing it!
We're fine!
Doki, when will you stop playing Overwatch?
Stop?
When's stream gonna end?
End?
You're never getting off this wild ride!
Look at that.
Peak Mercy gameplay.
Woooo!
E-e-e-end?
How does one stop?
Look, all I'm saying is that if I wasn't streaming my gameplay, we would have been masters.
We would have been like masters too!
Alright guys?
I'm not coping, it's the truth.
It's 100% the truth.
I'm not coping.
It's because, you know, I have to entertain and I have to...
Oh my god!
That's fucked up!
Oh!
I've never seen a more res-able res.
Oh my god!
There you go.
I got it.
I got the heals.
Going down?
Yeah.
Guys, I have to read and you know reading... you know reading is not my strong suit.
Now imagine reading and playing the game at the...
No!
You deserve this.
Oh no.
Oh no, our Kiriko died for her sins.
I don't think I was fair.
Can I fairly do this?
Will you get hooked?
Oh, oh, oh.
Hahaha!
The Mercy body block right there.
Yeah, also I'm playing Mercy, which I don't know if you guys know this, requires a very high skill ceiling.
I don't know if you guys know that.
Yeah!
We're back where we started!
Guys, we can do this.
We really need to win three games in a row.
Guys, three, three games... This is it.
This is where the win streak starts.
We're starting the win streak right here.
Right now.
Also, let me make my tweet for my waiting room.
Hahaha!
Let me... Let me...
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
I need to make my waiting... Oh shit, we're in game.
Alright, let's see.
Okay, this guy was top 500 in Overwatch 1, Season 1.
Damn, he's washed as hell.
Alright, Junkertown.
This is it.
Alright, now... Now I make my waiting room tweet.
Don't worry.
I did not expect to stream this long today.
I... I get into these phases in gaming where...
I suddenly just... I just can't stop playing.
Overwatch is like my biggest problem when it comes to that.
It's like when I get into like a stride, it's just so hard to stop.
It's just so fucking hard to stop when it comes to Overwatch.
Yo, yo, yo!
It's called addiction.
The Marvel Arrival is waiting room.
Hahaha!
Let's see.
Alright, here we go.
No Ana, no Ana, no...
Is that a Weedle?
They are running Widow?
Yeah.
I saw her crouch there.
No Weedle.
Ohoho!
Ohohoho!
Hahaha!
Okay, I have to play Kiriko.
Because they run...
God damn it!
They are running Ana murky.
So I have to play...
Do you guys see that fucking Widow right there?
Hahaha!
Fear.
Oh my God!
That's fucking right.
No!
Who woke him up?
Who peppered her?
That's way too fast.
Okay.
I think I can build Nano here.
That'll be fine.
He's just got hook.
How about Ruben?
I know you can hook.
I know you can get that one hook that we need.
Okay.
I thought he would, you know, pull him to me.
But that's okay.
Oh shit!
Alright.
Alright, it's Kiriko time.
We are not building our Nano.
We are not gonna be building our Nano.
Oh shit!
Okay.
Remember when I say when our win starts now?
I think maybe next game.
Alright, when she starts the next game.
I'm gonna hook him out of the high noon.
Oh!
That Mercy!
That Mercy successfully meat shielded the high noon.
Holy shit!
Okay.
That was really good.
Not gonna lie.
That was a really good hook.
Good accident.
That didn't hook too.
Can someone please kill that Widow?
I'm so scared.
No!
He's so low!
Please!
We got the Widow?
Nice, we got the Widow.
We got the Widow.
Watch.
Okay.
I got hit though.
I got a hit.
Awesome!
I got a headshot like that?!
That's fine.
It's not fine.
It was definitely not fine.
He's not gonna hook me.
It's so far away.
Okay, the fucking stomp stomp stomp was a little scary, not gonna lie.
It was scary.
It was like a horror film.
Scared.
Oh nice, we got the Weedle.
We're gonna Wes!
What?!
Not gonna peek that!
Can't fucking...
Ooh.
There is the Weedle.
Their Ana is really low bottom left.
Okay, that's good to know.
Oh, that's not good to know!
That's not good to know!
I feel all worn inside.
Wait, they Ana!
Mercy ult!
That's good!
No!
I'm okay.
Fear.
Every time I hear those, stomp stomp.
No no no no!
I just got it too!
Oh, he's not Weedle anymore, thank god.
I can't believe... Me too.
I can't believe I lived through that.
This Ana is really good though.
Okay.
Wait.
Nope.
Missed.
Andregas, thank you for the five gifts and chips!
Thank you!
I appreciate it!
Okay, bye.
Thank you!
Now if i get the...
Please.
Please no.
vorher Nice, nice, nice.
We don't care.
There's no Weedo so it's okay.
Oh no...
Oh no.
Where are you?
I'm gonna stay up here, high ground.
Hog's coming over though.
Let's look at Soldier.
You and I!
You and I, we work together!
I'll keep you alive!
You and I, Soldier!
See?
Boom!
You're alive!
Magic!
Oh, that is a very good hook.
Wait, what?
I hear somebody behind us.
Oh, there he is.
Saving cleanse for antis.
No!
Oh!
You're fine!
You're okay!
Look at that.
I'm getting involved.
I'm pushing up too.
He'll be fine.
He has the Doughkeeper with a negative win rate on Kiriko.
What's the worst that could happen?
I can't save like... I can't save a bomb.
Like, he fucking exploded.
That's like a fucking nuclear fucking bomb right there.
Basically brought on the next fallout.
Oh, he was low though.
That's what happens.
Okay, he's giving me ult charge.
It's okay.
I love ult charge.
Got it.
Oh, he's so low!
He's so low!
And he missed!
Oh!
There's no way you can die from this.
There's no way!
You're getting pocketed so hard!
I'm leaving!
If you die, you die!
Thanks for the catch up!
Can we put Mercy doing that over there?
Where?
Oh, there.
I mean, I'm fucking trying my best here.
Oh, I guess I'll leave.
Oh, wait!
This is the last fight!
No!
This was the last fight!
Okay.
Guys, why did no one tell me it was the last fight?
Guys, nobody said anything.
Wait, did we touch it?
Guys, did we touch it?
Did we touch it?
Leaving in the last... How was I supposed to know it was the last fight?
How?
Why did no one tell me?
Guys, I can't remember.
Anyway, I need to do my... I need to do my waiting room.
Okay, goodnight, dragons.
Okay, the waiting room is here!
I sure...
Time for some post-Overwatch...
Overwatch last game...
Last game...
Uh... Stress...
Relief...
Time for some post-Overwatch relaxing time because I totally got Masters back.
There we go.
I did it.
Is this a wait waiting room?
How many seconds do I have?
20 seconds.
I can get there in 20 seconds!
There we go.
Alright.
I can get there in 20 seconds.
See?
Mercy... Was he always Mercy?
Oh no, she was like Mora.
Okay.
Why damage boost me?
I'm fucking...
Oh my god.
Oh, that's...
That's okay.
We just regrouped.
Okay.
Um... This is looking positive already.
It's looking okey-dokey right here.
Very okey-dokey right here.
Okay.
Very fine.
I feel so healthy.
I feel so very healthy.
Bro, the Ana's just there by himself!
Guys!
I think I made an error.
No, you didn't!
Just kidding.
I don't make any mistakes.
No, you didn't!
You don't die!
Those!
Where is this?
Where is this Weedo?
Oh, okay.
Wait a minute.
Ohog.
Hi, Skippy.
Don't worry.
Okay.
We're fine.
She hits those.
That's right.
She is me.
Never peeking again.
Never...
Waaah!
Never peeking again!
Just don't peek.
She is me.
I is her.
There you go.
Thank you!
This is exactly why I went Kiriko.
Oh, no.
Oh!
Please don't get headshot!
Well...
Oh!
Please both my teammates don't get headshot.
That's all I want.
Oh, no.
No!
Yeah, I'm one too.
Why is everybody peeking the Widow?
I was okay!
Oh my god.
Bro!
You're not him!
Thank you.
All right.
I will...
That's right.
You're not him!
Swap!
Play Gangu!
You'll never beat him!
Let's hope somebody goes down there.
Oh my god!
That's sad.
Oh, no.
That's so sad.
Please, somebody save me.
We can recontest this.
Oh my god.
I might be a liar.
Yes.
I'm definitely a liar.
The win streak starts next game.
I swear.
The win streak will start next game.
Because I don't think this game is it.
I know.
Can we kill Hog?
No.
I don't know.
Can we?
No one can hide from my sight.
Thanks for the boost.
Whoa.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god!
The very first Widow kill we've ever got!
Oh.
Okay.
He went up.
That's actually crazy.
We did it, guys.
Congratulations.
We did the bare minimum.
We actually did the bare minimum.
I'm so proud of you all.
Ow!
Missed.
Give me all charge.
Their Kass is one.
Oh, nice.
Whoa.
Okay.
Can we kill Hog?
Oh, I'm pretty sure.
I'm pretty sure he was not meant...
Oh, there we go.
He hit me.
He really hit me.
Oh.
Oh my god.
They did it.
Guys...
I don't give a f*** right now.
They used Nano, at least.
This team...
I'm almost back.
This team might not be it.
He might not have the run.
This sim might not be it.
This...
This was just not it?
Is it?
It was just...
This team was just...
This team was just not it, guys!
It was just...
You know...
There was nothing we could do.
It took us...
It took us 10 deaths for our Widow to out-Widow the Widow.
It was just that.
It really was.
It's just not it.
Next match, surely.
Surely.
It's the next match is when our win streak starts.
I believe.
Guys.
This is when our next match starts.
I think I might need a refund on my insurance though.
I think I might need a refund.
Yo yo yo.
How you guys doing?
I will not leave a broken world alive!
Alright, this is it.
I don't know how you do it, Ana.
This is the win streak starts.
The win streak starts here.
Waiting for the perfect shot.
When the win streak starts here.
This is it.
Guys, Bacon, what happened?
I thought you were paying for my insurance.
Bacon?
What happened?
Faken!
Did you miss out on the last month's payment?
Did you miss out?
Fighting the win streak.
Oh no.
Not a bot.
Guys, I swear to god.
Please.
I...
I'm... Our team is dead.
It's not okay.
We got two.
Woo!
Don't touch me!
Don't touch me little bot!
No!
She's gonna start sucking!
Somebody save me!
Okay, we're fine.
Okay.
No amount of money can save this.
I'm sorry.
No!
Don't say that!
It's not me!
Thank you for the Akasufa, Faken.
I swear!
Okay.
Oh shit.
Like, what the fuck am I supposed to...
Bro!
I sucked it 20 times!
Don't boot me in here.
Oh god.
I will nano if it means I die.
Oh!
I said I would... No!
No!
Why?
Why is there three people on the enemy team?
On our spawn!
Hold on.
I hooked this guy.
Look!
It's just...
It's just that like... my insurance ran out again.
Don't worry.
I got bacon... bacon like...
Here's an IOU.
Bacon, thanks for paying again for my insurance again.
Oh my god.
He like dropped in a way I didn't think he was gonna drop.
Oh god.
Please.
Please somebody kill him.
I'm okay.
Are you?
He is.
Spoiler alert.
He was okay.
What's going on down there?
It's okay.
Oh god, Ruben.
Ruben, I'm scared.
Ruben.
Oh my god, he lives?
I'll punch you!
There you go.
See, we did it.
I have one... one death.
I told you it was okay.
I'm gonna go back to the base.
Guys, I told you.
It's okay.
We can do this.
The win streak is real.
This is it.
We just need to win four games in a row, guys.
Guys, you know, I know why.
I know why I haven't been winning.
You guys haven't been believing in me.
If one person bets against me, it's over.
Okay.
What is this TP?
So you only have...
So it's everybody's fault.
No, no.
I'm not saying it's your fault, dragoons.
I'm saying it's everybody's fault.
That's different.
Hey, they just gave us high ground.
This is awesome.
Guys, it's different.
Oh no, they have Wido.
They have dive Wido.
Is that fucking...
Where's the dive?
Where was the dive?
I heard I'm going to dive Wido.
I didn't see no dive.
No, Wido killed two of us.
How is there ever a dive?
Oh no, I fucking... He's dead.
He's so dead.
Guys, I'm in a bit of a precarious situation.
Okay, so... Ruben fed.
Ruben baited us all with the I'm going to dive Wido.
We got baited, guys.
What?
How did he dodge that?
Oh my god, she shot himself.
I'm going to ignore the ball and you guys are going to be okay.
Will we?
I don't know.
I don't feel okay.
I really don't feel okay.
Please, somebody get rid of him.
You can kill this guy.
Look at him.
Look at him fuck up his back.
I'm going to dive Wido.
It's okay.
I am unbreakable.
There you go.
Damn right.
I got those mines.
I had to make my first ever super chat to select you know, to lock in.
Thank you for this super chat for...
Thank you for making the insurance payments for me, guys.
Are you serious?
Guys, you're helping me make my insurance...
You're helping me pay off my insurance, guys.
I really appreciate it.
This is actually crazy.
This insurance only lasts like one minute.
Oh my god, he's so low!
God damn it!
Stop!
Bro, he's actually... he's just a nuisance.
Are you... okay.
I give up.
Bro, leave us alone!
This is why...
Bro, Hammond... oh my god, he's dead.
He's fucking dead.
Bro, this is actually an infestation problem.
What the fuck is going on?
What is going on over there?
What is going on?
I swear it's only been the Hammond.
I swear to god.
Somebody stop this Hammond!
Oh, peek me, please.
Oh god.
Guys.
Guys, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
Guys, I did it.
I hit my first...
Goodbye.
Holy shit.
Yes, he's very annoying.
Alright, this is it.
I'll nano...
I'll nano the Sojin.
And then Wind Streak starts now.
Hey, I'm coming back.
Bro, this Hammond...
Someone please call the exterminator.
These hamsters have been fucking too much.
We have a hamster problem.
I slept the target.
Alright.
It's go time.
Oh, whoops.
Really sad.
Whoops.
This is it.
This is...
Oh, they're all running away.
But this wasn't it.
Their brig is bottom right.
This was...
Oh, he was, but I didn't.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
He was bottom right.
We did it, guys.
Wind Streak starts now.
This ends now.
I told you.
Wind Streak starts now.
This is it, guys.
This is it.
I know you've been watching five hours of Overwatch, but this is it.
This is all you've been waiting for.
I told you!
Bacon!
I told you, Bacon!
Guys...
Guys... I told you guys...
My insurance...
My insurance only lasts like per game, okay?
It lasts every... per game, guys.
I told you.
That's why... That's why...
That's why we are having issues.
But this is where...
This is where our luck changes.
This is where our luck changes right here.
The bar stays the same.
Here we go.
I believe...
I believe.
Thanks for the win.
Yeah!
Shout out to Bacon guys!
We got a huge shout out to Bacon for getting us that win.
And he said no amount of money can save this!
You are wrong!
We just need to We just need to extend the insurance!
Black, thank you for this help!
Thank you!
I told you.
It's just really bad insurance.
Like, my...
I got like the cheapest one.
So that's why it expires so fast.
Expires so fucking fast.
Because it only lasts a game each.
Thank you for the super chat.
Is Diamond a good rank?
Well, it's more so of like...
The player base is not as big as it used to be.
And because the player base is not as big as it used to be...
Diamond for tank is top 500 now.
So...
Many thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This insurance does not cover any rank loss but comes with a complimentary 5.10.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Hat.
10 bucks you...
What?
Why would you bet it?
You have a gambling problem, Hat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Paladins next time?
Bro, I played Paladins like a little bit.
I think like a couple of weeks ago.
And oh my god.
Yo, yo, yo.
How you guys doing?
I have bumped into team...
Like, I bumped into players with like max...
Like, not max but really high level players.
Who...
I think I was in Bronze, you know.
Because I never played the game.
So they're MMR.
They weren't bots.
You can tell when somebody's a bot or not.
Because it has like...
They don't have like any...
Like...
Like they actually have...
They have no name.
I'm Ryan.
Wait, they're all Ryan.
I'll take the pet.
That's fucked up.
Oh sh...
Alright.
Please no...
Oh my god.
Okay.
I slept somebody.
Oh, our Hanzo is fucking dead.
I'm fucking dead!
Alright.
Okay.
We have Pharah.
So we have to go this.
Oh, this is kind of...
No, no.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
So...
It's okay.
It's not okay for our Pharah.
There's no way...
Yep.
Never mind.
Here we go.
What have I done to deserve this?
It's okay.
Oh!
I'm fucking running.
It's not okay.
It's fine.
Just go.
Go!
Just go!
Bro, I'll fucking go!
Oh, I won't go.
Bro, he's still alive!
Get her away!
Hey guys, thank you Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Bill, thank you Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Mikdas3 in the pool for gambling.
She wins this.
Thank you Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Twenty bucks, you lose, win, lose, win.
This is fucked up.
What if I match-fix this right now?
But like, I should have said that out loud.
So if I like, you know, whichever pool has the most money, and then somehow...
Ooh.
Okay.
We're good.
We're okay.
What is he gonna do?
Kill us?
See, we're fine.
Oh my god, there's a soldier behind us.
Kill the soldier!
Hey, soldier's dead.
Soldier's dead.
Get this mora off me!
Do it.
Kill her.
Okay, we're fine.
Betting your favor never seems to work, so I'm betting against you now.
Guys, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look at that.
E-sports gambling is now legal in 37 states.
I'm Canadian!
Wait, it's more legal.
Wait, never mind.
You're right.
Wait, it works.
Never mind.
It works because it's legal everywhere.
That's fucking right.
I forgot about that.
It's legal everywhere in Canada.
That's why streamers move to Canada.
The gamble!
It's actually true!
Streamers move to Canada to fucking gamble!
Because it's legal.
It's so fucked up.
It's true!
It's true, it was a whole big deal.
No!
The gold Kiriko!
Alright.
Yeah.
Yeah!
You know like those streamers that do like gambling?
Like those gambling streams?
On like, not Twitch, was it Kik or some shit now?
Or like, I don't even know if you can do it on Twitch anymore.
But like, it's because like, um...
It's because they have to move to Canada to do it.
Because it's legal in Canada.
Hahaha!
Their back is half-ish and they have no nade.
Okay, I saved him.
I'm a hero.
I'm a fucking hero.
Alright.
Is Baden forever on Twitch for real?
This is mine now.
Alright, we don't care.
Yeah, I'll take this.
Sorry Ana.
Oh!
Hey!
You know, Tracer, help me out, Tracer.
Tracer, help me out.
Oh!
This is where we all die, I guess.
This is where we all die.
Unless...
Nevermind!
Everybody got the Suzu except for him.
Hey guys, can you guys not die?
This is bad.
I'm saved.
They're honest that we're only down one.
Yeah.
One.
Take a lot of damage, huh?
Yeah, it was definitely one.
Okay, I might have been hit.
Yeah, we were definitely down one.
I'm gonna get my Minecraft.
They just whiffed post-match.
I dodged.
You can't f***ing DM my f***ing heals though.
Oh!
Oh my god.
Guys, I think we're gonna lose our...
I think we're gonna lose our lead.
It's so over.
Bacon, thank you for the Magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
Bacon!
$50 in Doki's second win in a row.
It gotta happen.
Guys!
We will start a win streak right here, right now!
We will get our f***ing win streak!
I believe!
Come on, we gotta go.
We gotta go.
You and me, Soldier, we have to go.
This is it.
Alright, he has...
Okay, I need a...
Don't worry!
They just wasted bomb, dude.
Okay, I can't save you.
Please!
I needed you to be closer!
Who better could it be?
Alright, we're good.
Win rate starts here.
Right here.
Right now.
Please Robin!
Oh no!
Even now!
Please!
Just kill that guy!
Where's the rest of our team?
Why are they going up?
Why are they still pushing this?
After everything we did!
He's literally won.
Oh.
God damn it.
We're fine.
Okay, I can swap back to Ana.
I don't have to play Kiriko anymore.
Okay, I'm pushing the payload.
I'm pushing the guy.
I'm pushing him.
Here we go.
Goodbye Ana.
Goodbye Tracer.
Oh, there they are.
We need our tank.
Somebody!
I'm sorry Soldier.
If you die, you fucking die.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Ruben has ult.
Oh!
It's okay.
It's not okay anymore.
It is absolutely not okay anymore.
It is a- It is absolutely not.
Just kill me.
Just kill me so I don't get staggered.
Yes.
We just need one good fight.
Can you be used?
Please!
Oh, shit.
Oh my god.
That's actually crazy to say.
You're fucking welcome.
Oh, I wish we could kill a lot of things.
I'm calling out to DPS Warden in VC.
Oh my god!
All I'm saying is that you guys bet against me.
All I'm saying is that I fixed this match guys.
The match is fixed.
Guys I got the payout.
Guys, I got the payout.
It was because I fixed the match.
I lost intentionally.
So, I got the highest payout possible.
Looks like chat is right.
The cycle continues.
Guys,
it's because I did that on purpose guys.
I did that on purpose.
We're back where we started.
We were.
We're actually back where we were.
After five hours.
I deserve to play Mercy at that point.
I win again, another 10.
Is this how it works?
Hats, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you for the- Exactly!
Guys.
It was all on purpose, guys.
It was all on purpose.
Look at that.
Easy.
Easiest 10 dollars of my life.
It was fixed, guys.
I was here for the big payout.
I was here for the big payout, guys.
Actually, Reng.
Don't keep throwing.
I'm not saying I'm throwing.
Guys.
I'm not saying I'm throwing, guys.
You have no proof.
You have no proof that I fixed the match.
Except for me admitting that I did it.
Oh my god!
How?
How do we- Okay.
I'm gonna...
Okay, I'm not playing Mercy.
Has it started yet?
Soon!
Soon, TM!
Bacon, damn!
Don't keep losing me capital.
Looks like the insurance won't be getting paid.
Soon!
This is it.
Oh my god.
At least he's not an orb anymore.
Like, that's the best part.
There we go.
Oh, what?
That's my bad.
Where's the Rein?
Is that the Rein over there?
Where the fuck is that Rein?
Oh, there he is.
There we go.
Oh, that would be so sick if I hit those.
Alright, we're gonna go to Sigma.
I think it's Reng.
She's winning while losing.
Thank you for the super chat, Jinya.
Thank you, thank you.
I'll be fine.
I can stop whenever I want.
Guys.
I can stop playing Overwatch whenever I want, guys.
It's not an addiction.
I can stop whenever I want.
It's just... I just don't want to.
I feel like he has shatter.
Who woke him?
That Rein can die.
Maybe later.
We'll find that win streak, so...
Guys, we'll find it.
I believe.
You're powered up.
See?
This is it!
This is where...
OOOOOOOH!
The Cask can die.
This was not it.
No, Mom.
I don't have a problem!
Okay.
I'm farming my ult off this ride.
I still have a chance!
Oh my god.
Okay, we're actually throwing now.
We might actually be throwing now.
Ruben's ride is not known to be like...
It's not known to be something that...
Oh my god.
He keeps hit... he keeps waking him.
Oh god!
He's at the side!
Oh!
Stop!
Earthquakes!
Victoria is close, but not close.
Okay.
Sorry I used your win streak earlier.
If you can have it.
Bro!
Bro, do you think... cause I don't think...
That it was just insurance.
I was actually really scared.
No mom, I don't have a problem.
Gladstone, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Jordan, thank you for the super chat.
Roy!
I'll search the globe, explore the depths of the ocean, we'll find the win streak.
Here we go.
This is it.
We're gonna discover the win streak right here.
We're starting the wins.
Right here.
Right here, right now.
This is it.
It's a flying car.
Oh shit, you're right.
Alright.
Just gonna casually...
Just gonna push.
Oh my god.
Oh he's so fucking good.
We'll be fine, right?
You're fucking... Oh my god!
Okay, not gonna lie.
Guys, guys.
Guys, I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
That's a good question.
Wow!
Well, I guess... No?
It was the answer all along.
Oh, goodbye.
I'm tired of this fight.
Junior, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
It's okay.
This is it.
Huge anti right there.
I told you that was it.
Why are they like in our spot?
Can we go run?
Holy shit!
Our DPS is like...
Struggles.
Guys.
Guys, I'm scared.
Kill this guy!
I'm so scared.
Guys.
He has shatter.
He 100% has shatter.
He's antied.
What do you mean?
Who's gonna do it?
Someone kill...
No!
Please!
Oh, there we go.
That's fine.
Oh!
Missed that.
There's no way he could charge.
Oh, why does that hit everyone but the ride?
Why does that hit everyone but the ride?
Oh, that's huge!
I'm gonna push the cart.
I didn't see it, but it looked huge.
These barrels are smoking.
That's it.
I told you.
I told you a winch would start one day.
Guys, I know it's like...
I know we've been playing Overwatch for 5 hours now.
I know.
But like...
But I don't have a problem.
All I'm saying... I just...
I don't have a problem.
Oh my god, I saved his life.
Oh my...
Okay, that was actually a really...
Oh my... Okay, that was actually a really...
A really good anti.
Okay, our Ashe is so fucked.
I have...
I think I have to go Lucio.
Unless...
Can we touch this?
We might be able to.
Oh, he's fucking...
Yeah, I don't think he's making it.
I don't think he's making it.
That's fine.
We push it pretty far.
It's fine.
It's so fine.
I believe.
This is it.
This has to be it.
You proved me wrong.
Guess you just got Lucio's...
Don't say that!
I'll be different.
I swear.
I'll just...
No!
Why are you on Brig?
I was gonna go Zenyatta.
It's not me.
I was climbing before.
I was climbing solo too.
It's not me.
It's everybody but me.
Guys, it's everybody but me.
They always say that.
They always say that cause they're right.
Holy shit.
Oh, that's not good.
Guys, there's a Rein above.
And I'm scared!
I'm so scared!
Ana's on our high ground.
Yeah.
I got two.
I'm on my way.
I swear.
Oh no.
I missed the nade.
And I have to reload.
I told you.
Woah!
Okay, there you go.
We're five.
Yeah, she said next team, not next.
Guys, I might have messed up.
No, you have it!
No!
Get back here!
You're blowing me up!
That's fine.
Guys!
Stop!
I don't have heals!
You'll have to try harder than that.
Can we back up a little bit?
I need to recharge my shield.
Please.
I'm so low.
I'm so far away.
Please.
Please, guys.
Yo, I'm backing up.
Yo, back up.
Oh, he definitely has shatter, though.
He 100% has it.
He definitely has it.
I feel the shatter.
I feel it right now.
I feel it right here.
Oh my god!
There it is!
Whoop!
Alright.
We recon test.
100%.
Alright.
There's a reining here, though.
Ah!
Heal!
Bye.
Yo, what is their Ana doing?
Wait, there's an Ana right here.
I'm gonna go for the Soldier.
There's literally an Ana in our spawn.
Nice.
Like, what?
Is there Ana still alive back there?
Where the fuck did the Ana go?
I'm like, a bit scared about where the Ana is.
Like...
I'm here.
Keep fighting.
Take this.
Like...
I'm defending red.
Wait!
Ana's behind!
There's an Ana still back there?
Okay.
Did we get the Ana?
Is the Ana still there?
I'm stuck.
Bro, is the Ana still...
Bro, the Ana still there!
Bro, get the fuck out!
What the fuck?
Leave!
Leave, Rachel.
She's throwing...
Like...
They had to still...
Guys, I won.
I fucking knew it, guys.
Guys, that's all it took, guys.
Expect...
Alright, guys.
It's alright.
Oh, shit.
What practice range?
I don't beat practice range!
I mean, it's three minutes.
It's fine.
It's three minutes.
Oh my god.
Alright, we're gonna chill for three minutes, guys.
A little reset.
This is it.
On the sixth hour, we're gonna get our masters.
Here.
On the sixth hour.
Yeah, she got...
The enemy Rein could not fucking heal.
The enemy Rein got fucked over because he didn't have an Ana with him.
Alright.
It's fine.
Guys.
We'll be okay.
This is the win streak.
The rank up for our guest bar hasn't gone up.
Guys!
Yes.
It was a visual bug.
Guys.
A visual bug.
You might think that the rank up bar has not gone up at all.
Like, not even once.
Throughout the last five and a half hours.
But it was merely just a visual bug.
And this is where it all changes.
This is exactly where everything changes here.
Like, look at that.
If I can hit those headies right here as Cassidy's, I can hit those headies on my sleep dart.
Guys.
This is it.
Right here.
Uh...
Blarious, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I can stop whenever I want.
Chat.
Guys.
It's just that easy.
I can stop here.
Your aim is cracked.
I know, right?
I know.
And it translates well in game too.
Ormido, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Uh... Keep it up, Doki.
The marathon...
The win streak begins when the better teams go to bed.
I am the better team!
I'm the better healer!
I swear!
It's just not me.
It's not me.
Guys.
It's absolutely not me.
Look at those headshots I'm taking against bots.
Look at that.
Look at these flicks.
Boom, boom.
Flick, flick, flick.
Come on.
Look at that.
And then...
Come on.
Get an Anakin that can do that.
Go, Fio.
Like, are you trying to say these flicks?
These flicks are causing me to lose?
It's just unfortunate that every time I lose, I get a bad player on my team.
What does each game have in common?
Not me.
I play different healers.
Because I can flex.
Like, look at that.
I haven't missed a single shot.
There we go.
I think we're ready.
This is it.
There's no way.
Guys, there's no way.
.
This will 100% carry over.
100%.
This will carry over.
You know what?
I know the issue.
We just need a third player to play DPS, so we have all roles accounted for.
All I'm saying...
If we have a third player, we will have a DPS player that we can count on.
And then I have a tank player that I can count on.
And then there's me.
I can count on myself.
You know?
I can't...
Excuse me, silly kitty.
I can count on myself, you know?
.
Boy, thank you for things.
300!
This is it.
We can do this, guys.
You have it private for friends too?
.
I don't think I'm in range.
Oh my god, that's hilarious.
.
That is why we haven't succeeded.
It has to be it.
Like, what?
Jesus Christ.
.
No!
The gold Caracoo!
.
What the fuck?
Okay.
.
The rez.
They got the rez off.
.
What the fuck is that?
Nope.
That was an insane hook.
Holy shit.
.
That hook was insane.
See those shots?
Look at that.
And you're trying to say I'm the problem.
Don't look at my sleep darts though.
It says 0% sleep dart accuracy.
It's because I haven't sleep darted yet.
.
Not yet.
Just so you know.
No.
.
Alright.
We're 5?
.
Dude look, Mercy alive because of me .
Here I going to hit .
.
Called it.
I'm not the problem.
I told you I wasn't the problem.
Oh my god, it was so unfortunate that I hit that shot, but then he just took too much damage, you know?
All I'm saying, he took too much damage.
We were not gonna win this anyway!
Content Nate, is this pre-recorded?
It was just unfortunate that, you know, the Genji took so much damage that like...
The Genji took so much damage that like, I just could not heal the damage there, you know?
You know?
They're gonna use six cooldowns, and then you guys will know.
He's doing things.
Guys, I think he's dead.
It's okay, it's okay, still one.
We'll still win.
Oh god.
Oh god, we're five.
Oh, we're so five.
It's okay, I got the point though.
We're still five.
Can you touch him?
He needs five points.
There you go.
I'm gonna go.
I thought staying in the cage would keep me safe, but it didn't.
Guys, look at that 20%... look at that 80% sleep dart accuracy.
Guys, look at that.
You guys don't believe me?
Don't worry.
Is that what she said?
I mean, it could be what she said.
Don't worry.
Watch this.
That's a medium one too.
Okay, give me a sec.
80%.
I'm sorry.
Don't be.
Give me a sec.
Oh my gosh.
80% sleep dart accuracy.
Oh shit, wait.
Five, four, three, two, one.
Round two.
Capture the objective.
Shit, guys, I'm not throwing.
We won't throw.
Guys, I'm not throwing.
Guys, guys, I purposely wanted to be last.
To go down here last.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god, 30% now.
Jesus Christ.
This is a lot.
Thank you.
I try my best.
My goal every day when I walk out of my house.
Maybe not when I walk out of my house.
There was...
You get what I mean.
There was a lot of things going on.
That's right.
80%.
It went up 82%.
That's fucking crazy.
You're not a grump.
Okay, he is.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
There's no way.
You're the actual smartest MAGA player right there.
That's crazy.
There's no way I was gonna say.
Please.
I'm scared.
Look, I knew I hit those.
Thank you for it.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
You're good.
Oh, I am not good.
Oh, there's too many things.
Too many things on my screen.
You know what we do have?
There's too many things going on.
It's over.
I live these though.
All right.
Nice.
I'm at...
Oh my god.
I'm at 85.
Did you see it?
I'm at 85% now.
85.
Holy shit.
We can keep going.
That's you right now.
We can keep going higher.
Wait, this one is going easy.
Oh.
That one.
Yeah.
Oh, my God.
Guys.
Guys, our mercy's fucked.
Jk, I'm gamer.
Oh, my God.
You're crazy.
You're actually crazy.
Okay, I can't game anymore.
I can't game anymore.
Someone, please help Ruben.
Genji, up top.
Genji definitely did not like this.
There's no way.
There's no way the Genji is gonna harass me still.
Where is the Genji?
I'm so scared.
Leave me alone!
See, I told you.
There's no way.
We're okay.
The Genji player gets so annoying.
Oh, he's definitely gonna have cage.
I feel like I should swap to Kiriko though.
I really wanna play Zenyatta, but we have Mercy.
So you're not...
What I've learned is that you're not supposed to...
Okay.
Oh.
Oh, this is... This is bad.
This is... Okay.
This is...
Why were they all in the cage?
Why were they all in the fucking cage?
Why?
Okay.
What the... The thing is...
More people ran in.
They wanted to be part of the fun.
Where's the content?
Alright.
It's time.
When all else fails, it's Kiriko time.
Kiriko is always the backup.
This is it.
Kiriko is always the... If everything fails, we go Kiriko.
It's okay.
This is our map.
This has to be our map, right?
Right?
Yeah?
It's in five hours?
Whoa.
Five hours?
It would be a shame if we went beyond that.
It's okay.
We got a time.
Oh, nice.
You have to be careful.
Here's one.
Oh.
Look.
There's one.
He's so low.
What is he doing?
Okay, Ski...
It's okay.
I'm gonna go up.
Oh, he's gone.
Don't feel pity for the Mario player...
He's gone.
Oh my god.
We're good.
We're okay.
Doki, when will we get off this ride?
Get off?
Doki!
Why are we still here, Doki?
You are here forever, remember?
You were here forever.
Alright.
Interesting.
Okay.
The ride never ends.
It never ends.
Don't worry.
I have 85%.
We're gonna rush in.
We live here now.
Overwatch 2.
24-7.
Marvel's Rival waiting room.
Overwatch every day until Marvel Rivals come out.
Every day until that game comes out.
The waiting room.
Oh no.
He absorbed you.
Please!
He's so low!
Are you fucking kidding me?
He lives those?
He actually lives those.
Holy shit.
Guys, I think I know why we're losing.
We need that deep 30 PS.
That's literally the reason.
We broke out.
Broke out the cage!
Break out the cage!
Beautiful.
Okay.
Thank God.
We have... If we lose this, we literally have...
85% hit rare.
15% code.
100% Marvel waiting room.
It's just the waiting room!
That's why we're still playing, guys!
Soothing your wounds.
We're still playing because we're just waiting!
I can stop anytime I want!
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
I had to use the cleanse because I got scared.
Oh no.
No!
I got my one.
No, I still win one.
Is it actually?
Get on the point!
Get on the point and heal!
Get to 90!
You can do this, Ruben!
Okay.
This is it.
We just gotta make sure they don't die.
Okay.
I'm gonna protect our Soldier.
We gotta protect our Soldier.
I have to...
One again?
Here one.
Please find our Mega.
Oh my God.
There's another change from nature.
Build the Mahou!
I'll touch.
Big, big, big.
You're good.
It's fine.
I got you!
No!
This...
I protected the Tracer, but I don't know if it was worth it!
Oh my God.
Maybe we bribed the other team.
Poor Boots.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's not me!
I don't think this is good.
I don't think he's gonna touch.
I told you!
I...
Sacrifice was worth it!
GG!
I honestly walked out of my life not even close.
GG six before Doki masters.
Thank you for the super chat, boy.
Thank you.
We broke the win loss.
Guys, we got a win streak.
No, my play the game.
Don't get...
We got...
We got the win streak!
This is the end of the video.
I'm gonna go back to the chat.
The save was worth it!
We didn't need me.
We needed another DPS.
We did it.
Oh my God.
We fucking did it.
This is it.
This is...
This is fucking it.
Guys, we broke the win loss streak.
So like, it's uphill.
It's...
It's all...
It's all like...
We're all...
We're still going up.
I told you guys.
I told you.
We get masters here.
Not washed.
I'm not washed.
I'm gaming.
It's not me.
It's the enemy team.
It's my teammates.
It's...
It was painful.
It was...
I'm gaming, they're hacking, they're walling.
They're aimbotting.
Um, I'm getting targeted.
I'm getting harassed.
I...
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
Alright, what do I play?
Let's see.
I'm getting stream sniped.
Oh, burrito.
Okay, this is it.
It's Mercy time.
It's my turn on Mercy.
My hands are cold.
Exactly.
It's snowing.
My hands are cold.
They're not excuses.
They're reasons.
Oh no!
Oh wait, that's a cool skin.
I like turtles.
Okay, here we go.
Yeah, it's everyone's fault but me.
Because I'm perfect.
I'm fucking perfect.
I make the enemy team feel nothing but fear.
Oh shit.
Woah!
I don't feel so good.
Wait, what the fuck?
Bro, what are you doing?
What are you doing?
Why is she alive?
Yo, keep me up.
I live.
Does she?
Yo, she did not live.
Oh my god.
Yo.
That was not living.
I think that was the opposite of living.
Dude, that monkey was warm.
That was definitely...
Oh!
I got arrowed!
What?!
Okay, that was like the most bullshit shot I've ever seen.
Holy shit.
Look, I didn't start.
I was not the first one to die.
So it was not me.
That's all I'm saying.
I might swap Ana later.
After I get all...
Yeah, definitely.
Actually, I can go Zenyatta.
I feel like Zenyatta would be perfect.
So we can burn the monkey.
All of them are under right now.
Wait, I have ult!
Is your birth name actually really...
Woah!
No, it's just a stage name.
I was about to say...
Guys, my...
My birth name is Jokivari.
Yeah, what if it was?
What the fuck?
Yay!
Is your birth name Burrito?
It's fine.
Uh, kinda, yeah.
Well...
Don't worry.
We're fine.
We gotta use this to reset.
He's fine too.
They're all okay.
Look at that.
Yeah, first name Doki, last name Bird.
Yeah, dude.
Those sandwiches are wicked.
See?
Everything's fine.
There's no mayo on a Reuben sandwich.
I knew we'd start the win streak here.
What the fuck is this?
What is this conversation?
What's it have to do with eating Reuben sandwiches?
Because you would know what type of condiments are on it.
Well, I know what kind of condiments are on a Reuben sandwich because my name is Reuben Sargassum.
Oh, I got you, Wyatt.
What the fuck is going on?
Oh shit, I got fucking shit on.
Let's go back.
Oh shit, what is going on?
No ammo on the Abizaria.
On first point...
On first point Gibraltar.
Yeah.
I'm scared.
What is he gonna do?
Walk up?
He's walking up.
He's...
It's okay.
His inner demons, let him be.
Alright, we're fine.
See, I told you.
We're fine.
He was on low ground.
See, I don't even think we need Rush.
Oh!
Guys, I think we need a Rush.
I'm him!
Average winning team cons.
Talking about making sandwiches.
This is it.
You know how it's like people...
who celebrate...
You know what?
I bet you, I could easily get top 500 this season.
I can easily get top 500 this season.
Everything, man.
What the hell?
Just not today.
Just absolutely not today.
Guys, we will...
We're not doing that today.
I can absolutely get top 500.
I can touch top 500.
I will not end this.
But I absolutely...
So fucking easy.
Get there.
Good job, team.
I'm not doing it today.
I have a life right now.
For like today.
No, he spent five hours for Barra to not move.
Yeah, I could be top.
All I'm saying is that it was a visual bug.
All I'm saying... the bug... it was a visual bug, guys!
We would have... we... look, it was... I almost made it to Masters 5, but then... but then, like, Blizzard... there was, like, a bug in the system.
And then, like, I accidentally lost, like, 50... like, 70 SR.
It was crazy.
I was so mad, too.
Like, it... too bad, like, Rewind is not on.
So you have to take my word for it.
It's... it's too bad that, you know, you know, there was no Rewind.
So you guys couldn't see it.
But basically, what happened...
was that... uh...
I just have a thing against white people.
...was that I lost 70 SR from, like...
some weird login stuff.
...some weird login stuff.
Bozi Taka!
Oh my god, he... whoa!
Amatsukunem!
...really close.
It would be more like...
...you're supposed to, like...
...make that sound with your throat.
The orbs did it!
Oh yeah, the fucking orbs!
I only learned the cuss words from our Armenian homies back in the day.
It's okay, it's okay.
Say it again.
Bozi Taka.
I think I got it.
It's better than the first time.
It's not like this Genji is gonna chase me, right?
Is he swearing in Armenian?
I'm helping.
Oh god, Kiriko, get your fucking ass out of my screen!
Kill Bat.
There you go.
You must kill Genji here.
There we go.
Look at that!
Windstreak!
Windstreak right now!
Yeah, there it goes.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Nice.
I told you, the insurance pays off.
Look at that.
The insurance is paying off, everybody!
I knew it.
I fucking...
The insurance, it's working!
Three in a row unheard of.
This is it.
This is where you're gonna hear it right now.
The first Overwatch 2 player that's gonna get a Windstreak.
The very first one!
Nobody else...
will ever get the Windstreak like me.
Impossible.
Alright.
Here we go.
Attack Midtown.
I feel like a Zen player today.
Yo, yo, yo, how you guys doing?
This is it.
Hundreds of dollars.
The insurance is finally paying off.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is it.
Finally.
It only took me...
Thank god I'm on streamer mode.
So nobody can see me griefing aims.
No one will ever know.
Who is it?
Arditiva was the one that...
fucked over countless people's top 500s.
This is it.
The first ever...
ever...
out of all players in Overwatch 2 history...
to have a Windstreak as long as mine.
Three.
Yup.
That's pretty epic.
The first one.
Holy shit!
What was that?
While I was poking I went from a lot of HP to not a lot of HP.
That's crazy.
Yeah, that was scary.
They won't know I'm here, right?
Okay, I got 16 damage on the board.
See, they didn't know.
Oh, they did it!
Wow!
No!
Soldier is harassing our...
This is targeted!
...all of NGL.
Oh no.
Wait, they just used turret.
This is pretty bad.
We got the Zarya.
We can still engage and win.
Yeah, we got the Zarya.
Alright.
Nice, we did it.
Good trade.
Call on the objective!
You with me?
Oh my god.
Yo, no bugs!
No soldier.
I can't see anything, but I think I'm shooting them correctly.
Oh, I am!
No, you look fucked up.
Okay, I might have given them like 200 energy.
I'll stop them.
That's okay.
Oh, I got baited!
Guys, get rid of the Zarya, please.
For the love of god, get rid of the Zarya.
Oh no, Reuben is so dead.
He's so dead.
Okay, I gotta stop face-tanking.
Oh, our Ana is so fucking great.
That is...
Okay.
This is it.
That is...
That is genuinely massive.
As it was closing too.
Woo!
Over here!
Holy fuck.
Oh no, the fucking truck fucked me over.
Oh, I'm so mad.
No, he's so low!
No!
Oh fuck!
Bro!
Please!
Please stop targeting me.
I'm just a poor Zenyatta.
And they rez their guy.
I'm just...
I'm just a poor Zenyatta.
Stop!
Huge, big kill.
Oh, shoot.
Please, shoot your Ana.
Shoot your Ana.
I'm slow.
I have no legs.
My legs are just cosmetics.
Yo, I have a plan.
My legs are actually just cosmetics, please.
Please have mercy.
My plan sucks, but they usually...
Oh, I've got you, you bastard.
Oh!
I'm sorry.
You were way too far.
Okay.
We're fine.
31, 31.
Yeah, I got out.
There you go.
We got it!
I have no legs.
It's cosmetics!
It's not real!
Cassidy.
Wait, where is the Cassidy?
Oh!
You couldn't switch spots!
Oh, he missed the spot!
He missed the spot!
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
Okay, no turret.
No, you should use my...
I'm LOIing my healers on purpose because I'm a stupid individual.
What is he doing?
What?
Did he just sit still?
I'm scared.
Oh, he was so low though.
Guys, Desire doesn't know I'm here, right?
Truly not.
Oh, god.
I'm scared.
Oh, he used the bubble!
No!
Oh, my god.
There's always half.
Wait, you guys are huge.
We're doing it!
I told you.
I told you we can do this.
Yes, what?
Alright.
What kind of question is that?
We're fine.
It's like basketball.
There's like basketball!
Shoot the Ana!
I'm more important!
See, I told you.
Our Hog is so dead.
There's no way.
Please, don't let Desire touch me!
Oh, my god.
He was so low though.
AHHHHH!
THE LAME TOUCHED ME!
One bubble.
Jesus Christ, leave me the fuck alone!
Oh.
Okay, at least I'll have transfer grab.
They won't expect me here.
I'm gonna use full hot.
Probably swap out real quick.
HOW?!
HOW DID HE KNOW?!
WHAT?!
Oh, he saw my little foot.
But why would he go there?!
Why the fuck would he go there?!
I told you, I knew it.
I knew I was getting targeted.
I knew it.
There was no other reason.
I fucking knew it.
Nobody believed me when I said I got targeted.
There's literally no other explanation.
There's no other explanation.
There's literally no other explanation, guys.
How else?
How dare you steal my kills?
Bitch, you're kidding me.
I got the nano.
I deserve the kills.
YEEEEEAAAHHHHH!
I believe.
Start believing, guys.
You gotta keep on believing!
you gotta keep on believing!
This is it.
Okay, I'm gonna throw a little less.
Maybe with a Gyrocall?
No, I think my Zen was okay.
My Zen was okay.
Don't stop believing.
Okay, maybe I'll go Kiriko.
Maybe we need the heals.
I think we need the heals!
What was my Kiriko win rate?
Like, at least 50?
To be fair, you can get a negative win rate and be top 500 now, apparently.
Please, Doki, I wanna go to sleep.
Sleep?
I wanna go to sleep.
This is not the Goodnight Dragoon stream.
What are you talking about?
Free us, Doki!
Don't worry.
I have...
Oh!
Good thing I went!
Okay, it's good that I went.
It's good that I went Kiriko because they went... they have Ana.
So I have to go Kiriko for the cleanse.
That was a hit.
It was a visual bug.
It's crazy that we're experiencing all kinds of visual bugs right now.
It's absolutely... How unlucky are we?
Like, wow!
All these visual bugs of things that hit but didn't show up?
Like, holy shit!
How is this possible?
Wait, what the... Bro, what?
Holy shit!
We need to call an exterminator with all these bugs you're encountering, Doki!
I'm so sad.
We're so... Damn, we're just that unlucky!
Guys, this...
I'm honestly just waiting for the fucking end.
Holy shit!
You got it!
Boom!
Cleansed!
Did my job.
I am happy.
It's not Doki-M anymore if I'm winning.
It's reality.
I wonder if they'll expect me doing this all the way through.
Let the kitsune guide you!
Oh yes.
WOOOOOOAAAHHHHH!
Oh my god!
AHHHHHHHHH!
Climbed!
Ooh ooh ah ah.
Easy.
Reality is often disappointing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Is Overwatch a game we're playing if you're not a streamer gaining income from playing it?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you thank you.
Yes.
But like...
But don't play too long or you're gonna turn out like me with a...
with a not addiction and I can quit at any time.
I can quit any time.
They have fucking Sigma.
Bro they have Sigma.
Oh shit.
What is going on?
Prove it.
I can quit whenever I want.
I just chose not to quit right now.
Guys.
I can pick and choose.
It's just right now I chose not to.
I'm escaping.
Guys?
Oh no.
Sorry I'm creating a...
I come back on Doom.
I'm running away.
Okay watch this.
I...
shit on you.
Alright.
Guys I don't...
Actually I'll be back in time.
I don't...
whaaaaat!
I knew it.
Fucking math.
Math should be banished.
Fuck math.
This is why math is terrible.
We should get rid of math so we can...
if we get rid of math we won't have physics.
If we get rid of physics we won't have gravity.
We just want to make this game a little longer.
Life does not need gravity.
I rather we float out from the... I float from on earth and then into the space so then we can go to space.
Oh my god.
My fingers felt weird there.
See?
Not me.
Poor guy.
Fine.
I saved the Ana.
We're fine.
Did my job.
What the fuck?
Whoa!
I'll save you from mass!
Jesus Christ.
Just missed.
Fine.
We're fine.
We're so fine.
Please get one kill.
What?
She's one.
ONE!
She's one!
Oh no.
She was so low.
Feedback acknowledged.
I'll choose Alcalism over Auradon!
Guys!
C9!
No!
Thank god!
Bro!
Holy shit!
That provides them with nothing.
I can quit.
Where is he?
No, I lost him!
Oh my god!
He fucking floated around!
Like a fucking butterfly!
I couldn't see where he was!
Easy.
That was so fucking easy.
Oh no.
Where is he?
Okay, we got it.
I might be slowly losing HP, but we got it.
And another win!
Longest win streak an Overwatch 2 player has ever got.
Four.
It adds up.
It keeps adding up.
It keeps adding up, guys.
Wait, what?
Holy shit, that's so sad.
Oh my god.
Where did he go?
There's me.
Did you see me?
I was right there.
Did you see me there?
Guys.
Guys, we just... Guys.
Guys, remember... We started from the bottom.
Guys, we started from the bottom!
Remember who you were!
Remember where you feel like you belong.
Select your hero.
Remember where you came from.
Alright.
Let's see.
What do we do?
This is my origin story.
Okay.
This is it.
You know what?
No.
This is where we prove all the haters wrong.
This is where we pay all... We prove all the haters wrong.
Fight side!
Thank you for the Akasufa!
Thank you!
Here's the insurance for hopefully the last game.
I believe in Doki.
Thank you for the Akasufa.
Thank you.
Doki, don't get overca... No, this is it.
I prove all the haters wrong.
I might have a negative win rate on Kiriko.
But this is where I make it positive.
Wait, actually... Like how...
How fucked am I?
This is where we're gonna make it 35% win rate!
This is it!
Oh my god.
Have confidence.
Have the confidence.
They're on Maga.
Kill me.
I got free relevant.
It's fine.
This is it.
Okay, I actually might have to go Zenyatta because they have Maga.
100% confidence right here.
You gotta have the confidence.
Oh my god, he was so low.
Okay, I wanted to die there so I can play this character.
No TP.
Guys, there's a reason why I died.
I wanted to play Zenyatta.
Guys...
This is...
This was the strategic swap here.
I had to die so I could do this.
Big kill.
So I could do this, guys.
I could use a hand.
It was all strategic.
Oh my god, he's so low though.
He's so low though.
Someone please!
Oh, that's really not good.
Oh, that's not good.
That is not good for us.
Oh my god.
Oh my god!
There was no...
I'm nano'd and I immediately die anyway?
Woo!
This is it.
This is fine.
I got the Maga, guys.
It's fine.
I got the Maga.
Guys, I got the Maga.
It's fine.
I got my one.
Oh my god.
That was scary though.
He has Wallace.
There's no way he knows I'm down here.
We already have Link, Trance!
Winneba.
We don't need him.
We don't need her.
We need Mido.
Guys, I'm just gonna slowly walk over to our Hog.
Guys.
Guys, I told you.
We do not need them.
Oh god.
We could kill Maga.
No, thank you.
No!
What the fuck is going on?
What is going on?
Where is my team?
Oh my god!
Where was my team?
Where did my team go?
No!
Where did our team go?
Okay, guys.
Guys, it's not because I went...
Guys, I think...
I think...
I think me going...
Oh my god.
I think me going Kiriko cursed the game.
I think it cursed the game, guys.
I think it cursed the game.
Okay.
As long as I...
Guys, I'm scared.
I'm stuck.
Guys, I'm actually stuck.
It's not noticeable, but I definitely don't know how to position a Zenyatta.
Is it noticeable, guys?
It's not, right?
Bitch.
Woo!
Hey, Mog, I'm coming up to you.
I'm dead!
No!
There are so many people there!
Guys, I don't think that one is.
Oh my god!
He lost the fight?!
What?!
Guys, it was a nice... it was a pretty cool win streak though, not gonna lie.
I think the win streak was so cool though.
I was like...
Getting that win streak was pretty fucking pog.
Oh!
That's where I lose!
It was... it was a cool win streak.
It was nice.
While it lasted.
You know?
It was... nobody thought we... nobody thought we had it in it.
But we did.
I hate poggers so much.
It was a pretty sick win streak for a while.
It really was.
Why did I pull the Kiriko?
Here we go.
It's not over yet.
We pulled it right here.
It was the other team's fault.
It really was.
Honestly.
Honestly was.
I can't believe it.
Again.
My team and also the enemy team did this to me.
As always!
They always do this to me!
No, no, no.
This is it.
This is where everything changes.
Chat.
Everything changes right here.
I think you need to spend money in the shop so you can boost your Kiriko win rate.
Shit, you're right.
I haven't bought anything in this game for like years.
That makes so much more sense.
Alright.
It's like how else would we lose?
I didn't die though.
All I'm saying is I did not die.
To be fair, I think having a Bastion 1 trick is also sort of like causing stuff.
I'm not gonna lie.
Having a Bastion 1 trick is not helping.
Goodbye Bastion.
Hello.
Hello Bastion.
Don't make me use cleanse.
Oh, I should have used cleanse instead of looking at my Bastion.
Guys, I think I figured it out.
We should absolutely not help our Bastion.
I think... I think I figured it out.
We should help everybody but the Bastion.
Oh, yup.
It's over.
It was so cool though.
Having the record for the highest win streak in Overwatch history.
A swapping 4.
It's so fucking cool.
I've never experienced that before.
Okay.
Here we go.
Woo!
I'm okay.
They're keeping the role of cleanse or TP so we're gonna kill her.
Alright.
See?
I told you.
Guys, it's not okay.
Guys, it's not okay!
You guys, please.
Somebody get rid of the fucking...
Fucking Gonzo.
I knew it wasn't okay.
They still have a Widow up there so don't die to her.
Guess who's gonna die to her.
In 3...
2...
1...
Oh my god.
I don't have an ear anymore.
I don't...
Oh, I'm so incredibly fucked.
Just kidding.
Oh.
Which one is ours and which one is his?
Beautiful.
I'll never know.
Oh.
Goodbye.
No.
Now we have to play this game longer?
What's going on?
Good question.
Maga.
Leave me alone.
Where is he?
Where's the Maga?
I'm so lost.
He's like up here but I don't know if I can climb it.
Don't worry, I got you.
We will get you there!
Somebody is asleep.
Who shot me?
Ba da da da da.
Did you hit anything Bastion?
Judging by you being no one dying I assume no.
Oh my god.
That's fucking crazy.
Ah!
Someone see me.
Oh god.
I just saw the fucking dragon before my eyes.
I'm so sad.
We're fine.
We staggered him.
Where is she?
Nooo!
She TP'd out!
Alright.
We're okay.
I do not have Suzu.
They have Junkrat.
Wait, that's good!
They're giving up!
That means they're giving up, right?
What else?
They're throwing!
Ohhhhhhh!
They were not giving up, guys.
They were not giving up.
They were absolutely not...
Nooo!
I couldn't sneak out!
Alright.
Just before anything happens, I gotta avoid him.
Just in advance.
Oh, now he swaps Reaper?
Ow.
It's okay.
Please!
Get over here!
My ult is literally right there!
Okay.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
We're not fine, but we're still fine.
Oh.
It's fine.
But...
It is not okay!
Okay.
I got you!
Nooo!
I tanked for you!
Get that!
At least!
Wait, he did do it.
That's all I have to say.
I say get a trade at least.
Honestly, I'm okay if we lose this.
So then we don't...
I'm okay if we don't...
I don't think it's winnable.
Oh, no.
Please, someone get close to me.
Someone get close so I can TP.
They definitely have tire.
I can feel the tire coming out soon.
I can feel the tire right now.
There it is.
Oh, it's okay.
One more minute of this.
Here we go.
We're just prolonging the invisible right here.
We're just prolonging this.
Wait, is Junkrat still alive?
How?
Is there someone above us or behind us?
Yeah.
No!
Somebody get him out of there!
Nice, okay.
Somebody got him out.
Alright.
This is it.
Oh, heat.
There's a mug on me?
Thank you.
I sort of was not surprised with the outcome of that ult.
For some reason, I was definitely not surprised with what happened there.
I will wait for Rush before I... I'll wait for us to have Rush before we do.
This is where I am.
Woo!
My ult.
Alright, here you go.
This is it.
I'm gonna do it.
Oh, holy shit!
Alright, bye.
Okay, we both used Cage and Rush.
You're fine!
He's so low!
No!
Please!
He's alive!
Oh my god, I'm...
Oh, okay.
I thought I fell.
I legitimately thought I fell.
Okay, they're not bottom left anymore.
Okay.
It's fine!
Suzu!
It's okay!
It's not okay anymore!
It's not okay!
Oh!
What?!
Okay.
This is okay.
This is...
This...
This is okay.
We can keep going.
It's...
It'll be fine.
It'll...
I'll find my own path.
This is okay.
Dead weight gets left behind.
Whoa, is that an emote?
What the fuck?
It has to be an emote.
What?
This is a long fucking emote.
Does it stop when like he's done walking?
Oh my god.
Wait, that's pretty sick.
I didn't know that was an emote.
Oh yeah, it keeps going until...
Now push him to the door.
Hey.
Okay.
Okay, come on.
It'll be cool if you walk out the door like this.
No!
It would've been so cool!
Okay, not gonna lie, it would've been so funny if he got like headshot.
Oh my god!
What?
What happened to his HP?
Like actually, what happened to his HP?
What the fuck happened to his HP?
Okay.
Oh, it's because they have a widow!
That's why.
Guys, now I'm not so sure anymore.
Okay.
This is okay.
What?
Are you serious?
Oh, this is not okay anymore.
Guys.
There might be...
I personally think they should remove Maga from the game.
This might not be as okay as I expected it to be.
This... is awful.
They used M.O.
It's not as okay, because they have a widow.
Their widow's on fire.
Oh no.
Oh no, it's not okay anymore.
Where's our Ana?!
Oh no, I have to do this to...
No!
Nooo!
Where did our Ana go?
Our Ana was flanking!
Our Ana was flanking so I had to heal it all by myself!
Ana, I needed heals help!
I needed you to help me!
Ana!
Nooo!
Guys, we could have had this match end like 30 minutes ago.
Not gonna lie.
This match could have been over so long ago and I would have killed you in another game!
I could have been in another game by now!
I can't believe your name is egghouse.
It's egghouse.
It's uh...
It's one shot one kill.
It's...
It's... What was the other one?
I already forgot the other one names.
Other stream sniper mode names.
Yay!
It was Slayer.
Already Tracer.
It was Kitsune.
It was...
12 hooks!
3 minutes of this.
3 minutes of a perfect game.
And with my teammates, it is not going to be a perfect game and you all know it.
I don't even want to peek.
Oh.
Oh, it's approaching guys.
Oh, we're trying.
We're trying so hard.
Oh.
Oh no, I don't have Suzu right now.
Oh, this is scary.
Okay.
You have self-heal now.
Now get your self-heal in charge.
They're just waiting.
No!
Oh, it's okay.
Bastion, what are you doing?
Guys.
I think our Bastion was may or may not have been a hero.
That was so just so low.
Like, just maybe.
Just say maybe.
Just a reversal.
There's no way.
I got a Bastion one trick and they gave me a reversal.
I got a Bastion one trick and they're giving me a reversal?
How is this fair?
It's okay guys.
I achieved something that has never been achieved in Overwatch history.
In Overwatch 2 history.
A four game win streak, guys.
This has never been done before.
I got a four game win streak, everybody.
I...
It truly was...
It truly was unstoppable.
The first one.
The very first Overwatch 2 player to achieve such a feat.
We were so close.
The four game win streak right here.
Live for all of us to see.
Is that crazy?
Select your hero.
Alright.
It's okay.
I avoided the Bastion one trick.
We will never have to deal with that shit again.
I hope.
Never again.
Will I have to deal with this.
Yo, yo, yo.
How you guys doing?
What's up man?
I'm doing amazingly.
On a win streak.
Feeling fantastic.
You ready to lose?
Wait, what?
Absolutely not.
Not on my watch.
What?
Go.
I'm not doing anything that I do.
I refuse.
You have to go down to go up.
Exactly.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Exactly.
How's it going?
I'm in charge.
This is it.
Two games in a row.
There's no way we could fail.
We can do this.
Seems more likely than you think.
Chat.
Seems more fucking likely than you think.
Two.
One.
Attackers incoming.
Defend objective A.
Don't keep each other safe.
Don't fret.
I see you.
Junker queen soldier Hanzo.
No!
No, I have to... What?
How did that hit nobody?
Okay.
Some of these... I blame ping.
I'm going high ground.
There's no way.
Enemy seen.
Oh, they're all high ground.
Oh, god.
We're fine.
Hey, there is a Kiriko over there.
MP!
Yay!
Oh, not yay.
Not yay, guys.
Not yay.
It has not been... It's not yay anymore.
I have never felt so un-yayed in my life.
I keep you up.
Wee.
Okay, I should not go.
Marga!
They're on Marga!
Please, can I experience joy?
Am I allowed to experience joy and happiness?
It's okay.
We're killing these guys.
They don't know I'm here.
They don't know.
That's the...
Guys.
I did so much.
I did.
I actually...
I actually solo killed the soldier.
Please.
The soldier.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe it.
I see you.
Here it comes.
Okay, I should be able to head high ground, right?
There's no way somebody will just be like peek-a-boo and then run at me.
Yep, I knew it.
I knew I'll be fine.
Are you...
Oh.
He was not able to climb back up, guys.
It was...
That team...
They're so fucking...
Where?
Oh my god.
Because you wanted me to...
Please.
No!
Guys.
I don't know what to do.
I'm not finished.
Why is everyone so spread out?
Why?
Alright.
They used...
So, I'm gonna live here now.
I live here.
This is my home.
Oh no, I have to reload.
It's okay, I hit those!
I'm just going.
I live here now.
I'm just going to back up a bit.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Wait, they capped?
Wait, when did they cap?
I didn't even notice.
I actually did not even notice we capped.
I'm dead.
JK, I'm alive.
We're still back.
I'm alive, bitch.
Okay, here we go.
I'm so scared.
I'm so...
Alright.
Fuck it.
It was worth it.
It was...
I know I could have waited for the nano... for the blade.
But I can't be bothered.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Ash.
Please, please, please.
Alright.
Okay, they're going to have maga ult and then we're fucked.
As long as I'm not next to him, we should be fine, right?
As long as we're not next to...
They also have...
Not only do they have maga ult, they also have blade.
But it'll be okay, right?
Not only do they have blade, but they also have soldier ult.
But we'll be fine, right?
I hope so.
We'll...
We'll be so fine.
Stand up straight.
Oh, this is it.
I couldn't... Oh, this is it.
This... Oh, goodbye.
Okay, they use rush and maga and blade.
I could...
I could see my life flash by.
There.
I saw it.
I saw my life flash before me, right there.
Exactly at that moment.
We also have nano.
Yeah, we have nano.
Oh no.
No!
It's because they went maga!
I'm so close.
It was so close.
We were so close.
They still had blade.
No, we had blade.
This team is the anti-fun police.
Oh my god, fuck you, play.
Zediana.
I hate maga so much.
We were this close.
We were this close, everybody.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
We were right there.
We were right there!
This is the comeback.
Surely, this is the comeback, right?
Surely, this is it.
We will get everything back here.
Right here, right now.
My sanity is perfectly healthy.
My sanity.
I can change heroes.
I can't.
This is it.
Is it Maga?
Is it...
I almost got headshot there.
Where is he?
He's actually so low though.
I think it's actually not fair.
How low he was.
Oh my god.
I'm trying my best to keep them up right now.
Oh god.
I'm just gonna stay here for now.
Woah woah woah woah woah woah woah.
Chill chill chill chill chill.
Chill chill chill.
Alright.
Okay, I discord Maga.
It's over.
It's fucking over.
I discord him.
It's so... Okay, he got rid of my discord.
But I'll discord him again.
And then it'll be over.
I discord him here and then it'll be over.
Oh my god.
He's dead.
Woah!
Okay.
I'm trying.
Alright.
He can get rid of my discord.
That's five.
Let the Kitsune guide you!
Nice.
He got him where he wanted.
Thank god.
Where else would he want?
There you go.
That soldier still has ult.
He's going up.
What is he gonna do?
Drop down?
He dropped down.
Where's he going?
Where's he running at?
How the trip never stops on and on and is beyond insane.
This is it!
Is that...
Okay, he's still playing Maga.
There's no way.
There you go.
But I'm gonna... I'm gonna die soon.
Holy shit.
I just know I live for a very long time.
Neither of our HPs are moving.
Oh, I know for sure your HP is going down.
I've got you in my sights.
Oh, our Genghis is dead, right?
Yep.
He was behind me this entire time.
The soldier's Omega infant.
Never mind.
Oh, he's fine.
Wait, what?
He has discord!
He's so losable!
Oh, he got him.
He got big health pack.
They're about to attack.
I can farm this.
Alright, let's hope they do the thing.
Guys?
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm okay.
Good job.
I'm so okay.
Oh!
I told you.
I told you guys I'd be okay.
Look at those dinks.
I knew it.
Go Kiriko, go!
Go!
You go!
You go heal!
Go Kiriko!
You better heal, I'll put that me!
I have no legs!
I have to fucking sit here!
Oh my god, that's embarrassing.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
I'm so sorry.
Go Kiriko.
I have to go.
I'm so sorry.
I should have fought you before!
I have to fight!
Kiriko, you are being a bitch!
Get the fuck out of here!
I'm gonna- Okay.
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
We do this again.
Oh, we do this again.
It's okay.
We do this again.
Yeah, they wasted Blade as well!
Alright.
Okay, everything is not the best.
But we can...
We can just, you know, cope for a little bit.
Oh, I love hearing that thing.
Oh my god, everybody is low!
I don't know who to look at!
Everybody is low and I'm scared!
It's okay, I got Rush before... I mean not Rush, Cage before he died.
Yeah, I got Blade too.
Pulse.
Yeah, I have...
Ulti soon.
Look, all I'm saying is...
If we have time, I'll swap to Ana.
Okay.
There we go.
I need to get my fucking ult in time.
Oh!
Nice!
Go!
No!
Get her!
That is so embarrassing!
No!
I just got Trans!
I can't believe it.
I literally just got Trans.
I was like the deal breaker here.
I literally just got it too.
Oh no.
They have Mogul.
They have Mogul!
Oh, woah, woah, woah, woah!
Oh, hell no!
Oh, get out, get out, get out!
Leave, leave, leave!
No!
We lost our Hanzo!
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice!
That's a good kill!
They have...
...Rosh and Gage.
We have to get in the... I have Trans!
Just make sure I live!
Oh, they have Blade too.
Which is...
Oh, god, no.
They have Blade, guys.
Guys.
They have Blade.
So, like...
There we go.
Oh!
Don't touch my team!
How is he alive?!
Oh, my god.
This is bad.
This is so bad.
Oh, my god!
I kicked him off!
That Turkey Kick!
That's the only way!
That was the only way!
I got aesthetic legs for the win!
The thing is...
I don't know if I should play...
I don't know if I should fucking play Ana or Zen.
Because they've both been working so well!
I can't believe it.
I kicked him off.
Holy shit.
Nothing ventured, nothing gained.
This is it.
This should be it.
My mother trained half our team.
I'll sign the rest of you up for lessons.
Can I stick with Zen?
Play Zen?
Okay.
But we could build Nano!
But we could build...
We could build Nano though.
I feel like I should play Ana for the Nano.
I'm going to go for the Nano.
The Nano for the...
The Nano for the... you know...
The Genji Blade.
It might be worth it.
Just think of the plan.
This is why I want Ana.
They have no QZ.
Oh no.
No!
The Torbjorn!
If it was Zen...
If it was Zen, it would not have mattered.
I'm going to say...
Genji, do you think you can get Sombra for this?
It would not have mattered if I was Zenyatta.
A Junkrat?
You don't have to touch.
You may move now or not to touch.
Attack!
Zen could have kicked away.
It would not have mattered.
All I'm saying...
More than.
I have to reload.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Zen would have kicked.
Guys, it would not have mattered if I was...
Zen
would have kicked.
I almost have ult too.
I'm just going to reload just in case.
I'm a little scared.
Not going to lie.
What is going on?
I told you!
Beautiful.
Trust the nano!
What the f...
Same.
What the f is happening?
What the f?
You...
Maga?
They have Zen.
Okay.
Ladies and gentlemen, I need some support ults.
Maga.
I wish I could heal the tire.
Oh, god.
Oh, God.
Oh my god!
War is returned there!
There were so many things!
Why were there so many things?
Okay.
Now the question is...
Zen or Ana?
I'm gonna go Zenyatta.
The trans.
The trans might be clutch.
The trans could be clutch.
That's all I'm saying.
This could be it.
We might need this for the trans.
I like the mp.
We're so close.
Guys, we're almost there.
I think the craziest part is this might be the longest stream I've done on this channel so far.
I don't have a problem.
I can stop at any time.
So far, yes.
I swear I can stop.
Resident Evil was 7 hours?
But don't worry.
I have something to say...
It's not about the gaining of ELO's.
It's about the friends we made all along.
Okay, he got fucking deleted.
Oh my god!
Big damage.
They're on Bastion now.
Christ.
And they're on Hanzo instead of Genji.
That damage was crazy.
What friends did you make?
You guys!
Someone's gonna be like, you?
Paralysis?
Parasocialist?
You guys!
Guys!
Okay,
I got it.
Nice.
That's okay.
Parasocial Andy!
Woah!
Woo!
She's still up top?
Here we go.
We're alive!
Don't you beat Parasocial!
I am uncomfortable!
I'm killing myself.
Woah!
I'm sorry, but I prefer you as a streamer.
What the fuck?
Woah.
He's still up top in our spawn.
He's one more on top.
It's okay, guys!
My Discord is still on him!
I think?
We did it!
Oh my god, we actually did it.
Holy shit!
We actually did it.
Kick them off, boy.
Doki, come on!
Kick them off, boy!
Give us the content!
Look at me.
There's me.
Do you guys see me?
There I am!
I'm over here.
Do you see me?
I'm on the news!
Just like BBC News.
We're going to beat the longest win streak.
Oh my god.
It was unexpected?
How?
I'm going to use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
How is that unexpected?
I'm back.
Oh!
I hate this map!
No!
Out of all the maps, there had to be this one.
Out of every single one of the maps, there had to be this map!
No!
And he's on Lucio!
Okay, this is it.
Guys, no.
The reason why I'm playing Kiriko is because I have to.
I'm playing Kiriko because I have to.
Because he's on Lucio.
Yo, yo, yo.
How you guys doing?
Wait, but I could play Ana.
Final boss Nuchucks.
What's wrong with it?
Nuchucks City is fucking terrible.
That's what's wrong with it.
It's a terrible map.
I hate this map.
It's the worst map they've ever made.
If any Blizzard devs are watching this right now, I love every map.
I love every map.
Oh my god!
Okay.
Okay, funny story.
Okay, this is like a little embarrassing too.
But like...
Hahaha!
Oh...
We already lost.
Okay, I'll tell the story later.
I'm leaving you guys on the cliffhanger.
Funny story.
There you go.
That's all.
Hahaha!
If only you'll know what the story was.
I guess you'll never know.
It's too bad you'll never know.
You'll never know what the story was, guys.
Oh my god.
Guys!
There's a Jugrat behind us!
So funny.
Hahaha!
Okay, guys.
Alright.
Doki, please.
We can't keep affording pain.
Your hatred is our key.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, funny story.
I don't remember when this was.
I think this was like one or two years ago.
Or something.
And I got invited to do a testing of Overwatch 2.
I think it was like...
Like a testing of...
Not testing.
Oh yeah.
Sorry.
It was some fucking in-house scrims or something.
With...
With a bunch of Overwatch content creators.
And I was like, oh cool.
I didn't stream it because I was tired.
So then I joined it.
What I didn't realize is that...
Devs were...
Hahaha!
Devs were part of it.
So I didn't realize this.
And then so one of the content creators...
Was asking for my opinion...
On Overwatch 2.
And I straight up was like...
I don't know.
It's just Overwatch 1.
It's just the maps are different.
Except like, oh you know.
Just the maps are like a little different.
Like oh, one of the maps is just like nighttime and daytime.
And then all my team was...
Hahaha!
All my team were Overwatch devs!
Can we save now for uh...
H?
Hahaha!
I think like...
So...
Yeah, that...
That was a Doki moment right there.
It was...
Yup.
That's a...
And then...
And then I remember one of the content creators was like...
Well, obviously...
Like uh...
This guy is the developer.
Maybe he could take that as...
Feedback.
And I was like... Oh shit!
I was just like...
Oh wait!
Devs are here?
Devs are...
Devs are part of the fucking scrims?
Oh!
This is a...
Certified Doki moment.
Very...
Definitely.
I would have logged off...
And changed my name!
Hahaha!
I was like... It's just Overwatch 1.
Like I was like...
That's what I said!
I was like... It's just Overwatch 1.
Like the maps are just like...
Like... Oh!
There's new maps but it's just like...
Daytime and nighttime.
Hahaha!
Oh!
It's me.
Can you kill the Larry?
You weren't lying!
So yeah...
That was...
The hated Doki because she told the truth.
I can't believe it.
I got baited.
I got baited into saying my thoughts.
Because...
When the Conicators asked for my opinion.
And then I didn't realize...
I didn't realize...
It was...
We had devs in the team.
Oh my god!
Let's go!
Just fine.
Get baited, nerd.
Hahaha!
I got set up!
I got fucking set up!
Oh!
This is a little awkward.
Hahaha!
Thanks!
Whoa!
He's like one hit.
Oh shit!
No!
Don't look at that!
Nice!
Literally left him.
Oh!
There's a Weedo.
Feel the Weedo.
Okay, we got this.
Oh!
Poor Lucio.
I'm heading over to the point.
We got it.
Oh, I hear them.
Oh!
He got baited!
Just like how I got baited into Shintaka Overwatch in front of devs!
Hahaha!
Almost the same thing.
I'm not even gonna say anything.
I'm just gonna say...
Oh yeah!
Oh yes!
Hahaha!
Almost the same thing.
Now he knows your pain.
The thing is, it wasn't one Overwatch devs.
It was like two Overwatch devs on my team.
So...
Hahaha!
And this is when Overwatch 2 just came out.
That was like...
It gets... I like how at the moment, I'm like...
The more I talk about this, the worse it gets.
It was when it just came out too.
It was even more awkward.
Did they say anything?
I don't remember.
I was so embarrassed.
I...
I was so embarrassed with everything that happened.
I actually don't remember.
No!
It's okay.
I need to play Kiriko anyway.
Because they went fucking Ana.
Life flash before your ass.
That's fine.
The blackout from anxiety.
The rush that you involved.
Bro, block the memories.
You would block the memories too!
What do you mean?
Hahaha!
Imagine!
Oh yeah!
Yeah, just something similar.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I called the playtesters and some of the devs.
And Apex bots.
Because I was like...
Oh my god!
You guys are real play...
Oh shit.
Because I got invited to an Apex playtest.
And then...
I was just like...
I was like... wait, these are real people.
Because like... I thought like...
people on my team and also like the people...
on the enemy teams were like...
bots.
Like actual bots.
And then I realized... wait a minute.
They're actually like sort of communicating in text.
And I was like... are you guys real pe...
Oh my god!
You guys are real fucking divas.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna go here and then...
slash.
Woah.
Yeah, I go soon though.
Oh no.
We'll be fine.
Someone needs to touch.
Can we touch this thing?
We'll be fine.
I have the TP but we'll be fine.
Okay.
Oh my god.
He's going all the way over.
He's going around the world.
Around the world.
We did it!
We fucking did it!
It's over!
We ended on NewJunkCity while telling a story.
This is the game I've tried the least.
And we won.
I can't fucking believe it's over.
It's fucking over.
Jeez.
That's the last game for me.
It's actually over.
Oh my god.
We did it.
And so...
Overthinking was...
was the answer.
We did it.
I told you we'd be in Masters.
Guys.
I fucking told you.
I told you.
No clickbait.
There was no clickbait chat.
It actually happened.
I was here.
Oh my god.
Sean, thank you for the machete.
Thank you.
Congrats.
We all know you can do it.
Now here's the insurance for the real content to take placement.
Guys.
I'm like...
I don't hate myself that much.
I might hate myself enough to play seven hours of Overwatch.
But not to the point where I play tank.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Guys.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
The head empty Zatsu buff is real.
Thank you to the super chat.
Thank you.
Daniel.
Welcome to the Romina farm.
Welcome.
We did it guys.
The insurance finally paid off.
We did it.
The insurance paid off chat.
I told you, Bacon.
Bacon, you were there.
Unless Bacon went to sleep.
Bacon, you were here.
I like to thank Bacon for sponsoring my insurance.
The last couple of games.
And also to all the other dragoons that betted against me.
And tried to gamble with my games.
And also to the dragoons that sponsored my insurance as well.
I have a lot of fans.
I would like to thank them all.
Johnny, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All Dokyu had to do was relax her yap muscles and easy win happens.
Simple as...
Two shout out to like Ruben for playing... for playing with me, for asking to play with me and then...
And then my actual insurance was Ruben.
Yeah, never doubted for a second.
Yeah, yeah, sure.
That's fucking right.
Yeah, you totally never doubted me.
At all.
I definitely believe all of you.
Nothing.
Thank you.
Thank you for the one get the chip.
Ruben the Gopher playing six hours straight with you.
But Ruben streams 15 to 18 plus hours of Overwatch.
Playing six hours with me for him is nothing.
He solo queues 15 plus hours sometimes and like...
That's like different from what he does with me.
Tang, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
We don't need sleep play.
It's okay.
It's okay Tang.
We have we have another stream today in an hour and a half guys.
In an hour and a half, we have stream number two, everybody.
But for now, we are free from Overwatch.
Is this actually the longest stream?
This is the longest stream I've ever done.
Audio, thank you for the five gifted chips!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm gonna check.
Is this actually?
Okay.
LGS...
This is the longest stream I've ever done.
This is actually the longest stream I've ever done is, of course, Overwatch.
I'm not even tired from Overwatch.
I honestly...
If I didn't have a second stream, I'd keep going.
But like...
But I have a second stream.
So I'm gonna call it here, everybody.
I hope you guys all had a great time hanging out with me for the Overwatch section.
We still have a second stream tonight with Goodnight Dragoons.
But anyway, everybody.
As always, everyone stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Or see you guys in the next second stream.
Bye, everyone!
Bye!